Hello!
Hello everybody!
Good morning!
Oh yeah, good morning to you guys.
It's like 8pm for me.
Good night to you, though.
Good morning!
Welcome to the girl squad.
We are the top 500 girl squad.
Hiro is top 500 in our hearts.
In your hearts, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
She's at least top 500 in my heart.
Well, at least in your heart.
Most important, right?
Yeah, that's most important.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
In Ditto's heart, too.
In Ditto's heart, you're like rank 500.
But in my heart, you're like top 10.
Wow, what a difference in treatment.
Yeah, Ditto.
That's so messed up.
Why is she only 500?
I didn't say that.
You didn't say no.
You didn't argue.
Oh my god.
You accept it.
You let me say it.
It's too late to say.
It's too late to defend yourself?
Oh my god.
That means I was right.
No, you're not.
You're not.
Friendship is never too late.
She's my top T.
Top T.
Wait, what am I?
You're a top 1000.
What?
You don't even have a thousand friends.
That's...
That's so sad.
You don't even have a thousand friends.
I can't deny that.
Because I don't have... I don't have... I don't have a thousand friends.
Yeah, then why am I...
I don't even have ten.
You don't even have ten, but on top of a thousand?
That's so fucked up.
That's so...
That's because I played Power World with her recently.
I was supposed to be there, but I fell asleep.
I fell asleep.
That's not fair.
It was my idea too.
I had to.
I had the idea to play...
Yeah, I was like...
Yeah, I was like, oh, where does she keep coming?
No, IGL, you're the highest rank.
What?
You're the highest rank.
We are all paid.
You're silver one.
I'm silver three.
It's not that different from Super T.
It's two tiers different.
It was the same.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys, how's the volume?
I don't know if Sound Guy's alive, so...
My other mod, it's your job to balance now.
My other mod has to balance.
Is that Predator Trail?
That's my Pred Trail.
It's the legacy one.
Oh my god.
Please carry me.
It's the legacy trail.
Carry me.
No, Silver One has...
You guys are...
Silver One has to carry.
I have one RP right now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and we have a Silver One player.
She's so good at this game.
Oh my god.
She's Silver One.
Ditto.
How did you get to Silver One?
I don't feel like I'm playing any base.
You don't feel like you're playing what?
What are you playing?
Oh my god.
Maybe I play too much CZZ.
You play too much CZZ?
Oh my god.
Oh no, she can't aim anymore.
She can't aim.
Okay.
I...Okay.
You're washed.
I feel weird.
Honestly.
You too.
I feel weird.
Two games, two games.
We're washed, guys.
Guys, we used to be like the Apex girls!
Guys, we used to be like the Apex girls in our country!
What happened?
What happened to us?
Oh my god, my chat's not...
Okay.
My chat's not showing.
You have autosprint on?
I do too.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
You guys have autosprint on?
Yeah, I'm lazy.
Yeah, that's the least.
Yeah.
I'm lazy.
You don't?
You're actually...
It's the first time I've heard you have autosprint on.
I've been autosprinting since season two.
Wow.
What a pro.
I know.
I'm just lazy.
There's no reason to walk.
In rank, you don't walk.
You don't walk in rank.
You don't walk?
I walk.
We don't.
Yeah, because you're always W keying.
You know?
You're always W keying.
If it's competitive, yeah, in competitive you have to walk.
Because you're sneaking up on people.
I walk right now.
In competitive, I don't walk.
You don't walk.
That's why we die.
Okay, I'm gonna walk the entire time then.
That's not your fault?
Yeah.
Alright, next week.
Isn't it... Don't you have a tournament next week?
No.
You guys... You guys die before I die.
Oh, okay.
Bet.
So that's not my fault.
Alright.
Here, you heard that?
She said we die before her.
You hear that?
Sad.
I'm lifelike.
That means somebody's not getting res.
Oh my god.
It's so... Yeah.
Pins, pins, pins.
Yeah, please what?
Please don't die.
What do you mean?
I never die!
I'm lifelike.
We will see.
We will see?
We will die first.
You're literally Pathfinder.
I like how we did not...
Oh wait.
What can you scan?
This is a people scanner, right?
Yeah.
Nothing is a rig scanner.
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, we're so washed.
I don't even remember.
I forgot how to open the map.
Okay.
Did you play too much C-C-C?
We can't counter...
I feel like Pathfinder is so slow.
Why is he moving so slow?
You picked Pathfinder.
What do you mean?
I feel like...
He moves really slow.
Are you sure you have auto run on?
Are you...
Yeah.
Are you on past 60 frames?
Are you...
Oh, look at me.
Look at me, look at me.
Is he wrong?
You're walking!
Oh, okay.
Okay, I missed you.
Okay.
I don't know what happened.
Oh my god.
I need to up here.
I don't know what happened to you.
Wait, there's somebody here?
Oh no, guys, I need to raise up here.
Okay, I sound guy, raise up here.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Okay, over there.
Okay, I knew it would be closer.
I can't...
Dina, how could you not tell you were walking?
How did you not see that?
I'm gonna...
grab a package.
Dina, what happened?
Dina, where...
He's hiding.
Guys, guys, give me a sec, I'm looting.
Give me a sec, I'm looting.
Okay, okay.
He's hiding.
Where?
Where is he hiding?
He's down here.
Oh, I see him.
Wait, let me revive her.
Razor, Razor, Razor.
Yeah, I'm hacking up to you.
Okay, you got Razor here.
You got instant rez, remember, you're crypto.
Wait, they're like pushing me.
It's okay, just Razor.
Okay, it's okay, we'll use her as bait and then she can die again.
It's okay.
Doki can do 1v2.
They're running away, I can do 1v3.
Why?
They ran away after killing you.
They caught me.
They caught me and they ran away.
There's another team.
Okay, we can go to it.
I'm going left side.
I'll gamma to A-Scope and I'll follow you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ditto, what happened?
You died first.
Ditto.
No, Doki.
They were hiding.
He was hiding.
I don't know.
Did you see a hero?
Was he hiding?
Well, I think they're scaring.
I think those are excuses.
It's okay.
It's because she was walking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Honestly, you're right.
You're right.
I can't walk.
It's okay.
Ditto, it's okay.
It's okay to die first.
We know every Pred player makes mistakes.
No, no, no.
Oh, you don't make mistakes?
No.
I don't because I'm the best player.
Oh, it depends on your IGL.
Yeah.
Alright, IGL.
What do you want to do?
What should we do, IGL?
Okay, we go.
We go landslide.
I'm behind you.
Okay, look, give me battery.
Give you battery?
Okay.
Here.
Okay, nice.
Let's go.
Even I don't have a battery.
I had two.
You could have.
You should have asked.
I had two.
It's okay.
Wait, how did Ditto know I had battery?
I don't know.
I just asked you.
Oh my gosh.
She has...
She has inventory walls.
Oh my gosh.
She's...
She's cheating.
She has walls.
You can only look at...
Kayla, do you want battery?
I brought up the game volume a little bit.
Sound guy.
Follow me.
We're following.
Wait, they're actually there.
We go here.
There's a team in front of me.
It's okay.
I will cover you guys.
Guys.
I fucked up.
I broke his armor.
Yeah, I broke one armor.
I broke my armor too.
That one's low.
Okay.
Almost okay.
There's two teams.
Two teams.
I'm backing to you.
Last one.
Wait.
I'll EMP them.
Oh my gosh.
They're all split up.
We're fine.
Okay.
We gotta go to zone.
We gotta go.
Believe me.
We gotta go to zone, guys.
Can you move here?
I shocked all of them, by the way.
Nice.
They have to come to us.
They're all here.
Yeah.
They have to come to us.
I think they don't wanna fight us.
Yeah.
They don't wanna fight.
Wait.
Another team.
Yeah.
Another team down.
Okay.
They're coming.
Shoot them in the zip.
Oh my god.
My aim's tight.
Don't kill him.
He's alone.
I got him.
We're a team.
He's cracked.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He's solo.
Okay.
Go there.
Kill him.
I got him.
I hear... late.
Yeah.
Okay.
I loot.
Guys, we'll be fine.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I'm aiming.
I can't.
He's flushed.
Oh.
I did it.
I'm so good.
Wait.
How did...
He's cracked.
He's one.
I'm so good.
Let's go.
I need this one here.
You're so good, guys.
I need like energy.
Okay.
Oh.
Over here in front of me.
Yeah.
He's low.
Oh.
He has the zipline buff.
Oh my god.
Another team.
I got him.
Behind us.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's another team.
I got him.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Oh.
He's low.
Yo.
Come here.
Don't.
Don't go inside the lane.
Come with us.
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
Last one.
I'm here, guys.
Yay.
There's so many people.
Why?
Is there still people?
Why did everybody come to us?
Why?
I don't know.
It's crazy.
It went from zero players to like a hundred.
This is everybody.
Yeah.
Everybody came to us.
Nice.
Okay.
I was not ready for this.
I don't have ammo.
Yeah.
I ran out of ammo during this fight.
I can't hear energy ammo in this boss.
Okay.
Oh.
I need energy.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It was like 200 people just showed up.
I have heal drone for us.
Okay.
I'll put this down.
Oh nice.
It's an armor weapon.
Okay.
We go there.
Uh.
Oh wait.
Where did you guys go?
Oh there you guys are.
Oh there's one team.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
It didn't activate it.
One team?
Where?
Oh behind us.
Behind us.
Okay.
We kill them.
Yeah.
We kill them too.
Okay.
One guy.
Oh my god.
Here.
There's a guy right to our left.
Right to our left.
Okay.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Just give me a second.
Okay.
There's a guy to our left here too.
I'm getting across.
I'm gonna cross here.
Okay.
Let me go EMP them.
They have to come to us.
Fuse.
Almost.
Okay.
I'm looking.
What?
What are you looking?
I got him.
Nice one.
Okay.
They don't have a time.
They have to come to us.
Oh.
They're ulting.
They have to go this way.
Here.
They're here.
I'm watching.
I'm watching too.
No.
They went there.
They should cross here.
I'm waiting.
Oh.
Nice.
I'm pushing.
I'm pushing up.
Wait.
I'm lifeline frontlining.
This one.
This one is cracked detail.
Oh.
Shit.
What the fuck?
Shoot.
Dead?
Where's the last guy?
I'll meet.
All dead.
Nice.
We're so good at this game, guys.
Yeah.
It's so good.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
We should be like a team.
Like an actual team, guys.
What the hell?
Yeah.
Guys.
We good.
We're so good against these silver players.
Oh my god.
I... I...
I feel bad for them.
I don't.
They should.
Okay.
I know.
I know you wouldn't.
They should stay in this area.
Come here.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Okay.
We go third.
Third party?
Where is it?
One team there.
That's... That's... That's Maljohn.
Alright.
I'm here.
There's four teams.
Four teams.
Four teams?
Okay.
I see him.
In front of me.
They're fighting.
Here.
Flesh.
Whoa.
In front of me.
In front of...
I'm gonna bat.
I'm batting.
Oh.
What the heck?
Dead chibi.
Yeah.
He's one.
Oh.
Nice hit.
Who's shooting me?
Left side.
Here.
Yeah.
Crack.
Oh.
Careful for the ult.
I can't...
I can't see anything right now.
Oh.
I'm pushing up with you.
Oh my god.
Is that your ult?
Oh no.
That's your dash.
I'll scan them.
Oh my god.
They have... They have golden knock.
They have golden knock?
Oh my god.
How dare they.
No.
I won that.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
I should have... Oh wait.
No.
I already have it.
Oh.
There.
Hold on.
On me.
Crack.
There's team 2 left.
Team 2.
That was... That was Crack.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have nade too.
I have to bet.
Yeah.
They're getting shot at.
Oh no.
Wait.
120.
I'm looking.
I'm crossing.
I'm crating across.
Okay.
Got him.
I got him.
Left side.
On left team.
Okay.
Here.
I'm looking here.
Be careful.
Left side of the team.
Okay.
Nice nade.
Got me long.
Okay.
I'm not Bangalore by the way but... Wait.
Someone's here.
Oh.
I don't find...
They're dead.
Okay.
I'm batting them.
Come here.
Anyone here?
He don't help you.
I'm your bat.
Okay.
Got it.
Oh.
Wait.
I'm getting rid of the Watson gen.
Jesus Christ.
This Watson gen is so... I will push this guy.
Okay.
I'm getting my package.
Here.
Yeah.
Wait.
They're all here.
Mirage 1.
Oh my god.
Which one is it though?
Nice.
Full dead.
Two teams left?
Wow.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't have ammo.
Over there.
I see them.
There's a gold rez.
Wait.
They're dead.
Last team.
Only one?
Oh my god.
I don't have heavy ammo.
Yeah.
Go loot.
There's so many bodies.
They're here.
Okay.
I see one guy.
I will.
One guy, one guy, it's one guy.
Oh, it's two guys.
It's two guys, it's two guys.
Oh, noogie fake news.
Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do, huh?
You can't do anything about it.
Wait, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I got you.
They're so low, they're so low.
They're so low.
They're all low, they're all low.
I hit them even though I was distracted.
They're so low, you can't lose this.
They're bad.
Oh my god.
I don't know, I think we're gamers, guys.
That was our first round.
Yeah, that was our first game.
Guys, I helped you guys with the last team.
You're just, you're baiting.
It's okay.
Guys, I was the meat shield.
Yeah, I was the meat shield.
I was the meat shield.
Look at us!
Oh my god, we got 20 kills together.
That's crazy.
Oh, yeah.
We can just requeue here.
Yeah, we don't have to go back.
Oh my god.
Someone in my chat was like, Wow, you guys can get, you guys might be able to get gold.
Really?
Do you think we're good enough for gold?
Oh my god.
They think we're good enough for gold.
I'm gonna get out of here.
I've never been gold before.
Oh my god.
But, dude, you have pets.
No, no, no, I'm not.
I'm silver 2.
I'm silver 3.
I don't know what you're talking about.
No.
I'm just a baby.
Once you have pets, always pets.
No, that's not.
I'm not.
That's not.
Ditto, you literally started, you didn't know what was walk and run.
You're a more recent friend than me.
Why is Pathfinder so heavy?
You were walking for like half, like 30% of that game.
We got out of, we got out of climatizer and you were still walking.
Oh my god.
I missed the same thing.
Yeah, and you were preyed.
Ditto, what happened?
No, I I play too much other games.
But I play other games.
Yeah, I play other games too.
I knew I was running.
No, I haven't been playing baseball for a while.
Almost one month.
I'm gonna, okay, I'm gonna...
I don't believe that.
I'm gonna look at her VODs right now.
Only one week.
I mean one week.
One week.
One or two.
Four days.
What do you mean?
No.
I play only one game.
I play one game and my internet is dead.
Five days ago you still streamed Apex.
Five days.
But that was only one game.
Four days and five days?
Oh, so that's two games and two days.
Yeah, two games.
Two games?
Yeah, so you play more.
One game a day.
Wow.
And yet you still don't know if you're running or walking.
No.
Ditto.
What happened, Ditto?
What happened to you?
My aim is still good.
That's why.
This is so nice.
There's a wingie.
Your aim is still good.
Ditto, if your aim is still good, pick up the wingman.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wait, really?
She said her aim is still great, so she should pick up the wingman.
Yeah.
Okay, I will use the wingman.
Ditto, do you think Ditto is going to hit her shots?
Well...
I believe.
You know what I'll say?
She believes me.
There's no one who believes you, Ditto.
Ditto, if you get most damage, most kills, I'll give you five subs.
Wow.
Only wingman.
Your inventory has to be two wingmans.
Okay, two wingmans.
Okay, find me another wingman.
Yeah, yeah.
If Hiro and I, if Hiro and I, either of us, does more kills and damage than you, you have to give us five.
Hiro, Hiro, you don't have to help Doki just list the two diapers.
Here, you have to kill people too.
You have to shoot people as well.
I'll scan them.
Don't worry.
I'll be helping.
I'll have zero damage.
I'm just scanning them.
Alright.
We need to find another...
We need to find one more wingman.
Not yet.
We need to find one more wingman for...
Wait, I scanned them?
What?
Oh, where?
Where did you scan them?
I don't know.
I can find wingman.
Where's wingman?
Where's another wingman?
We need another wingman for Ditto.
Guys, we can't fight yet until Ditto has two wingmans.
You know Mozambique?
Oh my god, wingman is too weak.
It has only six bullets.
Yeah, but then if you have two, you can't kill them.
If you have two wingmans, then you have twelve bullets.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Just remember, two wingmans, twelve bullets.
It's okay.
I can kill them with two bullets.
Yeah.
I believe in you.
Yeah, you said your aim is so good today.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
You used to be the wingman queen.
Remember?
Okay, okay.
Is that a nickname?
Yeah, when we first collabed...
When we first collabed, her entire thing was about wingman.
Really?
Yeah, she was known for...
Yeah, don't remember?
I don't remember.
He doesn't remember?
Did I say that?
Yeah, you used to be like...
People would be like, oh my god, Ditto and wingman.
Back then.
And you would always play wingman.
Yeah, remember?
It was like three years ago.
You would always play wingman.
Did you misunderstand me with someone?
No.
No, I'm pretty sure.
I am pretty sure.
I can't remember.
When did I say that?
What do you mean when?
Back then when you first got prepped.
You would always hold on to the wingman.
Oh my god, she doesn't remember.
She's getting old.
No, you...
No, no, you're gaslighting me.
I can literally...
Look at your channel.
Really?
Yeah!
I pushed your clips.
I think...
I have been playing SMG and Assault Ivan.
I think she's gaslighting us.
No, you!
You're the one.
No, no, no, you're gaslighting us.
Oh my god.
You used to pick up the wingman all the time.
Your old age is getting to you.
You're getting old, Ditto.
No!
She's gonna be like...
Only 17.
Grandma Ditto.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, grandma.
If I were a grandma, you might be older than grandma.
Oh, I'm older?
No, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Is this that enemy?
Is that enemy?
Let me check for you.
Don't worry, Hiro.
You can check for us.
So far, it is an enemy.
Yeah, that is an enemy.
If you find another wingman, ping me.
Okay, don't worry.
We will.
I wanna have luck.
Oh my god, Ditto is a hag.
Wait, Loba is running.
Oh my god, maybe they're gonna be like...
Wait, I have 0 damage.
I'm gonna scan for you.
Hiro, no!
You need help!
At least get the evil harvester, Hiro.
Get the evil harvester.
Okay.
I can't get it with my drone.
You can?
I thought you...
Oh no.
They have 2 parties.
2 or 4.
You did damage!
No, 0.
Oh my god.
45, 45, 45.
Okay, I can't do anything.
Blue armor, blue armor.
Okay, 90, 90.
Are you making up numbers?
I don't think she's hitting them.
I think she's making it up.
Over there, over there, over there.
We have to back out.
I think that...
There are so many people here.
There's too many, we have to go around.
Why are they focusing us?
I know, why are they focusing us?
I'm backing out.
I think we should go there.
Okay.
I'm here.
I hit landslide.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye.
Lito, stop making up that...
Like when you hit shots, stop pretending you hit them.
Lito, you don't have to pretend, Lito.
I hit them, I hit them.
You can't see my...
You're like, I'm getting gaslit from both of you.
No, I believe.
Hiro, Hiro.
Hiro, in your drone, did you hear...
Did you see her hit them?
Doki is a gaslighting queen.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
She always gaslighting people.
That is not true.
I would never gaslight people.
That's true, that's true.
I'm gonna grab this triple take and then steal your damage.
I have...
Oh my god.
And then grab it.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Let me know if you guys find...
If you guys find a sniper, let me know.
I need one more wingman.
I can find another wingman.
It's okay, we'll find...
We'll find more wingmans for you, don't worry.
I'll find... yeah.
I'll try to find one here.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe there is one.
There has to be at least one, right?
Oh, I hear shots.
Okay.
Still there.
Oh, you found it?
You found it?
Really?
No, no.
Not yet.
Oh, no.
I just got the red armor.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so strong now.
Yeah.
You don't have to shoot.
You already did 2,000 damage.
Yeah, guys.
I already did 2,000 damage.
Guys.
I did 4,000 damage for this red armor.
Wait, there is actually somebody.
Oh, one squad.
Oh.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my god.
Wait, in front of us?
Maybe?
Yeah.
Wait, let me look.
There are two squads.
Two squads.
No, no.
They are not.
No, no, no.
Maybe they are on the left.
Yeah, yeah.
Here.
Yeah.
I hear this way.
Okay, you go first.
Oh, so I could die first.
Is that it?
No, I'm covering you.
Why are you talking?
You know what?
I'm doing this.
I don't see them.
Oh, I see them.
They are on the left.
Oh.
I'm flying to there.
Alright, I'm going to get to the high ground here.
What?
You're joking?
I'm going here.
What?
Where are you?
He was right in front of me.
Wait, we are both not there, Doki.
What the f**k?
Why did you guys...
What?
Why are you sleeping?
They are right here.
They are right here in front of me.
Hey, hey, hey.
Let me EMP them for you.
Wait, I can't.
I can't.
I cracked one.
Oh my god.
I cracked the Bangalore.
They have two.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Should I shock them again?
Oh my god.
Hiro is doing damage.
Hiro is doing damage right now.
I almost cracked one.
Okay, okay.
I'm going behind.
Hiro, we need your help.
Hiro.
You got this.
No, I don't.
Hiro, come here.
Hiro.
Wait, calm down, Doki.
Enough one.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm batting.
Actually, I'm going to thirst him then.
I'm getting his armor.
He has a bow.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Where?
With me.
Whoa.
I got one.
Okay, nice.
Another one.
This is the last guy.
Okay, let me.
Let me.
Here.
What?
Wait, I'll rest you.
I'll rest you.
Wait, there's actually someone else?
What is the point of playing live like this?
I'm going to die.
Get him.
I have gold breath.
Okay, so.
I also have it.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I give you a joke.
Okay, I'm going to die first.
Okay.
Raise me.
Wait, it's so painful.
Cover.
I cracked.
I cracked the Loba.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
He's low.
Okay, slow.
Guys, wait.
No.
She's.
She's toying.
Kill him.
Run away.
Another team.
Yeah.
Another team is shooting me from ten miles away by the way.
I got the most damage by the way.
Thank God.
Yes, I got the most damage.
Did you just raise me?
I was going to.
I had to get armor.
I had to refresh my armor.
Oh, God.
What do you mean?
I did rez you.
Secretly just because we wanted the damage?
She would just knife me and gain only damage.
That's not true.
That is not true.
I knock people if I had to.
Oh, my God.
I got Daisy.
You want me?
Did you raise Quinch?
She is not here.
Oh, wait.
You want me?
I can shine.
She actually raised Quinch.
No.
No, I can't.
Didn't you hear me?
I said I got Daisy.
You got D-C.
Yeah.
I got disconnected.
Yeah, disconnect.
Yeah,
did a disconnect.
I got disconnected.
What happened to your...
Okay, double or nothing.
We can double it.
If you have more damage on Wingman, 10 subs.
10 subs.
Okay.
I only had one Wingman.
That's not my fault.
I will fight you.
You don't help me finding my Wingman.
I found you the first Wingman.
What do you mean?
Hiro didn't find you the second Wingman.
Here.
Oh, God.
Now you get everything.
Yeah.
Now you can't complain.
You can't complain anymore.
Ditto.
All right, double.
Double if you get more damage than Hiro or I.
Double.
I will get more damage this time.
Okay.
I believe you.
All right.
Where do we land, Hiro?
Ditto, where do we land?
We're going to get rid of Dido.
Land somewhere where you can get a wingman.
Oh, okay.
Maybe two teams.
Oh, okay, okay.
There's no teams here.
Yeah.
We can... we can...
Dirt them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then I'll just go here.
Or I'll land here.
We're so split.
I can't believe Dido...
I can't believe Dido rage quit.
Oh my gosh.
No, I said I got D.C.
She's so angry.
I got D.C.
Yeah, yeah.
D.C.
Yeah.
I got this blank then.
It's M.
Yeah, we believe you.
We believe you, Dido.
D.C.
Yeah, of course.
It had to be D.C.
It's D.C.
Of course.
Yeah, yeah.
D.C., D.C.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Next time we play with RPR, okay, I will help RPR.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, you're right, you're right, you're right, you're right.
It is a D.C.
IPR.
I believe you.
That was fun.
No, we have to fight RPR together.
I have not found a wingman yet.
There's a wingman here, there's a wingman here.
Oh, okay, nice.
Where?
Okay, I will go get it.
Okay.
Oh, they're flying.
They're starting.
They are?
Okay.
Yeah, just like flying.
Wait, I don't have wingman.
Yeah, go grab your wingman.
Here.
Okay.
There's three wingmans.
Oh, really?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Go grab it.
Wait, why were you running to me, Ditto?
Wait, whoa.
Ditto was running to me.
She thought I was Hiro.
I saw her like next to me.
I'm running to Hiro.
No, I saw you running to me.
I saw you at the bridge.
I'm so sad.
Why was there a bridge?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe Ditto couldn't remember what Hiro looks like.
Oh.
I remember.
I can't remember.
You said I was your top three.
Yeah, you were top three.
Yeah, you were lying.
It's not lying.
Then why were you at the bridge?
I was farming.
Farming what?
I was there.
A wingman.
Wingman.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Wait, I found one.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
You used the bomb.
It's all over?
Yeah.
Okay, I have one.
I have one wingman.
You're supposed to have two.
No, I got wingman and backpack.
Oh, okay.
So we need another wingman.
Okay, other one.
Other one is fine for now.
They're so angry.
Why are they angry?
Why did you make them angry?
Yeah, why did you make them angry?
So that Ditto can go and kill everybody.
Oh, true, true.
Ditto, why aren't you here yet?
Go, Ditto, the rest.
Now's your chance.
Yeah, now's your chance.
I'm just gonna leave.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, here.
Oh my god, in front of me!
I broke him.
I broke him, Ditto.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
Wait, she's low?
This one's low?
Wait, on me.
This one's low, Ditto.
Can you crawl to me?
Okay, I'm crawling.
Okay, um, okay, come back.
She's raising me.
Alright.
Okay, come back.
Wait, what do you mean come back?
You can do it, Ditto!
I told you I can do it.
I need you guys.
Okay, let me finish him.
I need heroes.
No, no, no!
I hope you get shot.
Wait, she's here.
She's right here.
Okay, he's gonna run.
I'm gonna loot.
You guys...
You kill him.
You need this more than us.
We're gonna loot.
Wait,
did you hear that?
Wait, did you hear that?
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
Wait, he's here!
He's here!
Oh my god!
Only one!
Ditto!
Only one damage!
Ditto, why did you leave us?
He's damaged!
He's...
Ditto, he krapped us!
Okay, okay, okay!
Ditto craft us...
and rez us...
Okay, that was so... that was like...
He just landed on us.
Yeah, we were like, wait a minute... isn't that...
Isn't that like a landing song?
Yeah, is that landing?
Is this the ending?
Did somebody fall on us?
I'm a Rezzy guy here.
Yeah, it's okay.
Rez is here.
They're gonna loot.
Yeah, you can 1v3.
You want that 10 subs.
Yeah, I can 1v2.
Can't believe it.
Ditto hates us.
She left us to die.
No!
They're coming.
They're there.
Where are they?
On the hill.
On the hill?
I didn't see them.
Which one?
Wait, let me think.
Did you actually see them?
Yes, I did actually.
I see them.
Over here.
I hit one.
Oh, she's in it.
Oh, the vantage.
Oh, there's one guy.
Yeah, the vantage is looking at me.
She's looking at me.
I'm backing out.
I want Ditto to be closer to them.
Alright, I'm going.
They're too far.
Yeah, they have to come to us.
Do you wanna go loot?
Yeah, let's get some loot.
Yeah.
I'm backing out.
Wait, what?
Behind is another team.
Okay.
I'll go first.
Be careful.
Here.
It's okay.
We don't take more damage here.
Yeah, we took less damage.
Oh my god!
Mirage!
Wait, why are there so many people?
What do you mean, why is there... It's okay.
He ran to them.
He ran to the team.
In front of me!
Oh, that's a lot.
That's a lot of people.
Is that a Mirage?
On me.
That one?
I got Ditto.
Wait, they're all dead.
Oh my god!
There's more.
Okay.
Yeah.
Be careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's more behind us.
There's more.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm looting so much.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck did they come from?
I'm looting.
Got me.
There was like people there, but they like ran away.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
They like showed up.
They came out of nowhere.
But they looted us.
Yeah.
They're so bad.
Oh my god.
You started it.
You said they lost to us.
No!
I just said they lost to us, but that didn't mean that they are bad.
Oh, they're not bad?
Then what does it mean?
Yeah.
We obeyed them.
True.
They're not bad, but we just We're just better.
We're just better.
We should go to a zone.
The other team ran away.
I'm surprised.
Yeah, they did.
Yeah, they were so scared.
Find me another wingman here.
You're out.
Okay.
Go inside the zone first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need that actually.
I need too many medkits.
I have like a... Oh, there's people in here.
There's people in here.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw a shot there.
I don't have zipline.
I don't know if they're in there, but I saw like a straight shot.
So there was a fight close by.
I think you can do an ult here because you found another wingman here.
They're far.
They're farther there.
Yeah, do an ult here because there's a wingman here.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
You sure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, you know, put ult down.
Okay.
So, they can do another wingman.
Let me see.
There's a team near by the way.
Okay.
No, you mad me.
I'm not scared.
They're like right above here, you know?
Really?
Yeah.
I'll put an ult down.
Yeah, put the ult down.
They're coming to us.
They're coming right here for the ult.
Come here for your wingman before you fight them.
Okay, okay, okay.
Get your wingman.
We can't fight.
What about your wingman?
No wingman.
Oh my god.
Okay, but I got...
Wait, this one, can we fight this one?
Can we just kill this guy?
Yeah, yeah.
He's down there.
Sure, where is he?
I see one.
Only one.
Alright, let's go.
Make a zip.
Fight them.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe in the ditto power.
That's why I zip.
Ditto.
I think they... he ran away.
Oh yeah, zone's...
They don't see him.
Maybe he's low here, I think.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure he ran to zone.
Or like... he got scared.
He was like, girls, and then he got scared.
There's one guy here.
Which one?
Over here.
Oh, they're fighting.
Yeah, go, go, ditto, go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Did they shoot us?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I broke one.
Only Hiro shot.
Yes, I broke one.
Wait, wait, wait.
Go, Hiro.
Go, ditto.
Go.
Wait, is he right here?
Watson, Watson 1.
Watson 1.
Watson's low, Watson's low.
You got Watson?
Nice.
Yeah, I got one.
Flash, flash.
He's flash, flash, flash.
Yeah, this is flash.
Be careful, be careful.
Flash the guy too.
I'm dying.
I'm gonna kill the Watson.
Okay, I will go left.
I will go left.
Wait, there's another guy there.
Okay.
Wait, he went down, he went down.
Another guy in front of me.
Wait, she's here, she's here.
She's here.
Conduit's here.
Okay.
Wait, she's here, she's here.
Conduit's here.
Okay, okay, I'm going.
Oh, the portal, portal, portal down.
Okay, okay.
All right.
They might part the back.
I'm not sure.
There's someone down here.
They don't, they don't, they don't...
They don't... They went down.
Wait, I see them, I see them.
Wait, they did...
Wait, they come back.
They come back.
Oh my god.
They came back.
They're fighting, they're fighting, they're fighting.
Oh there's another team.
She's back.
They're fighting, they're fighting in front of me.
Okay.
Right here, right here, right here.
Oh, what the heck.
What are they doing?
Wait, they took a portal in here.
I'll go there.
Go go go go go.
I'll go with her.
I broke.
There's a rez behind me.
Okay.
I'm gonna look at this rez.
Where is she?
What the fuck?
What's going on?
Yeah, inside.
Inside.
There's two.
There's a lot of teams.
There's one just behind us too.
I'm coming to you.
I'm coming to you guys.
Wait, low.
Low.
Okay.
I'm helping.
I'm trying to help.
I'm getting shot from behind.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Keep crawling to me.
He's trying to thirst me.
No, he's low.
He's low.
He's not going to.
No, he's not.
He's not.
Okay, I'm here.
This is going to be really risky though.
I think they're landing.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Okay, I went to ditto.
Bloodhound is low.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Wait.
You're fine.
Someone's pushing you.
Someone's pushing you there.
No!
Oh no!
Someone's pushing us.
I'm safe though.
I'm safe.
They're not here.
Really?
Can you crawl?
Oh, is that a person over there?
Are you safe?
I don't know.
I'll go to her too.
There's one person.
One person.
Two.
Wait.
There's someone at the back.
Oh my god.
Too much.
Only two, two.
Oh my god.
Why did he shoot me?
You...
How should I kiss others?
Wait.
He hid them.
No.
Let's protect each other.
We're coming to you.
Ditto, you can craft us.
Ditto.
You can craft us.
They'll craft us.
Okay, okay.
Let them kill you.
I'm dead.
Oh no!
It's okay, you're almost dead.
Please kill me!
Somebody show...
I'm gonna go to this bomb.
No!
It doesn't kill me!
Oh my god!
Please!
Die!
Two seconds!
Okay.
Okay, I'm dead.
Do you have res beacon?
Where can I... I don't have it.
I don't have it.
I will go find it.
Can you though?
There are so many people.
How many people are there?
A lot.
Okay.
Oh, there is an egg squad.
Yeah?
I will try to get you...
I think I have a res beacon.
I think I have one.
You should go over and see.
Oh no!
They are still there!
No, no, no!
They ran!
They rotated.
No, no, they rotated!
I'm just joking!
You were right!
No, I swear!
They rotated now!
Check, check, check!
See, they are gone!
They are gone!
I don't know!
I don't want to say a bad word, but are you blind?
What's the bad word?
See, they are gone!
They are gone!
Because of me!
No, they are not!
They took a sip!
Yes!
Are you blind?
Really?
Yeah!
They took a jump pad!
Wait, wait.
I have to find...
Yeah, yeah.
Outside?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It's outside.
Check in my...
Where is your... where is your... It's outside!
It's outside!
On the other side!
Yeah, yeah.
The other side.
See, they are fighting!
It's your left!
See that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
That's not mine.
It's mine.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You had one too!
You didn't see it!
Wait, I didn't know!
No, no, no!
Why did you shoot?
You could have rest!
I can't rest.
Trust me, trust me.
Okay, okay.
I trust you.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I trust you.
We could rest right here.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I don't trust you anymore.
It's okay.
Put the recipe in here!
Slow.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Don't put it in.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
We can't.
No, no, no, no, no.
You have to leave though.
You have to leave.
This is not so... Okay, okay.
I will leave.
Goodbye!
Oh my god!
I did it!
She's so good.
Oh my god, see!
I told you!
You were the wingman person!
Wait!
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no!
Oh my god, you did it!
Oh, I did it!
Congratulations!
You did it!
We did it because Nozzy died first.
Wait, what a rank difference.
Wait, let me go back to the lobby.
Okay.
Bad news, it says rank difference.
There's rank difference?
Who?
Tero got gold!
Can we play together?
You're too high!
No!
Here, here!
You go with Toki and rank up to silver.
How did that happen?
I was just...
Do you mean we play one...
Wait, I...
Wait!
Did I go to bronze?
Is it not?
You're a rookie!
Why?
It's because you're a rookie and like, Ditto's gold!
Also, here's 10 subs.
Oh, thank you, Toki!
Thanks for the sub!
Thank you!
Don't worry, look, look.
We'll gain the RP back.
Really, really fast.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna exit.
Here.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, Ditto, you coach us, Ditto.
Yeah, actually she can just watch us and tell us what to do.
Okay, okay.
Can someone, um, share me some screen?
Watch our stream!
Watch it now!
Okay, okay.
Coach us!
Okay.
I'll stream.
I'll be coasting, guys.
Isn't there like a relay?
Oh, I'll stream, yeah.
Yeah.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Really?
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Don't worry.
How- wait, what rank are you now?
Wait, you just- we just need one win!
Your rookie won!
Yeah, I'm rookie one!
Yeah, we just need one win!
I'm like, I'm like almost there.
I don't even need to win, I think.
I just need to kill somebody.
Yeah, you just need to kill people.
Okay, let's land on somebody then.
Okay!
Yeah.
How many points do you- um, do you need?
Yeah, how many points do you need?
Uh, 100, I think?
Oh!
It's really easy!
It's really easy.
Like, rookie is like... That's one kill.
Yeah.
That's like two to three kills, I think.
Maybe?
No, like, rookie is like really, like, any- anything is like... like 50 points, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I believe in us.
We can do this.
I believe.
Okay, Deco's watching us, so I believe.
Yeah, I will do wash party.
Alright, sound guy, turn him down a little bit.
Poach this!
Yeah, wash party, yes.
Are you streaming here?
I'm not streaming right now, yeah.
But you said it was okay!
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you need me to open it on Discord?
Oh, yes!
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me do it.
Okay.
It's okay, we're not Jump Master.
No!
This guy might play like a pussy!
Because he's- he's Jump Master.
What?
You're not playing like a coward!
Why did you call him pussy?
Because he's not jumping!
Oh, never mind, no, no, no.
He is not pussy.
He's thinking it's a fucking fragment.
We're gonna fight-fight here.
We're going to fragment.
Oh, I'm sharing my screen.
Here you go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, no, we're fight-fighting.
Wait, I'm like, my keyboard is wrong now.
Oh my god, wait, I can't find it.
Your keyboard is wrong?
I'm typing in Japanese, wait!
Okay, wait, okay.
It's okay, we're gonna type too.
Wait, he's fighting already!
He's already fighting!
He's actually fighting.
Oh, okay.
That's what I'm saying!
He's fighting-fighting, he's not pussy!
Okay, I'm going.
I'm gonna fight.
Okay, I'm heading over here.
You gotta- Wait, there's actually a gold knock.
Here.
Oh, wait, that's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I need that, actually.
Alright.
Um, um, okay.
Alright, what should we do, coach?
Coach, what do we do?
Just loot!
Loot fight.
Just loot?
We're not gonna fight.
She's actually fighting, though.
Oh, no, we have to help him.
Oh, no.
He's dying.
Oh, yeah, you have to go help.
I cracked him, I cracked him!
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go fight.
Nice.
Where is this other guy?
At the bottom, they're all at the bottom.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, goodbye.
Wait, he's cracked?
That guy's low.
Oh, there's a- He's not that low.
He's low, too.
Got him?
Nice, nice.
I'm here.
Nice.
Oh, I cracked him?
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Yay, we're so good!
Is that 100 points already?
I have plus 45 by the way.
Oh, okay.
We need a few- We just need a few more and we're good.
Oh, I have plus 45.
Oh, I put a heal drone right here.
Okay, you heal first.
Heal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I put heal drone here.
Oh, my God!
Wait, yes, Coach!
Yes, Ma'am.
I didn't do nothing.
I'm gonna go rez.
I'm gonna rez.
Oh, wait, I heard somebody.
Really?
No, GK.
I'm gonna have a respawn.
You can't trust her heal.
The only one who can trust is me.
What do you mean you can't trust me?
I'm in the middle of the match, I'm gonna go rest.
What do you mean?
She's a liar!
I'm not a liar!
Wait, there's somebody here.
I'll kill them, watch this.
I'm not a liar.
You're a liar for lying that... for saying I'm a liar.
You're lying.
I would never lie.
I would never lie to you, Hiro.
I would never lie to you.
Hiro, Hiro.
You should better not trust Doge.
What?
I'm your healer.
You have to trust me.
I'm your support player.
Okay, that guy's on top.
You got this, Hiro.
I believe in you.
I'm looting.
Really?
Okay, okay.
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got this.
Look, our third is here now.
He can be bait.
Wait, where is he?
Okay, on the bridge.
Oh, here.
I see him.
Doge, find the cover and shoot, okay?
Okay.
I'm finding cover.
I'm looting.
Oh, nice, nice.
My cover, nice cover.
Oh my god, do you see my cover?
If you crack them, you can push.
Oh, okay.
Did we crack them?
A little bit.
Oh my god, really?
Oh, I'm gonna push this.
Did you crack them?
No, but...
No, but you pushed.
Okay.
No, but I'm gonna push.
Yeah, but I killed him.
Nice one, nice one.
Yeah, I killed him.
He's flesh.
Nice, nice.
How did he die?
Oh, nice, nice.
How did I kill him?
Why?
Oh, my god, that's sad.
I literally don't know how a guy died.
Nice, nice.
See, we did it.
Coach, we did it.
Are you good?
Nice, nice.
You have 100 points now?
50.
I have 95.
Oh, 95.
We just need 5 more.
95, 95.
Yeah, we just need 5 more.
There's a lot.
Let's go find some more.
95.
Yeah, there's 12 scores left and it's 95.
Oh, yeah.
You're in the rookie.
Yeah, yeah, because she's rookie.
She gains like a hundred... a million points.
I'm so...
We have 5 more, you know.
I wonder how many points you can get.
Like the max... like maximum points.
I think it's like 500 plus.
Really?
I'm pretty sure.
Maybe more.
Isn't it more now?
Is it more?
I don't know.
I haven't been in.
Like, it was so fast to get out of rookie.
It literally took like 2 wins.
From like...
There's like nobody here.
There is nobody here.
But like...
Oh, yay.
But I can do this.
Oh, what's in the package?
Let's see.
This?
Oh, this.
I need that.
Triple take.
Alright, alright.
Doki, you are lifelike so you have to give the... what is that?
The what?
Evil Harvester to your teammate.
I just took it.
See?
You don't listen to your coach.
It's just because I'm just a bad player.
You're a bad coach.
You're just a bad coach.
I'm a bad coach like my papa.
I teach you how... I teach you how like he teach me.
It's not my fault.
You're right.
It's RPR's fault.
How dare you.
He's such a bad teacher.
I'm just teaching you like... yeah.
I teach you what he teach me.
I feel like every time I play with you guys, you get...
Guys!
Hiro!
Wait, I'm so far.
Only... only the...
Wait, I'm not... I'm not there.
No!
Hiro!
Wait, she put an... she put an ult down.
She put an ult down for you.
What do you mean no?
Wait, I'm here but she's looking at me.
I'm gonna put an ult down.
That's fine.
Why did you know me?
She's there.
Doki, Doki.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm at the portal.
Nice.
Where are you?
She took the portal!
Oh, she took the portal too?
I'm coming.
I'm coming too.
Oh, no!
I got shot by three different people!
No!
Oh, that's her keyword, bitch!
I'll look if she reses.
I'm gonna look for you if she reses.
Why?
Why did she try to finish you?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, she res.
She res.
No!
No, try to finish.
Yeah, bitch!
Oh, now you get 100.
You got 100, right?
Yeah, 100.
I think I got it.
Yeah, yeah, you got it.
You got it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, now we can leave.
We can leave now.
That'd be funny if you're just like 1.5.
Please don't.
No, no, no.
I'm here now.
Okay?
Yeah.
No, I'm bronze.
I'm bronze.
Yeah, yeah, bronze.
Okay, dude.
Nice.
Join us, dude.
Join me.
All right.
I can't.
Okay, where are you?
Why didn't you like send a friend request to Hiro while you're in the lobby?
Hiro is offline.
You could send a friend request right now.
Oh, she's offline.
Maybe it's your name.
No, she's not.
Liar.
I joined off of her.
It's a lie.
See?
I joined off of her.
My screenshot.
Kara, I will give you my screenshot.
Photoshop.
She's offline.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
So, sound guy, turn the video down a little bit.
Okay, I think it's a real issue.
Maybe, maybe English is not the best language to communicate with Doki.
What language should we use then?
What do you mean?
Maybe we can't use Thai.
I'm communicating.
Doki.
It's the only thing I learned from Doki.
What is that?
No, no.
What's that?
You know this.
This isn't Lee.
Wait.
What does that mean?
What?
You can ask.
What does that mean, Ditto?
What does that mean?
Motherfucker.
That's the only thing Ditto taught me though.
Wow!
Ditto is a bad influence.
You asked me to teach you.
You asked me!
Hiro asked me to teach her.
Is that true, Hiro?
Hiro!
Hiro, I don't remember.
I have no recollection.
Hiro, Hiro, Hiro!
Remember!
No, she doesn't remember.
Don't pretend that you can't remember.
She's not pretending!
She's just old!
She's pretending!
You guys are such an actor!
You're an actor!
It's not true!
I'm not acting!
You're good!
I actually don't remember at all.
Oh, Hiro!
Hiro!
You can't remember.
Yeah, we're just getting old!
No, no, just like how you remember.
Remember when you didn't remember?
Wait, there's people?
Okay.
No, no people.
There is!
Wow!
Oh, Hiro landed on them.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
I got a gun.
Did somebody press the button?
I'm fucked up.
Me!
No!
Why did nobody press the button?
Wait, wait, wait.
They're like right here.
It hits the bottom.
Why did nobody press the button?
Okay, I'm gonna...
Why would it hit the bottom?
There's the button!
I need a present.
I don't have the button here.
I'm going over to...
Oh, now... Oh my god, you guys.
Now you guys...
Guys, guys, guys!
You fuckers!
No!
Don't look here.
I didn't press it.
You press it.
I'm here.
Okay.
There's one guy.
Oh my god!
I hit... I missed every shot.
Oh my god, you could lie, you know.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
They're shooting you.
Oh yeah, they're shooting me!
Okay, I... 34?
Oh my god.
I hit half of...
Okay.
I'm looking for you guys.
It's okay.
They're still not there yet.
Yeah, they're just poking us.
This one's leaving.
What?
Oh, they're leaving?
They're scared.
Yeah.
Wait, they're scared.
You can push, you can push.
Last guy, let's get here.
Last guy's here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're leaving.
They're running.
They're scared.
I'm watching her.
Here, here, here.
Yeah, I'm watching too.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Oh my god, they're running, running.
Just stop.
Chase, chase him.
Okay, okay.
Oh no.
Only two?
No, three, three, three, three, three.
It's three.
They all...
Three, three.
Oh, what the fuck?
That's another team.
Another team, another team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we have to go back, go back and loot.
We have the full place now to loot.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Why did they leave?
Yeah, dude.
They're not dead.
Why?
Yeah, that's why.
Yeah.
I see.
It's so stupid.
Now we have all the loot.
Why?
Why they leave?
They're scared, they're like, oh my god, they're all girls.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, hoodies.
Average age on Apex player.
Oh my god, guys.
Hoodies.
What is that?
That's it.
What is cooties?
Cooties?
Oh, it's a...
It's a disease that girls carry.
And it only infects the boys.
So when we touch a boy, they die.
That's cooties.
It's a real disease.
Yeah, it's real.
The doctor says there's no cure for cooties.
I see, I see.
There's no cure.
It's very dangerous.
Oh, wingman!
Are you still gonna do it?
No, no, no.
Oh.
I think we can fight this team.
Alright.
Let me...
Eh?
Can you scan?
Scan, okay.
Yeah, okay.
Anyone nearby?
Wait, they're here.
Right here.
Oh, yeah, I see them.
I see them.
They're really close.
Oh, they're why?
Okay, okay.
Only one?
Yeah, there's only one.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna... I'm gonna EMP him right now.
That's so cute!
White armor!
Nice, nice, nice!
That's so sad.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
He got his streamer mode.
Where's your teammates?
Oh no, the cooties got him.
We gave him cooties.
Oh no!
Wait, let me check if they're still here.
Yeah, they're still here.
They're still here.
They still have to be.
Like, where are they?
Where did they go?
They're so scared.
Okay, I...
Maybe you can read the...
Let me scan.
Yeah, yeah, people scan.
We've never done that.
I will scan the ring.
I'm gonna grab the bats here.
I will go scan the ring.
Alright.
It's kinda far.
Maybe they ran away.
I mean, but Hiro still sees them.
Yeah, it's...
They're still here.
Oh wait, they're gone.
Oh, they're gone?
Oh, okay.
Can you scan here?
Yeah, we might as well scan it just in case.
Yeah, I don't have too far.
You know what, I'm gonna be here.
Yeah, if you're too far, I'll punch you closer.
Oh god, don't punch me in the lap.
What do you mean?
I'm in a really dangerous position right now.
I know.
Okay.
God, I'm so scared.
Wait, you're actually punching me?
What do you mean?
I would never.
Okay, they're here.
There's one guy over here.
Do you wanna fight the Saging or Skyhook?
Okay, maybe there's a teammate.
Yeah, do you wanna do Skyhook?
Okay, let's do Skyhook.
There's only one team here in the solo.
Let's do Skyhook.
Where should we go?
I want to go Skyhook.
Yeah, let's go Skyhook.
Wait, do you fight?
What's that?
There's like bullets there.
It's a solo and a team there.
Yeah, and a team.
We go Skyhook because there's a lot of teams.
And I think they will have a long fight.
Yeah, let's go there.
I'm heading there.
Okay, I'm just taking a little bit of the days.
I'm gonna grab some more ammo.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Frontline, Lifeline is here.
Okay.
Do you think they are still fighting or no?
There was two.
There was two in the solo.
There were two and there was one team over there.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like we'll bump into somebody.
There were like three.
Yeah.
We'll figure it out when we get there.
I can't hear anything.
I don't hear anything either.
Wait, wait, wait.
In front of me.
Oh shit, that might be them.
Behind them?
Oh my god, in front of me.
Two, two, two.
I knocked one.
Nice one.
They're low.
I knocked two.
I'm going to.
I don't know where the last guy is.
Okay, you got this.
I did my job.
Okay.
I already did my job, so it's your turn.
Oh my gosh.
Why were they in white armor?
That was so close.
But they were white armor.
I didn't hear anything.
So they're like extra bad.
Maybe they just revived?
No, you revive and get your armor.
That's the thing.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You still get your armor.
Wait, wait, wait.
Not the team.
In front of you?
Oh.
Oh, okay, there.
Okay.
I'm pushing.
Oh my god.
I'm pushing toes.
Wait, I'm not.
It's okay.
I believe you, Dato.
I'm shooting.
I can't.
I don't stop shooting.
You're shooting.
I'm shooting too.
You got it.
There's grenades.
I got him.
I got one.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm batting.
Okay, okay.
Two left.
One left.
I can't help.
She's here.
You got this, Hiro.
It's your turn.
We got our ones.
She's running to you guys.
She has one.
She's running to us?
You got this, Hiro.
I'm gonna loot.
No, let Hiro kill her.
Let Hiro.
I just wanted to see Hiro kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just wanna watch you cry.
We each got our ones.
Okay.
Nice.
I like Ditto's comms.
Never stop shooting.
No reload.
Just shoot.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, nice.
You didn't give Hiro purple armor.
That's so fucked.
Ditto, you're not a team player.
If I didn't get purple armor, I would've been so fucked.
I didn't take it.
You were gonna take it.
That's not true.
No.
That's true.
I wasn't giving Hiro the armor.
You did.
You did it before.
No, that's not true.
I did it to you.
That's true.
But I won't do it to Hiro.
No.
I'm running away.
It's okay.
I'm too sad.
Hiro will understand me.
Hiro's sad right now.
What do you mean?
I'm just gonna be on my drone next time.
She's not sad.
She's sad.
She's not.
Ditto, why did you hit her?
You're in the open.
You're in the open, Hiro.
Ditto often does this to me.
Ditto, why would you do that?
You're so...
That's so fucked.
I'm in the grass.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucked up, Ditto.
I'm so...
Poor Hiro.
She's getting a bleed.
She can get...
purple armor herself.
You know what?
I'm just gonna stand right here.
Come here, come here, doggy.
Why me?
Captain!
She's dead.
Why me?
Why?
We have to come here.
Only one.
Only one here.
I'm getting shot at.
No, no, no.
I'm getting back.
Okay.
I cracked.
Ditto, I cracked him.
Why didn't you go out?
Why didn't you go?
Wait, wait, wait.
Behind, behind, behind.
Wait, she's...
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
What the fuck?
Please!
Please, hello.
Guys, I'm getting...
I'm getting cyberbullied!
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
What the fuck?
There's a charge rifle over there.
I don't... Can you finish that?
No, I can't.
Okay, I'll finish them.
I'll sit here and dock you.
Oh my god, this team is so annoying.
They are, they are.
There's three squads, though.
They are very annoying.
Oh my god.
I'm scared, Hiro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where?
On the ping.
On the container.
We should kill this team.
Which one?
This team?
Oh, they're pushing, they're pushing.
Crack, crack, crack, crack.
You got it.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Okay, we can fly.
That guy is really far.
He's like over there.
There's another team.
Can you thirst him?
Oh, yeah, here, here.
Where is he?
Here, on the ping, on the ping.
I don't see a ping.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Look at crosses.
I don't see him.
Where are they?
I don't know, I'm looting.
I'm looting?
He's over here.
I'm over here.
Alright, alright, I'm coming over here.
Wait, on me, on me, on me, on me, on me.
Crack, crack, crack, crack, crack.
On here, on here.
Behind this box, behind this box.
I cracked him though.
Broke, broke.
Nice, I'm crossing.
One hit, one hit, did you?
I knocked.
Not pass finder.
I knocked him, I knocked him.
This one is one too.
This one is one.
Yeah, but he's like blocking him for me.
I got him, I got him.
Nice, pull it, pull it, pull it.
Right here, right here, right here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I got the gaps on...
Oh, I saw purple, purple, purple armor over here.
Up top.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
I need it.
Oh, we go together?
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, go Ditto, go!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
You can't die!
Crack, crack, crack.
Oh god, I can't see.
I'm having a watch.
Red armor, red armor.
Oh god.
Okay, I need a backup from that.
Okay.
I am healing, I'm healing.
In front, in front, in front of here.
Over here, over here.
I'm taking the zip, I'm taking the zip.
Okay.
I'm doing something crazy.
Okay, I have only one battle left.
Where's one hit Ditto?
Okay.
I have two.
Two in cross.
Okay, nice.
I'm trying to...
I got one, I got one, I got one.
Okay, inside, inside.
Okay.
I will go help, I will go help.
I got one, I got the other.
Last guy, last guy, last guy.
Crack them, I cracked them.
I want your shit.
Give me your shit.
Yay!
Alright, look at us go.
We're so good now.
Where's this guy?
I almost have no more...
I don't have ammo.
We're poor now.
We're so poor.
Over there, over there, over there.
They're coming to us.
I see him, I see him.
Wait, they also have a bow.
I need his bow.
Give me your shit.
Let me go look at them.
Be careful here.
It's a rampart.
Let me, let me.
I'm gonna EMP them in a bit.
My drone is coming back.
Okay.
I'm getting on the roof.
Okay, I just got my...
Oh, I got one hundred with my main.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Careful.
Get the rampart away.
I'm doing it now.
I'm slowly heading over.
Alright.
Be careful.
I got knocked.
You got knocked?
Alright, alright.
Back out.
Can you keep crawling back to me?
Crawl back to us.
I think I can't.
Oh no.
Okay, okay.
You cover, you cover.
I'm gonna go grab her.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I have to, I actually have to bat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should.
Oh, they're getting crossed.
They're getting across right now.
Oh, they see me heading.
Cover, cover, cover.
She, she, there's a...
Maybe you have...
Yeah, yeah.
You have to kill them first.
I got it.
I got it, I got it.
Oh, they killed me.
Oh, no.
He got you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Keep coming back.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
But I need you to cover though.
Okay, okay, okay.
You can do it, you can do it.
Okay, they have... I think this is one...
It's a solo and then this team.
Yeah, solo and...
This is bad.
They're on me, they're on me.
The solo's on me.
No, this is a...
No, no, no.
All on me, all on me.
It's a solo.
Pass me that, pass me that.
One knock, one knock.
And one, another one with heal.
I don't know where he is.
He's here.
Okay.
I got him.
Flash, flash, flash.
I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice.
I need to cover.
Oh, shit.
That's a solo.
It's okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, they're not solo.
This isn't solo.
This is not a solo?
It's not a solo, Doki.
It's not a solo.
It's a full team just waiting.
Full team ratting.
Please die!
I almost got him too!
It's a full team ratting!
Cowards!
They had to look for cowards!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I can't believe the full team ratting!
And they, and they, they lose.
They lose the lifeline.
They lost!
I can't kill.
I can't believe it.
Nice.
I can't believe a full team ratting!
We were like, mowing down.
We killed everybody in this team ratting.
I was like, wait, that's not one person.
Wait, didn't we each quit again?
I got Daisy.
Oh, yeah, DC, DC, DC.
Yes, yeah.
Do you wanna be leader?
No, no, no.
I can't join.
Why?
I can't join anyone.
I invited it.
I will play Horizon because Password is too high.
Password is too high.
It's too hard?
Yeah.
I got handshot with that bossing.
Oh no.
Yeah, I mean his hitbox is like bigger.
His hitbox is bigger.
It's okay, this time.
This time, you won't die.
I believe.
Yeah, Hiro, do you believe?
Do you believe in Ditto?
I believe.
Ditto got 1v3 this time.
Yeah, Ditto, you're gonna 1v3.
Why?
Why you guys want me to 1v2?
Because you're prent!
You're so cool.
You can't do.
Ditto, I 1v3'd.
Where was your last game?
I literally 1v3'd.
What do you mean?
You played 2.
Yeah, and I 1v3'd.
Where was your 1v3?
Yeah?
Ditto?
What?
Ditto, where was your 1v3?
I just 1v3'd last game.
Which game?
Last game!
I literally 1v3'd last game.
No, you didn't.
You didn't.
What do you mean?
You killed that lifeline.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't.
Which one?
I killed 3 people in the caustic.
You killed 2.
I killed 3.
I killed 2 and I damaged...
I broke 1 armor.
Alright, Ditto.
Your turn to 1v3.
Did you just hit 1v3?
I'm not saving your life anymore, Ditto.
No!
Remember the bridge?
The bridge!
I saved your life.
The bridge.
No, I did not 1v3.
What do you mean?
I killed... I saved your life.
I killed 2 and I let you knock the 3rd.
Ditto was just here to watch.
Naughty.
Who's right?
If I say anything...
They're gonna turn on me.
I was scared.
.... uesta vsteruffy.
dorman No, you gaslighted me again.
You lied.
You're gaslighting me.
I know what I did.
Last match?
Yes.
I did.
Wait, is somebody there, Doki?
I did a 1v3.
It's time.
She's actually there.
Wait, watch this.
Two together?
Inside the building?
Doki can do it.
Not together?
Oh my
god.
Down one?
He's low.
Nice.
I down one.
I'm here.
Flash.
I hit like 80.
Yeah.
Hero 1v3.
You guys play together.
I will just watch.
I will just watch you guys watch.
1v2 people?
Okay.
What do you mean?
Where's your 1v3?
Why?
Why not?
Why do I have to play?
If you guys can 1v2 every team?
Because we gotta show everybody that we can each individually 1v3.
I can.
I can 1v3.
Then show me.
Where's the enemy?
Next enemy.
Okay.
You're getting that one.
I can actually sound here by the way.
Oh yeah.
Why do we have to 1v2 people?
We have 3 people.
Why do you have to play solo?
Because each of us needs to show that we're good at the game.
Okay?
And we wanna prove that people... We're actually fighting really hard right now.
Yeah.
And we wanna prove to people that we are a Pred girl squad.
We each have the 1v3 at least once a day.
Wait.
He's right here.
Ditto.
It's time.
Don't help her.
Okay.
I'll scan for you Ditto.
Here we go.
Yeah.
We scan for you.
Another one?
Yes.
Only one.
You see it?
Wait.
He's coming.
It's a bottom.
Yeah.
Look.
I'm following him.
There he is.
No.
I killed one team.
You did it Ditto.
I did it.
One only.
You keep killing one.
Yes.
Here.
There's another butthole here too.
There's only one guy here.
Go.
Go Ditto.
No.
Oh wait.
Another team.
Not the team.
I dropped down.
I cracked him.
It's the same team.
That's his teammate.
Okay.
I'm gonna loot.
No.
This is a different team.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Army.
I'm here.
Wait.
They're here.
Yeah.
Almost can.
Oh my god.
He's cracked.
I will kill them.
Ditto you can do it.
If you kill two that's a 1v3.
He's so low that guy.
He's so low.
The lifeline.
Oh my god.
He's coming out the car.
There's one guy here.
I got him low Ditto.
I got him low.
I got the Bloodhound low.
It's your turn 1v3.
He's so low.
Now you need two more.
One more.
One more Ditto.
I broke it.
I broke it for you Ditto.
1v3.
Yeah.
We did it.
1v3.
Okay.
We did it.
1v3.
Yeah.
Guys we're good at this game.
We each can 1v3.
Each of us can 1v3 guys.
We're a pro squad.
Oh my god.
Another squad.
Here I'll EMP them.
Go Doki.
You can do it.
Now we can play as a team.
Okay.
As a team.
We play as a team and show everyone how we're good as a team.
Now that we show everyone how we're good individually.
Now we show people how we're good as a team.
Okay.
Here.
Enemy.
Wait.
There's another team behind us.
Go.
Yes.
There's one.
There's an Ashe.
There's an Ashe back over here.
They did a knife thing.
It's Kondoid.
He's white armor.
Yeah.
I broke him.
Don't worry.
I will follow him.
Yeah.
We follow him.
Follow him.
Don't let him run.
You know what?
I'm gonna jump tower.
Yeah.
You're so far from us.
He's so low.
Really low.
He's here.
I'm running.
Okay.
How low is he?
He's dead.
Wait.
He has a team.
I'm gonna finish him.
Where's your team?
Okay.
Wait.
They're resting.
They have a team.
Okay.
They're resting.
I will go back.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Oh.
What the f***?
Wait.
I got snared.
Yeah.
They snared you.
Come here.
It's Ashe.
Wait.
Did he throw that all the way from there?
Is that Ashe?
White armor.
Keep up here.
It's Ashe.
Yeah.
He f***ing snared me all the way back here.
He's here.
Here.
He has to come to me.
Watch this.
Wait.
He ult here?
Oh.
Wait.
That's a good ult.
Another one here.
Here.
Okay.
Oh.
Ashe.
You made a mistake.
Okay.
I feel his teammate.
I made a mistake.
He's over there.
I waited too long.
Where is he?
He ran.
He ran this way.
Go kill them.
I'm running.
Let me check for you.
Yeah.
Where did he go?
He doesn't have his ult anymore.
He's here.
He's so far.
He's just too far.
No.
I'm gonna chase him.
You can't run away from me.
Okay.
I think we can go zone.
You guys go left side.
And cut him off.
Yeah.
You guys cut him off.
He has to go here.
He has to rotate here.
I think...
I think he's gonna carve his teammate banner again.
Did they have a crafter for him?
Oh.
Wait.
Does Conway...
Whoa.
Oh.
Shit.
I fucked up.
Wait.
Guys.
I fucked up.
I'm ready, Doki.
Why we team?
Doki, you won we team.
Guys.
I'll go to you.
Okay.
I got her.
I'll craft it.
It's okay.
Here.
Really fast.
Guys.
I fucked up.
What happened?
I got hunted.
Wait.
Full squad.
Yeah.
That was a full squad.
Here.
Wait.
They're fighting, Dido.
Okay.
Fighting with me.
They're fighting with me.
Maybe we have to go there.
You know what?
I'll EMP them for you, Dido.
Oh, yeah.
We can do it.
Okay.
Are we fighting?
Are you on a fight?
You're on a fight?
Yeah.
Alright.
We're gonna fight in zone then.
Yeah.
Here.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
I cracked one.
I don't have an angle.
She's there?
Yeah.
I see them.
You use your horizon Q.
I'm gonna...
Nice.
Flash.
One's flash.
Yeah.
There's one's almost low.
I got one.
All dead.
Nice.
See?
We did it as a team.
Okay.
We're good as a team and individual.
Guys.
See?
It's kinda painful.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What they have a...
Wait.
Do you have a... Do you have a heat shield?
Yeah.
I have heat shield.
Yes, I do.
Wait.
Oh my god.
You both so far from each other.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I'm lagging.
Are you lagging?
Oh my god.
That was lagging.
Wait.
The zone hurts, guys.
What is that?
Guys.
I'm lagging.
The zone hurts.
So far, it's not good.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
The zone hurts.
The zone really hurts.
Yeah.
Wait.
So far.
We don't have a...
Oh my god.
We don't have a jump tower.
I have only one heat shield.
And Doki, she's using heat shield for herself.
I'm dying.
I only have...
I have one...
Yeah.
I have one lip too.
Oh, no.
I might die.
I might die before I could head over.
Wait.
Did I... Oh my god.
I don't have heals.
Wait.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
Heal.
I'm so close.
I'll give you a little bit of heal.
Wait.
I don't have a heal.
Okay.
Go.
It's fine.
Heal first.
Heal.
30 seconds.
I made it.
Goodbye, guys.
You're so dead.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, everybody.
Are they there?
Oh, I don't know.
But I'm running.
Okay.
I don't know.
But I'm running.
I need it.
Oh my god.
I need it in the zone.
Guys.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
The zone's hurt.
Am I gonna make it?
I don't know.
Oh, okay.
Heal or not.
Wait.
There's a Wraith in front of us.
I'm running.
There's a Wraith.
It's okay.
I'm looking.
Team here.
Okay.
I think we go.
We go.
We go left.
Just...
Yeah.
Full left.
I'll go to you.
Yeah.
But there's a Wraith right here, though.
Okay.
We have to go right then.
No.
One team on the right.
We go here.
Okay.
We can go from the...
We can go from the bottom.
Yeah.
They're over here.
That's okay.
They don't see us.
They don't see us, but they saw me.
They saw me.
It's okay.
Be careful here.
I have... I have Q.
I have Q.
Guys.
Guys, this is bad.
This is... Oh.
Oh, God.
Guys.
Okay.
They got 2.
They got 3B.
We are okay, we are okay, we are so healthy.
We are good, we are good.
Stay here, stay here, this is safe, this is safe.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we are so safe.
We go down, okay?
We are okay, we are okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the fuck, who came here?
Do you want to go down?
Okay, I want his armor.
We are okay.
We are okay, we are okay, we are okay.
I see him coming.
Where?
He's more, Kev.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over, I'm Qing.
I dropped one.
Wait, I dropped down too.
No!
Tito!
Kev, he's Kev, he's Kev.
Kev, we can't get up, no, they are rezzing.
He's rezzing, he's rezzing.
Go, go, go.
He rezzed, he rezzed, he rezzed.
In the, in the...
Crack, crack, crack.
You have to hit.
Okay, okay.
He's low, he's low.
He's down?
Zone, zone, zone, we run, we run, we run!
Zone, zone, zone!
Zone hurts, zone hurts!
Leave him, leave him, leave him, the zone hurts!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I will cut off my armor.
I need a battery.
The zone hurts!
Okay, okay.
I will get keeping them.
Yeah, we can keep, we can keep.
Okay, I will get keep later.
Yeah, they have to die.
They are not dead yet.
They have to die, they have to die here.
There's no way.
Wait, they have a...
They are going to die, they are going to die anyway.
Yeah, they are going to die, they are going to die.
Yeah, they are going to die taking that.
Be careful.
Are they?
Where?
Where are they?
Where did they go?
Wait, there is someone here?
Wait, he is Kraber?
No?
Are they...
They died?
No?
No!
What?
I didn't... I didn't...
I don't get a kill.
Yeah, I don't get a kill too.
Where did they go?
They lived?
What?
Oh no, they got... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got to the zone.
Nice, nice.
Wow!
Nice!
Where is Gibby all?
Kraber, Kraber here!
There is a Gibby all in front of me.
Be careful, be careful, be careful.
I know, I know, but there is a Gibby all in front of me.
Yeah, but...
They dead, they dead.
They all dead.
No, no, no, no, we didn't get a kill.
I get... I got a kill, I got a kill.
You did, you did.
Oh, what?
I got two kills.
Oh, you got two kills.
What the...
Oh, they come to me!
They come to you?
Okay.
Oh, there was solo.
That was...
There was solo.
Okay, I am here, I am here.
They push us, they push us.
Be careful.
I am going up, I am going up.
No, that's me, that's me.
I was on first floor.
Can you kill for me, Hitoki?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Now we are on 2v2.
They have Kraber.
Where are they?
I have EMP.
Over here, over here.
Almost dead.
Over here.
Okay.
There is like a...
There is solo over there too.
Okay.
I want to kill solo.
Oh.
If we crack, we can push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, you want our EMP?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
This guy is solo over there.
Your EMP, I will kill up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We are heading over, we are heading over.
Okay.
I will kill up, I will kill up.
Yeah, I am right here, I am with you.
Weeeeee.
He is right below us?
Yeah, on the third floor.
I am not there.
Whoa, that guy is solo.
That guy, right here.
Okay.
Oh, with me, with me, with me.
I am coming, I am coming, I am coming.
Nice.
Thirst him, Thirst him, Thirst him.
Okay.
I got the bat, I got the bat, I got the bat.
Thirst him, Thirst him.
Where is his teammate?
Here, here, here.
I am pushing.
Okay, let's go.
On here, on here, on here.
Not.
Last guy here, last guy.
That is the creeper guy.
I am pushing.
Okay.
I will punish you.
Punch him, punch him, punch him.
Punch him.
Guys, guys.
Yay!
Look, we won V3 that entire game.
And also, we played as a team.
We punch.
We punch, yeah.
Girlfriends, girlfriends.
We are the cootie squad.
Three kills.
Twenty kills.
We did twenty kills again.
Let's go.
We are the cootie squad.
We touch them and they die.
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
We are the cootie squad.
Cootie squad.
We have cooties actually.
Yeah, we have cooties.
You don't want to get touched by us.
We all have cooties.
Yeah, we all have cooties.
When we shoot a person, they die.
That's why we punch them all together.
We gave him extra cooties.
Because we touched him.
Yeah.
Yeah, punches is like more...
It's more fun.
You die faster.
God, skin to skin contact.
Is it?
Skin contact.
Cooties are always fatal, guys.
But we make it faster when we punch you.
When you get punched, it's like...
It's like you die in one day.
You die in one hour if you get punched.
We die in one hour?
One hour?
Yeah.
And the punch...
The punches stack.
So the more punches you get, the faster you die.
Like...
If you get...
Yeah, if you get punched by all three of us, you die in one second.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
That was...
That was really fast.
Yeah.
It's really fast.
Yeah, it's like poison damage.
It stacks.
Like, times ten multiplier.
You know?
The multiplier.
Here we go again.
Yeah, yeah.
This was our winning area.
We won over there.
Oh, one team.
The cootie squad is here.
The cootie squad.
Oh, they're with us.
They're with us?
Only two.
Where is the third?
Oh, I hear the Valk.
I'm gonna go kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear them.
They're flying.
They're flying?
Where did they go?
They took the tower.
They took the Zed.
Oh, yeah.
They're gone.
They went.
They're here.
Oh my god.
Okay, you guys got this.
I'm getting the...
I'm getting the crate.
Nice.
Got it.
Where did they go?
Here.
Over there, I think.
I'll scan them.
Yeah, they're here.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I will go with this car.
Okay.
I'll scan them for you.
I'm going to grab this longbow.
I will scroll first.
Only one.
Here.
I'm heading over.
Where is the Zed teammate?
Where is the teammate?
Whoa.
Another building.
Oh, oh.
He's coming.
It's the Loba.
The Loba...
The Loba queued over here.
He's on the roof now.
It's two.
Okay.
I'm going to climb up.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm heading over.
Oh, it's... Oh, there...
Oh, my...
Loba is... Loba is dead.
Wait, lolololo.
One hit.
She's resing?
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I fucked up.
I fucked up, guys.
I'm sorry.
Heal, heal, heal.
Oh, my god.
It's okay.
You guys can 1v3.
Are you safe?
Yeah, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
You're not safe.
You are not safe.
Just my shield.
Oh, god.
Behind you.
No!
You are not safe.
Kill me.
Wait, wait.
Yeah!
Look at this.
No, no, no.
I'm going to grab you.
Isn't that too far?
Oh, my god.
Thank you.
Are you close enough?
No!
Yeah, I'm just waiting for them to know.
It's okay.
They didn't see.
They don't see.
Oh, no.
Now they know.
We have to go.
Go, go, go.
Now, now.
Now, now, now.
Now.
It's okay.
Wait, wait.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Just res me and then we craft it later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm looking for it.
We craft me craft...
Okay.
No, I lost my gold gun.
Here?
Yeah, yeah.
The dome.
Yeah, just res me here and then craft me later.
What happened?
What happened to you?
I climbed the wrong thing and then I slid.
It was like a slide.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I thought you were with me.
I thought so, too.
I was there, but you know...
I was like one hit.
I thought so, too.
No!
I lost my gold gun!
I'm so sad!
I'll go rest.
I lost my gold longbow.
It's okay.
There's no one grab your longbow.
We can go back.
Why would no one grab it?
It's such a good gun.
Wait, there's someone here.
Why is no one use longbow?
What do you mean?
It's a good gun.
There's someone here.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Okay.
He's like right here.
Oh, yeah.
There's only one guy.
Oh, but... Oh my god!
What the fuck!
Okay.
Maybe we can go lunch side?
Lunch side.
Go back.
Go back?
Okay.
Go to the waterfall.
Oh, it's not the waterfall.
What's there?
Geyser?
Geyser.
Okay.
How about lunch side?
Lunch side.
Let me check.
Are they still there?
They're all there.
They're using my longbow.
They don't lie to me.
They're literally using my longbow.
Yes, they.
They used your longbow.
They're using my longbow.
Liar!
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't read their minds.
Why?
We were the closest crafters.
There's no crafters here.
What?
Yeah.
Wait.
There's someone here.
What the hell?
We run backwards.
They don't see you.
I think we can...
Wait.
This is a scary game.
This is a horror game now.
They're right above us.
Oh my god.
You guys.
They scared us.
We have to go up.
Really?
Pretend you're not there.
Pretend they only saw me.
They only saw me.
They don't know you're there.
It's okay.
They don't know.
What the fuck is this area?
They don't know but they have a bloodhound.
Yeah.
It's okay.
They don't know but they have a bloodhound.
They're not gonna scan.
They're not gonna scan your way.
We have to fly.
Maybe we can run.
Maybe we can run here now.
Can you?
Yeah.
Run left.
Wait.
They're like right next to me though.
They are?
But they're fighting.
Another team.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Just hit the fragment.
The closest craft.
No harvester.
Just craft this and harvest it.
That's literally the closest craft.
You.
Okay.
Jump.
Jump tower.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Here.
You can do it.
Be a hero.
You know how I go there?
Yeah.
That's good.
Okay.
Nice.
We just never leave this place.
We're here forever.
Yeah.
And then you craft this and then you quick res us.
Okay.
Yeah.
You get to the same area.
You know what?
I can... I can... Yeah.
Yeah.
Over there.
I'm gonna send the truck.
Okay.
I swear.
Somebody could... Okay.
Bro.
That's so dangerous.
Don't worry about it.
You like suddenly just start like...
Okay.
Zero team.
That's good.
Nice.
Hero.
It's a hero.
It's so scary.
I saw one team.
By the way.
Oh no.
Hero.
It's a hero.
I'm pretty sure it says one.
It says one.
Okay.
We're back guys.
We're back.
Okay.
Here.
I took a harvester for you too.
Oh nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh okay.
I'm back.
We're back guys.
It's like we never died.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm taking a...
I'm taking a respawn beacon with me.
Oh yeah.
That's smart.
That's so...
That's really smart.
We definitely need that.
We're a mess right now.
I'll like sell.
I'll like sell too.
Oh yeah.
Might as well craft.
Let's see.
I'll do it just to get us a package.
We need a package.
So bedroom.
Yeah.
We need a package.
Alright.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Oh I hear them.
I hear them.
I'm gonna EMP them.
I'll EMP them.
Oh I hear them.
I'm gonna...
Oh never mind.
Never mind.
I'm gonna help.
Is that yours?
Oh that's not you.
That's not you.
Wait.
That's not me.
That's not you.
They're right here.
I thought that was you.
I didn't shoot him because I was like Hey.
Wait.
Don't worry.
That's not me.
I have my...
Respawn beacon.
Leave Ditto.
And then...
I'm trying to leave.
I'm really in a bad position right now.
She's having a good position.
I thought that was...
The Crypto made me think the enemy Wraith was...
Was you.
For some reason.
Oh my god.
How are you alive?
Okay.
Res me.
I'm scared they scan me there.
Oh no.
It's okay.
They don't know.
Ditto are you close to Res?
Yeah.
Ditto you Res me.
Ditto don't...
Ditto you just say it loud.
They might see me.
They're on top here.
It's okay.
They don't hear.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm sure.
You still don't.
No.
I don't trust Ditto.
They saw me.
They don't die so...
Okay.
You...
They saw you.
No.
You die first.
Okay.
Break.
You can't do that.
Ditto you're alive though.
You're alive.
Do you have beacon?
Yeah.
I do.
I do have a beacon.
But there's somebody here.
No.
You like...
Wait.
There's a Loba Market.
No.
You know what to do?
You...
I was gonna say you should just get your drone out and rest us back there.
Really?
Yeah.
No.
Do it.
I mean so... Do it.
Wait.
There's no team.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Let's rest us here.
Yeah.
Let's rest.
Honestly.
This is why I'm not ideal.
Loba.
Yeah.
We have a Loba.
Let's go.
Oh.
That's good.
We're so back.
We're so back guys.
It's okay.
We're so back.
Guys.
Everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm back.
Yeah.
I told you guys.
We're so back.
Wait.
There's no solo.
There's a solo near us.
Which one?
Here.
Go kill them.
I thought you guys...
He's here.
Right here.
I'm going.
Hello.
Okay.
Wait.
No.
He's... Wait.
The ring.
But then we can... There's Loba.
There's Loba.
Have him run so we can have his loot when he dies.
He's gonna take the geyser.
No.
We can't take the loot though.
He went to the door.
Another team here.
Another team.
They're trying to keep us.
They're keeping us.
Oh no.
I think we can kill this guy.
Okay.
He's low.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
EMP.
Ditto.
Kill.
Okay.
You guys do that.
Let's go.
I'm going up.
I have to kill this team.
Where?
Over here.
In front of me.
Nice.
Behind me.
On me.
Last guy.
Okay.
Oh.
I can't see.
I can't see what the f...
I'm broken.
No.
I'm so bad with flat light iron sight.
Nice.
This is bad.
Okay.
This is very bad for me.
I'm logging.
I'm very bad.
I got hit by the...
Oh.
You had gold.
Yup.
Okay.
That's good.
I recovered.
He is here.
Okay.
I need to get rid of...
I will kill him.
What are you looking at?
I need loot.
I don't have health.
What you looking at?
n.
What are you looking at?
Alright.
I cracked him.
Cracked him.
You have health.
Do you wanna fight?
No.
There's team to your left looking.
There's team to your left looking at us.
Thank you.
I have to find attached man.
We have a good spot.
Team here, team here.
I'm looking.
Oh wait, what the f***?
Two teams fighting now.
I'm just gonna... okay.
I'll push here.
Yeah, we can go there.
I'm looking.
Can you EMP them?
No, I just EMP.
Yeah, she already used it.
I will need it.
What the f***?
I knocked one.
On me, on my door.
I finished them.
Flash, flash, flash.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we take this building.
This is our building, b***h.
Yeah.
Be careful.
That's scary.
Whoa.
Wait, what?
Where are they?
Caustic crack here.
Flash?
Not flash, sorry, I lied.
Not flash, not flash.
What do you flash?
Okay, okay.
Another one inside the building.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going up, I'm going up.
I'm batting.
I'm going to you.
I got them, I got them.
They're over here.
Over here?
They're getting shot at.
Okay, another team, be careful.
I cracked them, I cracked them.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're cracked.
We can't fight, we can't fight, we can't fight.
I almost have EMP.
Yeah, yeah, let's wait for EMP.
I have ult, I have ult.
Okay, where do you want me EMP?
I'm going to loot.
Now I'm just looking guys.
There's a gold res here for you, Hiro.
Maybe they're laning.
I'm not sure.
I don't know either.
Here, here, here.
We gotta get the zone though.
I would, okay.
Oh yeah, I have to get the zone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, with the zone.
We might get gate kept here.
Where's the other team?
I don't know, that's the scary part.
I don't know.
They're there.
Over there.
So that means we can push up here.
We are not inside it.
Yeah, we have to figure out how to...
We have to figure out where to go.
We can take this place.
Yeah, we can just stand here.
Maybe it's full team lag.
Let me scan them.
Be careful.
Maybe... I'm not sure.
I'm looking.
Here, here, here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, they're hiding.
Here, there's one here.
There's one here too.
Look.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
They have blue armor.
They're not that strong.
This is three people with the tech.
Wait, it's a solo.
No, it's Chi.
Chi.
I'm doing something stupid.
I got one, I got one.
Okay.
Oh, cracked.
Someone stay high ground.
Dead, dead.
Oh, wait.
One more, one more.
I'm throwing the other one.
Be careful, be careful.
Dead, dead, dead, dead, dead.
He's here, he's here.
I'm pushing.
Okay, me too.
I'm pushing too.
You can push, you can push.
Oh, all red, all red.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
I need cover.
You know.
Okay, she's out.
Don't land on me.
Low, low, low, low, low.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, Ditto died.
Look at that.
We're so good.
Ditto and I died like six times.
We died a lot.
He was MVP.
Thanks for the scan.
This thing res.
The res.
You tell Ditto it was just resing us.
Crypto's really fun now though.
You can't run away from cooties.
It's like, you know like those like...
No, it's just like the sanitizers.
It kills 99% of germs.
And then he has the 1% that lives.
You might kill...
99% of cooties.
But there's the 1% that will bring us back.
So carrying a respawn becomes so great.
I can't believe we won that.
Holy shit.
We should not have won that.
The first part where Doki fell in the lava.
I did not expect that.
I actually think...
That's just like a poor way to do it.
I'm like, come on!
I like - I climb the one area that you can't climb.
Then I slid down.
Then I slide down.
Yeah.
And then like, Ditto and I were fighting on top of it and I was like, hmm...
I'll show you, I'll show you.
If you land here, I'll show you where I climbed.
Okay.
There's like three teams.
Maybe a lot.
Yeah.
No, we can do it.
I think we should go here.
I think we should go here first.
Okay, yeah, yeah, you're right.
Okay, I'm with you.
There's a team of us, there's a team of us.
One team, one team, yeah.
I will grab a gun, I will grab a gun.
I have a gun too.
Can you grab it?
Yeah, I got a gun.
Me too.
Okay, good.
I don't have it.
You're going this way?
I'm heading over.
Oh, that's a Mirage.
I'm here, Diddle.
I don't know where the other...
Nice.
I'm trying to figure out where the other guy is.
He's outside here.
Yeah, I hear him.
On my left?
Oh, they have two...
Oh, here, here.
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
Why did he...
Why did two Black...
What?
I mean, okay.
I'll take it.
Oh, he's like, oh my god, he's so cute.
He's like...
He's so cute.
Thank you.
What's the order?
Oh my god, that's the Mirage clone.
Yeah.
Let me check.
He wanted a hug.
Here, um...
Wait.
Where's the Mirage?
Here, here, here.
Here.
Just the Mirage.
He...
Yeah.
I think the teammate ran.
Yeah, I think you ran the crab.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
Because the Mirage can crab, right?
Yeah, not here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think so.
Let me check.
Okay, there's one here.
Okay.
And there's one here.
Bloodhound.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, with me, with me.
Oh, with you.
They didn't run?
Yeah.
Huh?
It's Bangalore.
Oh.
I think she's running now.
I think she's running.
Yeah.
Now she's running.
I'm gonna check the other...
Make sure the other team doesn't push us.
On the jump tower?
You guys got it, I believe.
Oh, they're fighting too.
Oh my gosh.
They're so low.
Wait, there's two teams here.
Let's explore this way.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I got her.
Oh, you got her.
You guys, I see her.
What?
So good.
Oh my god, I really wanna shoot so badly.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're pushing.
I'm gonna watch.
Nice job.
I'm here.
They're right here.
They're pushing.
I'm here.
Okay, I got the loot a little bit.
Okay.
Yeah, they...
They...
They fused also.
Your team?
Or are they...
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Full fight, full fight, full fight.
Okay, full fight.
I'm gonna...
Push, push, push.
Okay, okay.
My name.
Bangalore cracked?
Yeah, he's so low.
Oh!
Okay, I'll...
Okay, I'm here now.
I'm here now.
Okay.
No, I have to reload.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
How did my life...
Okay, I need heal.
I thirsted the...
I'm thirsting a bloodhound and one armor swap.
Yeah.
I thirsted.
You guys got it.
On me?
Okay.
Give me a second.
Wait, I don't have shield.
Oh, thank god.
Another team.
Oh god, another team?
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I need loot.
Sorry, I don't have shield.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where are you?
Okay.
Oh, Ditto, you're so far.
You're so far.
Okay.
I got...
Oh, I don't have any ammo.
That's it.
I got the gold bag now.
Only one left.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to that one.
Here.
Here, you're raising.
Raising.
Okay.
Okay, okay, got it.
Oh, I have to reload.
I have to reload.
Yes!
Okay, you got it.
You got it.
Nice.
Oh my god, that was so scary.
Oh my god.
Doki, can you rez me?
I'm gonna send the lava.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm so low.
Okay.
I don't have gold rez.
Wait, where's the rez?
Oh, I lied.
Oh, Doki.
Abe, she's a liar.
No, it's coz she died in the lava.
I didn't realize he died in the lava.
Wait, you don't have gold?
No, I don't.
I thought she had gold coz, like, I had to destroy her armor.
You say.
I died.
You're so funny.
I'm in the water.
I will play L-Star.
Oh, you're gonna play L-Star?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will play... oh!
I got two kills with RE-48... 45.
Oh, you should run it.
Okay.
Yeah, you should run it.
That means like...
Find me this!
Okay, I'll find you.
Don't worry, I believe.
Okay, there's nobody here right away.
Yeah.
We killed everybody.
Okay.
Yeah!
Alright, we gotta go up.
Okay, okay.
That's it.
Nice.
Wait, there's rest over here.
I saw it.
Alright, let's go.
Wanna go?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we can go.
Do you have jump tower?
No, we can use this jump.
Yeah, I was like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's so far.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'll show you guys where I climbed.
Come over here.
Okay, so like...
Wait, where are you?
I'm here.
Okay, I'm watching.
Okay, so like...
You know how we were all here?
Right here.
Uh-huh.
So...
You guys all climbed this, right?
You guys climbed this, right?
Uh-huh.
I climbed this.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's how I felt.
Dido and I were already running away when you were talking.
Did you see?
Did you see though?
Yes.
You saw?
You saw this one?
Yeah.
There's one team?
Okay, I'm going over here.
Okay.
Let me check.
Wait, you're here?
You're here?
I don't know.
There's a...
Oh, I see.
I see.
They're in front of me.
I'm...
Nice.
Hey, I knocked one.
Okay, I'm pushing out.
Okay, here.
On me.
Okay, I'm here.
Where are they?
Oh, I cracked.
Cracked.
Last guy.
Last guy on me.
Okay.
I knocked one.
Nice.
Oh, he has gold.
I have gold now.
Go, Kira, go die.
Go die.
Oh, nice.
Kira actually have gold?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go die.
Oh, TobiShash.
TobiShash.
I go die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
I will go with TobiShash.
Go, go, go.
Die to the ring.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you guys.
I have it.
I'm like full.
I'm like full right now.
Yeah, yeah.
I have your drone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We slowly die.
Oh my god.
This is zone one.
Here, here.
Here's some names.
Here.
Oh.
I flew.
Like a rocket jump.
It would be funny if a team pushes us.
What are you trying to do?
I have gold res.
All right, nice.
Yeah.
Wow.
There you go.
And then here's the drone.
Well, thank you.
There you go.
And I'll feed you some shizzles too.
Wow.
I'm going to go get some gold res.
There's nobody here, by the way.
See, I told you I have gold res.
Wow.
Thank you.
I told you guys.
Yeah, we're helping.
See, look at us.
Girl squad, girl squad.
I'm leaving.
You can't leave the girl squad.
Wait.
Can I ask how many kills you guys have?
I have a lot.
I have six.
Okay.
I have...
I've only been scanning people.
I have like 250 damage and eight assists.
You have eight?
Oh my god.
A lot.
Wait, there's actually somebody here.
Oh, there is?
Where?
I don't know.
Let me scan.
Oh, they res there.
I saw...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Let's go.
Wait, let me just scan.
Yeah.
It's time to give these boys some gold res.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
Oh, right there.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's so low.
He's by himself.
How is that low?
He's so low.
I'll scan them again for you.
I like assists.
No, he's one.
Nice.
I got one.
They're all back up there.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm just gonna burst them.
Atop.
Where?
Oh, wait.
No, no.
They're down here.
Should it?
Oh, wait.
I mean...
I need help.
Last guy.
You're right here.
He wants to thirst me.
He's fucking crazy.
No!
Oh my god.
He actually got it.
It's okay.
Look at this.
He actually got it.
What?
Oh my god.
My harvester.
He actually...
He has let him...
Another team.
No!
Really?
My lord.
You gotta rest me back.
I'm resting you right now.
I'm resting you right here.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't have a magazine.
I got griefed so hard.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's someone laying here.
Yeah, buddy.
My stuff.
It's me.
Yeah, it's me.
I forgot.
Wait, this one has a gold... gold dock.
Yeah, I have gold.
I will give you gold here.
Okay.
I need...
I need to grab my stuff, guys.
Take me back home.
Oh, yeah.
You can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can guard me.
They're resting over there.
Yeah, they're resting anyway.
So I need to get my stuff.
There's...
There's another team.
I'm out here, but it's safe here, I think.
You can grab your loot.
I need my loot back.
I can't believe it.
Oh, dude, they're fighting here.
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
Wait, what?
I got a magazine.
Did you scan out someone?
Yeah, you scanned somebody.
Yeah, I scanned in there.
In there.
Yeah.
I saw that, too.
Yeah, we can...
We can...
Over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can...
Oh, they're inframing.
They're inframing.
In front of me.
They're lying.
Flesh, flesh, flesh.
What the fuck?
You okay?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I'm right here.
I knocked one.
Right here.
Right in front of me.
There's another one.
The other one's behind there.
Nice.
Where's the last guy?
Thirsty?
Yeah, fuck you, lifeline.
There can only be one lifeline in this lobby.
Oh my god.
You supposed to stop me.
I'm not gonna finish this guy.
I don't care about this guy, but I'm gonna do this.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Me.
I'm a fucking loser.
Wait, they're fighting over here.
You wanna join?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to join.
Okay.
Why did you have...
Oh.
She...
Over there.
That's just health much delivered.
Let me scan it out for you.
Okay.
Here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I see them.
I'm heading over.
Oh, they're dead.
They finished.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
They're shooting a drone now.
Wait, I'm gonna wait for Ditto so she can tank the damage from me.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm not gonna tank damage from you.
What do you mean?
You're the fragger!
You're the entry fragger!
I'm literally support!
Why?
Support can be attacker too!
You can be an attacker too!
Yeah, but I'm literally support!
Let's armor!
Crack!
Okay, I'm batting, I'm batting.
Full squad there.
I cracked the one.
Maybe we can go here.
Yeah, we were okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here.
I'm here.
Wait, I cracked like two of them.
Okay.
No, I can't.
I just hit.
I will kill up.
Yeah, we're heading over.
We're heading over.
I'm behind, okay?
I'm going to...
They're over there.
I see them.
They're fighting.
I'm here a little bit.
Here, the lifeline.
The lifeline.
We have to kill the lifeline right here in front of me.
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Oh, lifeline?
Yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here.
On me too.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's another team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here.
Three teams.
They're fighting.
This guy is a solo.
He's dead.
In that truck.
There's a solo in that truck.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kill, kill, kill this one.
Kill this one.
Okay, okay.
Let me go scan them.
Wait, wait.
I want to...
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, I'm coming back.
They're down here.
They're down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Down there.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here, there's nobody.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Okay, I'm right behind you.
I'm right behind you.
They're down there.
They're there.
Okay.
Oh, there's...
There's someone here.
They're pretty far.
There's death blocks.
Death blocks here.
Yeah, let's just loot.
Let's just loot.
Reset.
Okay, okay.
There's like a rat right here.
I saw him.
Okay.
There's a lot of team here.
There's another...
I think they're gold now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where are they?
Where did they go?
Okay.
I think they went down.
Yeah, I think so too.
Oh, but we're going to get camped on our own.
Wait, wait, wait.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
On you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
Oh, but we're going to get camped on our own.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here, right here.
Under, under, under, under, under.
Come here.
Oh, yeah.
He's, he's gripping...
Zipping, zipping.
Grapple, grapple.
On you guys.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I'm going to use my ult inside this.
Okay.
Wait, I have EMP.
I have EMP.
Okay, okay.
Oh, this poor fucking team.
Okay.
Nice.
I knocked one.
Where's his teammates?
I don't know.
Wait.
What?
I don't know.
I think he's high.
Maybe I'm in.
Yeah.
Flash, flash, flash, flash, right here.
Flash.
Oh, my God.
Pathfinder.
He's so low.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Not nice.
No.
He's literally one.
Here, I'll put a jump tower here.
Not nice.
I got him.
Nice.
Wait.
He's here.
Okay.
I will go back.
I will go.
I'm going there.
You should come with me.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Follow me.
I'm coming back now.
Oh, my God.
I'm so far.
I'm so far, guys.
Your support is so far.
One hundred on my ping.
Coming.
Oh, wait a minute.
I'm going to take this.
Guys, I'm looting.
I'm looting.
They took the high ground.
We can go here.
I think we can fight them if...
Wait, there's someone on our right.
They're not here.
Where are they here?
They came here.
On my ping.
Loba is cracked.
Let me get him for you.
Wait, what the f...
I hate ping.
I got one.
Flash.
He's one.
No, there's a last guy.
I'm safe.
I need energy armor.
I got him.
Don't worry.
There's energy here.
Alright.
Where's the...
Where's the last two teams?
There's one over here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me get him for you.
There's two...
There's two over there.
I'm just gonna...
He's low.
Over there.
I can't see him.
32 purple.
He's pushing you.
I feel like there's someone near me.
There's someone near me.
Is there?
Like, at the bottom?
Oh, I'm here, Mimir.
Yeah, one team.
One team.
Not solo.
Not solo?
Okay.
I can't see this guy.
I'm backing out.
I'm backing out to Hiro.
They're there.
Okay.
Yeah, we're getting gatecapped.
Yeah, we have to cut the left.
I have EMP.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Whichever team we fight, the other team's gonna third party us.
I think I hear a note here.
EMP!
I got one!
I'm going!
One!
One in!
Where is he?
Alright.
Where is the guy?
Wait, they're fighting?
They're fighting?
Yeah, but they're fighting a rat.
There's only one guy.
Wait, wait, let them fight!
Let them fight!
No!
We should've let them fight!
It would've been funny!
Yeah, it's a rat versus rat!
Oh!
That's really the last guy.
Last guy.
Rat versus rat.
They're actually both one hit, I think.
That's a poor rat!
I think they're about to die.
I think I almost got 4k.
Oh my god.
Another one!
I was just scanning.
He's like, yeah, Havoc is really good.
Look, I have AT.
I think all...
You're an assist!
You're the assist queen.
Oh my god.
Crypto is strong.
I think Crypto is strong in a team fight.
Because then you EMP and then like...
Yeah, because they're trying to gate keep us.
Yeah.
And then they EMP and they can't do anything.
Oh my god.
We're so good, guys.
Girl squad, girl squad.
This is it.
How many wins did we get?
We got so many wins.
Yeah, I feel like we won like almost every time.
Yeah, I mean...
Oh, why don't we win?
I'm silver.
Yeah, we all got you from rookie to...
We almost got you the gold.
I think we can actually...
I can actually go gold.
Yeah, I think so too.
I think Ditto can get to plat.
And then like...
Yeah, we can get to gold.
Oh my god.
Plat is crazy.
Yeah.
How is your rank now?
I'm gold 3.
I'm plat.
I'm plat 4.
I think you're plat 4.
I'm almost plat 3, I think.
No, aren't you plat 3, I think?
I am.
I mean silver 3.
My account is only gold 1.
Wait, really?
Yes, I don't play rank.
But you're about to get...
plat now.
Alright.
Do we have anybody?
We have a squad here.
Not with us though.
Yay!
It's like, hey, we can kill them.
If we die, we have heal.
If we die, we have hero.
I'll immediately res you right on them.
Yeah.
We land on their heads and punch them.
We don't need guns.
Oh my god.
Cooties, right?
Give them extra cooties.
Alright, let's see.
Ugh, I bet they're not gonna die.
I don't like guns though.
Where were they?
The ship?
No, they're at the big mod.
Big mod, okay.
So we're fine.
Because they have to get big mod stuff.
Finally, finally, finally.
I can remember how to play Apex.
When she learned how to run, she learned how to play.
True.
Why is Pathfinder so heavy?
Yeah.
Guys, am I running?
Am I running?
Why does Apex feel different?
I'm so slow.
I need energy ammo.
I feel like...
um...
Horizon is faster than Pathfinder when...
when running.
Really?
I thought so.
I think it's just the animation.
They purposely like make the animation...
Like, because like Gibby feels slow, but he's the same speed.
Yeah.
It's just they made his animation so slow.
That it looks slow.
I see.
Oh wait, they're here.
They're right here.
Oh my god.
Where are they?
Here.
Behind the rock.
Flash, flash, flash.
I'm pushing.
I'm getting one for you.
He's so low.
Oh my god.
He was so low.
He's so low.
I'm gonna push.
His teammates are this side.
His teammates are here.
Okay, I'm getting this.
Oh nice.
Where did I get shot by?
Oh, you see his...
Their teammates are coming.
Okay, I'm going with Diddle.
I cracked one of them.
I'm shield selling.
I'm not with you, Diddle.
Okay, I'm coming, Diddle.
I knocked one.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm trying to see where they are.
Over here.
I'm still not so low.
I knocked two.
I almost knocked him.
1v3, Diddle.
1v3.
Okay, okay.
On me?
They're late.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Flash.
On me.
Oh, here, here, here.
Nice.
Oh they have lifeline.
Yeah, they have lifeline.
Oh, they have purple.
Purple Spitfire.
Nice.
Spitfire.
Here.
Yeah!
That's right.
They tried to push us, but they died.
How dare they.
They shouldn't have shot at us.
We would have left them alone if they didn't shoot us.
Good.
Oh.
Wait, the cure package is right next to us.
Yeah.
That's so good.
What's that?
It's a powder.
Does anyone want it?
You want it?
No, I already got two.
Last game I got two red guns.
So I'm willing to...
Okay, okay, I will use this.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I have my own package too.
Is there scope?
Scope?
No.
I want a bag.
I don't have...
Maybe there's a bag in my package.
I have two scope.
I'll find one.
There's three bats here.
Does anyone want them?
Yes.
I got it.
Yeah, I have four bats here.
I will get one.
Alright, let's go.
How many do you have here?
Yeah, I have four bats.
Battery?
Yeah, how many bats?
Two.
We grab one for her.
I'll grab it for her.
Okay.
I have an extra slot.
Wow.
I will get one for myself.
Okay.
Wow.
Wow, Ditto.
Ditto, you're really greedy.
I have four.
Yeah, but you could have...
I have four now.
Yeah, I have four too.
I grabbed it for you.
Thank you.
See, this is what separates me from Ditto.
I'm actually a good person.
Yeah, I bought this for you.
No.
Lily.
Lily?
No.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
If you want.
She does.
She deserves it.
No.
There's another bat.
Wait, there was another bat here.
I'm full now.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Well, thank Doki Bird.
Um, good game, captain.
It was a hard race, sir.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, Akiyo.
Where should we go?
Okay, here.
Um...
There's no...
Wait.
What?
What happened?
Did you punch me?
No.
What happened?
I thought there was an enemy.
Oh.
Wait, why?
Why did you think it was an enemy?
You punched me.
No, I didn't.
I didn't punch you.
I thought I got shot.
Nobody.
Wait, there's somebody all the way there.
You got shot?
I thought you...
Yeah.
Ditto immediately turned around.
I thought you got shot.
I didn't know he was there.
It's like...
Yes?
Everything in my house is...
She freaked out.
She was like Wait.
Wait.
I heard a, like a...
I heard the sound like a gun sound.
Yeah.
It's my left line air loom.
It's the air loom.
Icy.
It's so noisy.
Your air loom is so noisy.
Yeah.
Wait, there's no here!
No lie, no lie, no lie!
I like how...
I like how Ditto was like, really?
Over here.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Wait, what?
One guy with me!
How?
How can he get inside?
Can you get in?
Holy shit!
In one hit!
We're all so low!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm gonna grab that terrible trophy.
How can he get inside?
That was so scary.
That was so scary, that's why I'm here.
We could've all died from the nade right there.
I will kill them, I will kill them.
Right here, right here.
Okay, go!
Go, go, go!
Go kill them!
Go, kill them!
Go, go, go!
Why are you shooting me?
I thought you were gonna kill him!
I killed one.
I'm mad, I'm madding.
Last one, last one.
Lifeland ran, he ran, he ran.
You guys got it.
We can get him.
I don't think so, he's so far.
Everyone!
Oh shit!
We can go chase them.
Okay.
That poor guy.
Okay, I saw it, I saw it.
I see him, I see him.
I saw it, I see him, I see him.
Here I go, I saw it.
He's going right.
He's right here.
Here, here, here.
Hey.
You almost died.
It was worth it.
I got the shock stick melee.
That poor guy.
He's running from the cooties.
I'm walking down.
Got the cooties.
Wait, I want more energy armor.
I have to go back.
Okay.
I got gold res now.
Oh nice.
Yeah.
Oh, was there two teams?
You always get gold every time.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm gaming.
Wasn't there like two teams?
I thought it was two teams.
No, there's one.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's one.
There's nobody.
Oh, okay.
They were just super split up then.
Yeah, where's Pathfinder?
Yeah, where is his body?
Where's Pathfinder?
This box.
Oh, here, here.
Oh my god, he crawled so far.
How did he get here?
Oh my god.
He crawled so far, little guy.
Yeah, he was trying to survive.
Yeah.
He was trying to survive.
He has a respawn beacon too.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we need that.
I think there's a squad there.
Okay, let me go check.
You know what?
I'll go.
Yeah, I'll escort in the fragment.
Nobody here.
Let me check.
I'm going.
Yeah, I can hear them fighting.
There's somebody rezzing.
Okay.
And they're fighting here.
Okay, okay, we can go there.
What the...
Oh, they fight.
They fight.
Okay, okay, okay.
Donkey is really scary!
Oh my god!
Right?
Stop!
Scary!
Have lifeline!
It's gonna be so bad!
I think they already said it.
I'll use...
We're heading over.
Follow me!
Yeah, we're coming.
We're almost there.
Okay, all cracked!
Alright.
Go, Ditto!
Go!
Kill all of them!
1v3!
I'm getting across!
I'm on a cross!
Almost cracked Pathfinder!
I got one!
Last guy!
The other guy!
I got him!
Oh my god!
Oh, thank god!
Thank god!
On me!
Last guy!
Okay!
I got the bat!
Right here!
He's not low, but he's by himself.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
See?
So easy!
I'm gonna grab the car, but...
Wait!
The other squad...
Like...
There's another one just res nearby.
They all res here.
They all wanna die.
Okay, I have to lose some stuff.
Yeah, me too.
Alright, let's see...
Is there any extra light?
Oh, there is.
Let me check.
Where's the last body?
Oh, there it is.
No!
Nobody has...
Nobody has Barrel Stabilizer.
What do you want?
I see them.
They're all the way over there.
I made the...
Okay, okay.
Let's go.
Okay.
They're all the way over there.
Okay, we jump there?
Yeah, yeah.
We just head over there.
Yay!
Oh, be careful!
They have Devotion!
Oh, yeah.
They do.
Careful.
They're like all the way over there.
I think they're there.
Really?
No, I see them now.
No one there.
They're there.
They're up the hill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Over there.
Yeah.
Pretty far.
I think they're there.
Yeah, I'm heading closer.
Yeah, they're far.
Blue armor!
Oh, they're baby.
They're baby.
They have blue armor.
Yeah, they're running.
They're running.
They're all...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
They have purple armor.
He has purple armor.
Yeah, one of them is blue armor.
The purple armor is almost K.
Okay.
Doggy, be careful.
I'm behind you.
Oh!
Okay.
They...
They missed their ult.
Wait, the next team over there.
Okay, be careful.
Be careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We might have to go.
We might as well wait.
They're getting shot.
Yeah, they're getting shot by that team.
Oh, if...
Oh, that team's gonna get me, babe.
I want that spot.
That team's gonna get it.
Wait, I almost have EMP, Ditto.
Oh, nice.
I almost have it.
Just give me a second.
Okay, I can EMP them.
Wait, what?
Oh, my god.
It's pretty hard to push from here.
Yeah, because there's a team to our left right here.
Okay.
That one's looking at us.
It's okay.
Maybe we have to...
We have to wait.
Yeah.
No, I want to see how I can stick them.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I know.
I know how to fight.
How?
Kill that team first.
The left team or left team?
Left team.
Okay.
Kill that left team first.
Yeah, you pissed us off.
Yeah, go, Dad.
You made us angry.
Yeah, that's right.
I think the above squad is kind of...
Yeah, we can pull left.
Yeah.
Let me...
There's still one team that's missing.
Where did that last team go?
I think that's the last one.
They keep hitting us.
Oh, here, here.
Another team.
Here, here.
I saw them.
Okay.
130.
I don't know who it was, but...
Oh, my god.
Two.
Bangalore.
Bangalore passed by them.
Loba.
I broke Loba.
Oh, they're over here.
One is up here.
Okay, I'll go with Ditto.
One is up here, by the way.
Bangalore is low, too.
Yeah, I'm pushing up.
He's in here somewhere.
I think he ran, ran.
Yeah, he ran.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, yeah.
I'm pushing.
Okay.
He got it.
I'm thirsting.
All right.
Pushing up.
This team...
This team is so annoying.
You know what?
I'm gonna EMP them right now.
Yeah, fuck this team.
Wait, they ran.
I'm gonna EMP them anyway.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice EMP.
It's a full team.
Yeah, they're red.
Red armor.
That other team is red.
Yeah, they're red.
I'm gonna heal my...
Can you give me some doors?
Yeah, I can.
I'll come back to you.
Oh, they have a...
They have a Crypto, too.
They're cheating.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Oh, my God.
They also have a Crypto.
We have beta Crypto.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you see that?
To our left.
Yeah.
Doki, you got it.
Wait, where?
On me.
They're pushing.
They're pushing us.
I got him.
No, it's okay.
Yeah, that lifeline.
I was like, what?
When you did the scan.
Yeah, you did the scan.
I was like, I need to scan that.
What was he doing there?
Come on, let's try.
Oh, I don't have shield cells.
I'm gonna grab some shield.
I got shield cells now.
Okay.
Can you help out?
I have 75.
No, 10%.
Oh, lifeline.
Lifeline.
Okay.
I have 10%.
Oh, wait.
What?
I'm gonna try to get him.
Don't worry.
I'm clad.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
No shooting.
We're shooting you?
Over here.
I cracked him.
Be careful left side.
There's one guy.
This is two teams.
This is two and then this is three.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm packaged now.
I can get cover for us.
We need a push up for this.
Oh, wait, wait.
Drop, drop.
God, the other team is...
Okay, I have EMP.
I crypto dropped.
I got EMP.
I'm batting.
I'm EMP.
I'm gonna EMP now.
I'm sailing.
Okay.
I have a bass here.
We need some.
Oh my god.
I need that barrel staple.
I'm...
Okay.
Oh, is that yours?
EMP it again?
Mine.
I'm going.
I'm going to Doki.
Yeah.
I don't know where they are.
I'm going inside.
You know what?
I'm inside.
One here.
I think I'm...
I can't.
I got him.
Nice one.
We got...
I'm thirsting.
I'm thirsting this.
Wait, they're on top?
I thirsted.
I met this.
I'm sorry.
I got the lifeline.
I got one.
There.
Full dead.
Okay.
It should be two because we killed the lifeline member from that team.
Wait, I don't...
Okay, nice.
Yeah, we...
Let me go scan them.
Really?
Yeah, we have...
We have crypto.
Let's just wait.
Oh, yeah.
We have crypto.
Yeah, two.
Two.
Three.
Wait.
Who the fuck is that lifeline?
The lifeline was the team we killed earlier.
We just wait.
Wait for them to push us.
Yeah.
Sure.
Oh my god.
I...
I don't have a lot.
They may have Ashe.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
I will try to push them.
I cracked them.
I cracked two.
Okay.
I'm pushing.
I'll just make...
I'm gonna queue up and troll my lane.
First for...
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
He's here.
Cracked, the flash...
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Um...
Crack, crack, crack.
Horizon.
Horizon 1, Horizon 1.
Last one.
Horizon.
Okay.
Yeah.
You won again.
Wow!
Another win!
Girl squad!
Cootie squad!
Cooties are too strong.
Nice one!
Nice!
Another win!
Oh my god!
Who can stop us?
Neat hand sanitizer.
Oh my god!
Me?
Another girl squad can only stop us.
Another girl squad.
Four in a row.
Holy shit.
Four wins in a row.
We are so good.
Wait,
Ditto, are you almost flat?
Wait, what rank are you?
I think... I'm still gold too.
We'll see here what our rank is.
Because we got four games.
Aren't you gold three?
Yeah.
Because we got four games in a row.
We won four times in a row.
So like, we must be close to plat for Ditto now.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, those silvers never stood the chance.
Yeah.
It's also... it's gold now, guys.
It's not just... it's also gold now.
It's gold now.
Oh my god, gold one.
Gold one.
Yeah, it's really gold one.
Like, plat is already like master players and...
Yeah.
And there's master right now.
We literally got... we're getting it in like...
Yeah, there's masters right now.
It's not like master?
No, plat is masters right now because it just... the rank just started.
Yeah.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Mm-hmm.
Oh yeah, plat...
We're now fighting masters too.
Yeah, yeah.
We're fighting masters now.
We were fighting masters.
We've always been fighting masters, guys.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Actually, actually might have been, by the way.
Yeah, I think so.
I think they sure.
Some of them had... we had like a team with a decent aim at one point.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Like the Bangalore that sneaked up on Ditto as well.
That one was like...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Master?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Don't scare the grenades.
Let's go.
I'm gonna loot the back houses.
Okay.
No team.
No team this time.
Yeah, there's no one wanna contest us.
Yay.
They're scared.
They know we're here now.
Yeah.
They know our names.
Let's see.
I'm gonna go grab...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I did a lot of damage.
Yeah, you did.
You wanna try and get 20 kills, Ditto?
Yeah.
Ditto, you were so close.
Oh, yeah.
You got 16.
Yeah, I got 16.
You could've got a 20 bomb.
We were so close to a 20 bomb.
Oh, my God.
It's almost there.
It was so fun.
Oh, my God.
Killing people is really fun.
In game, right?
In game?
Yeah, in game.
I'm so happy.
In game.
What are you talking?
Whoa, Ditto.
Whoa.
Apex.
In Apex.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, because... except Apex, I can kill anyone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can kill anyone and, like, you won't get in trouble.
All right.
Ooh.
Nemesis.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to prowler.
Is car... is car good?
Car?
Car's always been good.
Yeah.
It's really good.
Okay, okay.
It's the better R9.
R9 is really bad right now.
Yeah, R9... yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I need to... I need to remove my pred... my pred keychain on the R9.
Why?
Because I can't see it.
Because I'm not... nobody's using it.
So, there's no point.
Okay.
I'm going to prowler.
I need to remove it.
I'm using... I'm using R9 this time.
I need to put, like, another gun.
Oh, what?
Which gun?
I don't know.
Maybe Nemesis.
Because I use the Nemesis a lot.
I think Nemesis is so nice.
Yeah.
Nemesis has always been really nice.
But Havoc is better.
Oh, yeah.
Nemesis is, like, good.
I'm going to grab the Havoc, actually.
More on Havoc, Nemesis.
Havoc, Nemesis.
Yeah, that's a lot of energy.
R9 is, like, good, too.
Oh, thank you.
R9 is good.
L-Star is alright for me.
I prefer Havoc if I see Havoc instead.
L-Star is nice.
L-Star is... but, I don't know, like, far, L-Star is a bit shaky.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
It's a pretty hard team.
I feel like they, like, removed the spawn rate for R9, too, because it's dog shit now.
So, wait.
I haven't found a...
I only found one R9 the entire time we were playing.
Oh, yeah.
There's no one used there.
Wait, there's actually...
There might be somebody there, by the way.
Oh, yeah.
There's, like, a disruptor here, too, by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think.
I'm gonna go look.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
I have to go home and wait here.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Are they close?
Yeah, pretty close.
On my ping.
It's coming.
Here.
One guy on...
Maybe they're...
Coming to you.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Can you get this guy?
He's fresh.
I'm pushing.
He's too far for me.
No, he was too far.
She's running so far.
He's scared.
Oh my god.
They used the knife.
Where are they?
On top.
I see them.
Oh my god, they're already there?
They're so far.
I'm gonna bring a package here.
I'm gonna loot.
Now they know we're here.
They don't know you're here.
Because I'm looting here.
One is running.
Where's the other team?
I'll get this guy for you.
He's right here.
I'm running.
I'm running so fast.
Dido, you keep running too.
Oh my god.
Dido.
He's okay, I'm good.
Doki, careful, there's three.
I'm here.
I got shot by the longbow.
I'm waiting.
Should I go up now?
I think they're running.
I think they ran.
No, they're gone.
They're all gone.
I have an evac tower.
Okay.
I'll be here.
While you guys jump.
I don't know where they're going.
I don't know where they went either.
They're here.
They snipe you there.
I don't know, I got sniped.
Right here.
All the way over there.
Are they rotating?
Why?
Over there.
Right in front of me.
Be careful.
Wait, this isn't our team.
They take the zip line.
What?
How do you have purple armor?
What the fuck?
Maybe they take only...
Oh, that guy is really...
Do you want to jump on him?
Fuck you.
Dido is rushing in.
That's a Rampart team!
Careful!
Careful, Dido!
I'll be here.
I can't look yet.
I'm gonna shot a button.
Oh my god!
I couldn't hear.
Lampart is low.
Wait, there's like three people on my face.
That's why I was like, that's a Rampart team!
That's another team.
This guy is dog shit.
What the fuck?
Who threw that?
Wait, he's low?
Doki?
No, I can't.
I'm getting long mode.
Wait, can you pick her up?
I can rez her.
Oh!
Nice one!
Oh my god!
I couldn't hear the Rampart.
Guys, I can't do anything about it.
I'm sorry.
You can go.
I'm gonna craft you.
Oh my god!
You're rezzing.
No!
It's okay.
We're gonna craft.
I told you that Rampart team!
They caught me!
I can hear the Rampart team!
I felt it!
That long mode guy was so bad though.
He missed like 100 shots on me.
And then he hit me the moment you need me to peek.
Okay.
Oh my god.
The only crafter is like all the way back here.
Wait, there's a Loba.
Wait.
Who's Loba ult is that?
Wait, wait!
I want to know if Plat player can team up with a Silver player.
No.
Only gold?
I don't remember.
Maybe Diamond you can.
We'll see.
When you get Plat we'll see.
Okay.
I'm almost gold too anyway.
Anyone knows?
You can!
Okay.
It's three rank difference.
So you can.
Okay.
Then totally fine.
I just want to know where the fuck that Loba ult came from.
Like who?
Where did that team go?
Oh my god.
Where did that team come from?
Alright.
It's my turn.
To be a hero.
Yay!
It would be funny if I crafted the wrong thing.
Shield battery.
I was like looking at it.
It's like reflex, you know?
Yeah.
Thank you, Doki.
Yay!
We're all alive.
Thank you.
This is your first...
Your first...
Wait, Doki!
There's a team!
Wait, wait, wait.
Which one?
Right here!
I'm jumping right now.
That's me.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
There's somebody behind us!
I'm backing up.
I'm gonna be there.
I didn't lie.
We should go back to...
Outlook?
No?
It's really far.
This is the closest risk.
Wait, they're pushing!
Are they?
I saw them run off.
I don't know where they're pushing though.
I think he ran.
They didn't really push.
What the fuck are they doing?
They're a bit scared.
I'm not sure why.
Wait, another team is fighting.
Oh, wait.
What?
Maybe here.
Okay, I need a little bit of ammo.
What the fuck?
They're throwing everything at me.
What happened?
What are they doing?
Another team here.
I'm going to you guys now.
I'm like, where are they?
We have to go inside the ring.
We can go in the car.
My chat is like the 1%.
You only killed 99% of the bacteria.
I'm going to go up here.
Wait, they're fighting.
They don't know.
You flank them.
Hiro and I are going to show up here.
Here.
What are they doing?
I don't know.
I got hit though.
They hit you?
I'm trying to get them back.
Go, Ditto.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
He's low.
One guy low.
We're looking.
I hit the purple armor too.
Oh my god.
I got armstacked.
I got stuck.
I broke one, Doki.
I can't see.
It's so hard to see.
Bangalore is low.
My nade is hitting.
Flash.
They're in my thermite.
Oh, he killed me.
I'm in.
I'm hitting.
Nice.
I'm pushing up.
Nice one.
He's so low.
Bangalore.
Doki, you can't do it.
I'm pushing.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
I'm down.
Yeah, he might come to you.
Just try and heal.
I don't know where.
Where did he go?
Nice one.
Down.
Oh, he's over there.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
His team is far.
Refresh your armor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll cover you.
I think that Bangalore is on the way.
No, he was outside.
He was outside the door.
I don't have ammo.
Is there any energy?
Yeah, there's energy in here.
There's a turbo charger in here.
Oh, I need that.
I'm gonna close this door.
Oh, we gotta leave.
Yeah, we gotta leave.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Maybe you can... you can...
You can... you can...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
We're in free...
Yeah, but... yeah.
We have to run.
It's okay.
Wait!
Are they racing?
Are they racing behind you?
Yeah.
No, no.
That's another team.
Blue armor.
Right here.
Just one person.
Flash, flash, flash.
I don't have ammo.
Just run.
Run.
Do you need energy?
What are you doing?
Here.
I need any energy.
Okay.
Nice, guys.
Wait, do you have a Q?
I do.
I do here.
I didn't know you had no meds.
I didn't know you were that poor.
I'll EMP them.
I don't have ammo.
I don't have any.
Just craft ammo.
I'm crafting ammo, too.
I'm grabbing ammo, as well.
Blow us?
They're below here.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, we gotta pray that this gives us...
Oh, we gotta go from below.
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta pray that this gives us mobile res beacon.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm leaving.
Wait, you're leaving?
I'm doing it for you.
Remember what I did.
Nothing.
No mobile res beacon.
I'm gonna go to the beacon.
I'm gonna res her at the beacon.
Oh, there's a beacon?
Oh, there's here.
Yeah, there's beacon.
I'm gonna do it now.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh crap.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
No problem.
I'm worrying.
Oh, I'm worrying.
It's okay.
I think they're gonna push to you guys.
No, they are.
They are.
Oh, they push here.
Loba.
Loba's almost here.
Oh, I'm trying my best to help.
Oh my god.
I was running all around.
Wait, you can res me, I think.
No, no, no.
I cannot.
No.
No, they're gone.
They're gone?
They're actually gone?
They weren't here.
There's another team.
Oh, nice.
Wait, let me get behind that.
Oh my god.
Wait.
See you, cute.
Nice.
Maybe you can get his tie.
I'm trying.
I'm trying so hard to live.
Oh, Hiro.
Goodbye, Hiro.
On top, on top, on top.
Be careful on top.
Holy shit.
Wait, what?
Wait, what did you just say?
Wait, I EMP'd all of them.
Oh, Hiro, there is no...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're getting literally crass.
What do you mean?
I'm not getting there.
I am not getting there.
You got this.
Holy shit.
The moment they walk up this, I'm dead.
It's the cape.
I hear the fucking rampart.
They ain't done.
They don't know?
Is that it?
Yeah.
Yeah, they don't.
They're lazy.
Kira, Kira, Kira.
If I shoot, I die.
Oh my god.
They shoot?
Holy shit.
Wait, maybe you should leave.
No, I can't.
There's people to my left.
There's a rampart right here.
Oh my god.
Please.
It's so hard.
Oh wait, they're re-deploying.
Yeah, they have to fly.
They have to, they're scared.
Leave you alone.
Leave me alone.
Only one?
Two.
They're slow.
You can go third them later, I think.
The last one is...
The last one, I...
I think there's no cover.
What the fuck.
What?
Two minutes left.
Anyone inside?
Is there anyone inside?
No?
Can you go inside?
This is so...
Oh my god.
Bro, stop!
No!
You're crazy!
You're really insane!
They're gonna lose.
They die?
No?
They're gone.
What?
How?
How did they let them do that?
I don't know.
It's so fucked up.
It's cause they're all the way up there.
What the fuck?
They're crazy.
They didn't shoot each other.
Why?
Was it a bloodhound?
That was the worst thing for us.
Wait, this team is like dead though.
No!
I streamed.
They eliminated us.
I can't believe it.
It's cause Ditto died.
We didn't have Ditto.
Ditto died too early.
Oh my god.
Ditto, you were super...
IGL died.
What do we do?
What do we do when our IGL dies?
Yeah, we just can't do anything without Ditto.
I'm back.
Yeah, I can't believe it.
They killed our strongest cootie.
You're almost plat though.
Oh really?
Yeah.
How do you know?
I just got to go one.
Maybe two champs.
Yeah, two wins ago.
So she should be close now.
We got top three.
Aren't you like just a few points away or something?
Yeah, you should be.
Okay.
We stop when...
Hero gets gold and Ditto gets plat.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what we call it.
Oh my gosh.
Guys, how many wins have we got so far?
I feel like we won like every...
almost every game.
Like 80 games.
Why there's a lot of teams here?
Why?
Oh, there's a lot of people.
Yeah, why they win that?
Wait, they're all going there.
Holy shit.
That's not even where the good loot is.
That's the thing.
Wait, there's someone... one right here.
Okay, kill them first.
Oh, apparently we had like five wins.
Oh, really?
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Oh, a lot.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where's the team?
You said there's a team here?
Yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
They're in the middle of the area.
Oh, the house?
Yeah.
Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Let's kill them.
Last time I played with Appiah, it's so hard to get champion.
I know, right?
Yeah, you need all girl squad.
Wait, what?
Where did they go?
They're here?
They killed somebody.
They killed...
Over here.
I'm going to bottom.
Careful, careful.
I got one.
Tommy?
Flash, flash, flash, you got him.
Nice.
Oh my god, he has a PK!
He has a massive, massive, massive, massive PK.
I don't know.
Massive, massive, massive, massive.
Right here, on the stairs, on the stairs, on the stairs.
They're not resing, he's not resing yet.
Second floor?
Okay.
I can go, I can go.
He's resing, resing now, resing now.
Oh, they're resing, they're resing.
Oh, we're resing too.
I will go try to cross the door here.
We thirsted one though, we thirsted one.
Maybe you can't touch me?
Be careful, be careful.
Flash, got him!
Nice, nice.
Yeah, nice.
Nice!
Yeah, girl squad, girl squad!
Yeah, we're resing, we're resing, we're resing.
Okay, I need a heal and...
Oh no, my drone!
My drone!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm healing myself, I don't have drone right now.
I have as.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
I got two shots, I got two shots from Mastiff and I'm dead.
Yeah, that Mastiff fucked us up.
That was scary.
Yeah, I saw that, I was like, oh god, you guys both went down immediately.
Yeah, I like looked at him and I instantly died.
And I was like, okay.
I'm just like, yeah, that sounds right.
Okay, I'm healing you.
I got Mastiff.
I'm ready too.
Now it's your turn.
Alright.
Let's go.
There should be a lot of teams in front of us here.
Yeah, I'm gonna scan them right now.
They're racing, they're racing, they're racing.
Oh, okay.
You should come here.
I have EMP.
Nice.
Wait,
that's a golden longbow!
Where is that?
I need it.
I wanna run golden longbow.
Oh, they destroyed it before you could do it.
Too bad.
There's just one guy.
Yeah, there's just one guy.
I'm gonna cross for you.
I'm almost there.
I'm here.
Where are they?
Why is armor in blue?
Oh my god, I got killed.
You got crossed.
I see.
I got so fast.
Okay, wait.
Where is Patiam?
I'm gonna get him.
They're chasing you.
Wait, they're chasing me?
No, they know.
They know I'm a lifeline.
Grab her!
I'm gonna send them on a wild goose chase.
Did you get it?
No!
I just crafted.
Okay, they're chasing me.
I just wanted to longbow.
There's two people on the death box.
Okay, so the bloodhound is just chasing me.
There's only one?
You want to be one bloodhound?
Wait, wait.
You can last me here.
There's a person that acclimatized.
You want me to rest you here?
No, wait.
Don't craft it!
No, you already crafted!
I crafted it earlier.
It's okay.
You already crafted.
Don't worry.
I'll get your banner.
I'll get it.
You get my banner.
Oh my god.
I saw the scab.
I didn't know they would get to me so fast.
They got to me so fast.
Oh my god.
I really feel so sorry for you.
You think I can get it?
I don't know.
I believe I can.
You think this is enough?
The distance?
If you couldn't, you can just carve at the camp.
Oh, you can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Let me try.
It's too far.
Can you?
It's a far distance.
Oh, 30.
Is it?
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I can grab my loot.
Nice.
Where are they?
I have no idea.
I'm a animal.
I didn't know either.
I got fucked up.
Where did I die?
What?
They stayed?
They actually...
They can't get another point from me.
You can't respawn me.
They stayed?
They actually stayed.
Oh my god.
They got me.
They're gone.
Trust, trust.
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god, Hiro.
They're gonna come for you.
Oh my god.
I'm running!
Maybe you can raise us.
Right here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're gonna get shot off the zip.
Trust me.
You're gonna get shot off.
There's two squads here.
Okay.
It's okay.
You just gotta run to us.
Because we...
Let me see.
Oh my god.
Hiro!
They're right behind you.
Hiro, they're right behind you.
No.
We fight.
I need to fight him.
We don't have anything.
What do you mean we fight?
I EMP'd him.
It's okay.
There's another team here.
There's a team right here.
Okay, go ahead.
Guys.
It's okay.
There's a team right...
Guys, there's a team right in front of me.
Why?
How can I survive?
Guys.
I think I'm gonna die to the zone.
I'm gonna risk this.
Syringe!
Oh no.
Hiro, live.
Hiro, just live.
Hiro, no!
I can't live.
You guys gotta live.
There's another team here.
Oh my god.
They're in front of me.
They're in front of me, too.
Oh my god.
No!
Ditto, you gotta live.
You gotta live, Ditto.
I don't help.
You can come to my spot, Ditto.
I have heal.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying!
Just follow me!
It's okay.
Wait, I don't think Ditto can even res you.
She's so low.
Oh no, it's them again!
It's them!
Oh my god!
They have Pathfinder!
Pathfinder and Revenant!
They chased us!
Oh my god, it's them again!
Holy shit!
Okay, we're just trolling, you know?
Yeah, yeah guys.
We're not playing our best right now.
We were like...
No, just res here, res here.
You know, we...
We actually played smart.
We would not have resed there.
We were just...
Just trolling, guys.
Okay.
Guys, if we wanted to try...
We won't troll.
Yeah, we won't troll this time.
We won't troll this time.
If we don't troll, we're gonna keep winning again.
Yeah, yeah guys.
See you.
Winning all the time is like boring, right?
Yeah, winning all the time is so boring.
We gotta make it more challenging, you know?
We gotta make it harder.
You know?
Alright.
Where do we go?
I don't know.
You...
You jump.
Where do we go?
Ditto.
Um...
You...
You decide.
No.
I will never decide.
Ditto.
Yeah, but...
You loose.
You are going to just go back tomorrow.
You are going to...
I'm..
Sorry Hammu.
I'm so sorry, no other game.
Okay that's enough.
Alright, that's enough?
That's enough?
I agree.
Okay.
Yo, that's enough.
Get the...
Leave it right now.
I saw them.
Landing on us.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, see, I saw them landing on us.
Wait, they're actually on us, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
On me.
One here, one here.
Oh no.
I got one.
Oh my god!
I have...
Wait, we have two squads on us.
Oh my god!
I have... I have one thing!
I have one thing!
Oh no!
I just knocked one here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I'm coming.
Okay, one guy here, one guy here.
Okay, okay, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
Oh shit, he... he killed.
He put a... he put a...
Wait, he's finishing!
Finish, finish!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Here, here, here.
Maybe you can tab us?
Yeah.
Oh, they're still here, they're still here, they're still here.
Okay.
Oh god.
Another squad.
Wait, there's another team.
We got another squad!
It's an enemy!
Oh god.
Yeah, it's good, it's good.
Ditto, ditto, ditto!
Wait!
I'm alive!
We're two here!
Run, run, run, run!
Just run, just run.
There's so many people.
There's two people here.
There's just too many.
There's too many, there's too many people.
I have no ammo, I have no more ammo.
Why did they land on us?
I have no ammo, I have more ammo.
I couldn't even get a platter.
Holy sh...
Oh my god, they landed here too!
Oh no!
Wait, go, um, the tree?
How about the tree?
You can, you can jump tower.
Oh, you're right, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Do you have any light to jump tower?
Oh my god!
I don't have ammo!
What the...
It's okay, no, no, no.
We're still trolling, don't worry.
Yeah, we're still trolling, guys.
We're still...
Oh, I made two teams fight each other!
Oh, wait, wait, A1!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I started in a fight.
Wait, look.
We are in the plat lobby.
Yeah, we're in the plat lobby, guys.
Look.
Okay, okay.
Look, look, look.
We have to get it.
Guys, we should try it now, guys.
We're in the plat lobby.
Okay.
We're in the plat lobby, guys.
Wait, is it a plat already?
No, right?
No, no, no.
No, we're just in the...
Yeah.
She just gold one, so we get moved to plat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're going to move to plat lobby.
Okay, now we know that the players are a lot better now.
We can't randomly play around anymore.
We have to play position, positioning.
Oh my god.
Oh, I guess I'll play positioning.
Yeah.
I'm gonna play positioning.
Wait, I thought you said pathfinder is bad.
Why are you playing pathfinder?
Pathfinder is slow.
Yeah.
Pathfinder is good.
Why is he good?
All right.
See, look.
They're masters.
Wait, they have a bronze on their team, too.
And two default skins.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, we're landing soon.
I'm running safe now too.
Hey, how come now Pathfinder is good after you say Pathfinder is garbage?
I didn't say that.
I just said that he was low.
No, you said he was big hitbox.
Didn't you say that?
It's okay.
I can play Pathfinder.
Now it's okay.
Now I know how to move.
I know, yeah.
My memory is back.
Okay, now you remember how to play FPS games.
Yeah.
Sudden memory loss.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, now I know.
It's okay.
After playing Horizon, she learned how to play Pathfinder.
Pathfinder, yeah.
That's how it works.
Yeah.
Here you go, little.
Wingman on Pathfinder is kind of scary.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we saw her.
You scared everybody away.
Yeah, we saw you on the Wingman as Pathfinder.
It was really scary.
I say, I say.
But I'm not gonna use Wingman in this lobby.
You're not going to?
Okay.
Oh, I have it.
Like, everyone has a good aim.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh, no!
You got blue!
What happened?
No!
I got purple!
Ditto, I saw blue!
Why did you say oh no?
Why?
Then why...
Why you said blue?
Then why did you say...
I got purple here.
Then why did you say oh no?
Because I got purple.
But why were you...
Did you say...
Why were you sad about it?
She wants gold?
No, no.
Yeah, I want gold.
I want gold.
I was like, wait.
Ditto's chat.
Can you clip that gold?
You can clip that purple that she got?
No, here.
Here.
Ditto, can you...
Who do you trust?
Who do you believe?
I'm talking about your chat.
No, no.
I'm asking.
I'm asking Hiro.
God.
I gotta go to the toilet.
Like, I gotta go back now.
No.
No, Hiro!
Hiro!
I don't...
Hiro, no.
You have to choose.
I don't think Hiro trusts you, Ditto.
I don't think she trusts you.
Oh, Hiro ignores.
Yeah, she doesn't trust you.
That's why.
She doesn't trust you too.
No, she trusts you.
She trusts me.
She trusts...
She believes me when I said you didn't get purple.
She didn't say that.
Hiro.
You have to choose.
I have to choose?
Hiro, if you don't choose, somebody in the world is gonna die.
Hiro.
You gotta pick.
Alright, guys.
Here is...
I forgot.
Whoever this is most damage, I'll trust you.
My PID.
I'm going to play the red keychain that I can never see because nobody ever runs R9 anymore.
Wait, earlier that octane was running R99...
Ugh, she doesn't count.
That octane doesn't count.
Octane?
Doctane?
The octane doesn't count.
Alright.
I rarely see it though, honestly.
Yeah, I rarely see the R9.
Wait, they didn't open this VIN.
I want to go to the dome to grab something.
Alright, okay.
And we have to... evil armor.
Oh yeah, we need evil armor, yeah.
But here, I give Doki this thing.
Oh, yeah I need that.
I'll take it long.
Okay.
I want a scope too.
Wait, what kind of scope?
2 of... 2?
2H or G?
Alright, we'll find.
Any scope, any scope.
Okay, I'll go find.
Chat, you know we're serious when we start crafting.
We were not crafting earlier, now we actually have to craft.
We just randomly...
Oh wait, I have to go get that evil harvester.
Yeah, you were supposed to craft the evil harvester.
You know?
Okay.
You were ahead of us.
Yeah.
They're actually fighting here.
Oh wait, we should go for that.
Be careful.
There might be over 2 teams.
Okay.
I mean we can tell from Hiro's thing.
Yeah.
I'll check.
Where are they fighting?
They're fighting over in this town?
Yeah, over there.
Yeah, in the town.
I can like scout it out now too.
I don't need anything here.
Are they high fighting?
No.
I'm checking.
They are fighting.
They are fighting right now.
They're still fighting.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here.
They're fighting right in front of me.
I'm going, I'm going.
Okay, okay.
They're hard fighting now.
They're hard fighting.
Okay, okay.
They're high ground.
Okay.
Here.
Can you put a zip?
Okay, okay.
I will use the zip line.
Here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Then I will go and heal them now.
I'm gonna...
I'm climbing up on the stairs.
Okay.
They have one knock at least.
They're listening.
They have at least one knock.
All right.
Down here, down here.
He's down here.
Flesh, flesh.
Oh, they're running, they're running, they're running.
There's one down there.
Yeah, that guy is Flesh.
Here, here, here, here.
Um...
Okay.
Inside?
They were Flesh, yeah.
Down.
Yeah.
Two people, two people.
Inside here.
Okay.
I think they're running.
Here, here, here, here.
Outside, outside, outside.
There's one here.
Oh, one Flesh, one Flesh.
There's one over here?
There's one running.
They're all running.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
On me, on me, on me.
Yeah, he did it.
I'm with you.
If you lose that one, we won.
I'm here.
Inside the building.
Okay.
I am heading to Ditto.
Second floor.
There's one over there.
There's one over here.
He's running to him, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
They're together.
Broke, broke, broke, broke.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm pushing up.
Nice.
Are they rising or no?
I finished one team.
Okay.
Right here, right here, right here.
He's running.
Okay.
They're using jump pad.
No, advantage, advantage.
I hear them.
Right here, right here, right here.
Yeah, right in front of me, right in front of me.
Oh my god.
He's not low.
Yeah.
He's dead.
Okay, I got the belt.
Where's the last guy?
Another one is running.
Yeah, yeah.
He's running, he's running.
Yeah.
I'm gonna thirst him.
I'm thirsting him for loot.
Okay.
We don't have anything.
Oh, new team, new team, new team.
Behind us.
Okay, we have to, we have to go to the other side.
Oh, we have to push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming over.
There's a new team right here.
There's a new team here.
Okay.
We have to go to zone anyway.
He's here.
He's hiding here.
Hello.
We know you're here.
Oh my god, I'm in M-San.
Got him, I got him.
Wait.
There's...
No.
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait.
Another one.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Wait, wait.
Here.
Why?
Wait a minute.
There's one.
One more?
We gotta go to zone, I feel like.
Okay, okay.
How you going?
Um, lower siphon.
Yeah, I'm gonna go here and then take the zip.
Oh, nice.
And grab the Evo too.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we're the...
We're like, wait a minute.
Why is...
The guy's not dead?
Not dead?
Oh.
Where is it?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's okay.
I'll just go...
Go alone?
Yeah, I'll go, I'll go, I'll go scare.
Oh, another team here.
Okay.
We're here already.
You're by yourself, you're by yourself.
Oh my god, I'm trying to fly.
Oh, no!
It's okay.
No!
We gotta run, we gotta run, we gotta run.
They're coming to us, they're coming to us.
Only two!
You know, you know, you know, you know.
There's another one here, another one here.
Only two and another one here.
Oh god!
Yeah!
No!
Joy!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why?
You know, run!
You know, it's not smart to be here, you know?
Hey, they're teaching me.
You know?
They know you.
I wanna run, I wanna run.
I really wanna run.
But like...
Wait...
What?
From chasing people to getting chased.
I don't know if I'm safe.
No, you're safe.
What?
Wait, they're...
They, they...
Oh, that's what I'm saying.
Their ears or eyes are really good.
Um, there's people on the left.
Okay.
But I don't have anywhere else to go.
Hiro, you might be able to come back.
I'm so safe.
Hiro, another team.
Oh, I'm not safe.
I'm not safe.
I lied.
They're right here.
I see the darkness.
Oh my god!
Wait... wait, there's someone on my face!
No, they don't know, they don't know, they don't have a bloodhound.
There's no way they have a bloodhound.
What about me?
I'll get you.
I'll crawl closer, I'll crawl closer.
I'm crawling closer, I'm gonna die to the lava, but I'll crawl closer to you.
Maybe you can grab my banner?
Yeah, I'm gonna get it.
Don't worry, I'm closer to you, Hiro!
I'm closer!
It's okay!
I'm coming!
Wait, they threw so many shields out.
I'm outside the ring, by the way.
I'm outside the ring.
Don't worry, I'm watching your heels.
It's okay, it's okay.
You're okay, you're okay.
Is it only ring one or two?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's ring one, it's ring one.
No!
Don't worry!
Don't worry, don't worry.
Don't worry, you're just gonna get closer, you're getting closer.
Wait, it's ring two?
It's a little bit painful.
Wait.
Oh, you have to...
You have to heal first.
Yeah, you have to heal.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, it'd be awkward if you cancelled your heal right now.
I'm being that.
I'm dead.
I can't get the banner.
I don't know if you should do that right now.
I don't know if you should do it while you're in the ring.
I don't... that's my...
I believe, I believe.
You grab, you grab...
Doki's banner and go to the tree.
You have to grab it now, there's 19 seconds left.
Okay, got it, I got it!
Here, right here.
Oh...
Oh, nine seconds.
Got it, got it, got it!
Go fast, fast, fast, fast, fast!
Yeah!
Be careful, another team.
Reza's over there.
You see that?
Yeah, wait.
You can make it.
Is your drone far enough for that?
Are we gonna...
You're gonna die.
I have a respawn beacon.
I have a beacon.
Yeah, but the moment you put that beacon down, everybody's gonna look at you.
How about, how about launch site?
Do you think... do you think...
I can go here.
She's not gonna make it.
There's no way there's someone underneath.
She's okay.
Yeah.
She doesn't see me.
No, no, no, no, no.
There's sound.
There's a sound.
There's people here.
Here, do you hear that?
Go left, go left, go left, go left, go left.
Oh!
We should be able to climb it?
Oh, okay.
Oh, there's people here though.
Is there?
I think so.
There's none.
Oh yeah, one team.
We can't see them.
Is there?
Where did this come from?
I think they're inside the house.
Be careful, be careful.
I think, yeah, I think they're inside the house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why would it be like locked?
It's a cave.
We can, we can...
How do you get back up?
Hiro, how are you gonna get back up?
It's okay.
Hiro!
Hiro, you're stuck down there.
Which way?
I'm gonna revive you.
You have to go back.
I don't think this is...
Hiro, I don't know, Hiro.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna come back up, Hiro.
This is round 3.
I'm gonna revive.
I'm gonna revive you guys.
We're gonna revive us in zone?
Don't worry, dude.
At 30 seconds, I'll...
No, 45, I'll put a respawn down.
What?
Wait, but...
How are you gonna...
No, then you guys can land on top.
And I'll...
I might die.
You're the zone 4.
Hiro, you're dying.
Okay, I believe.
Put it down, do it.
I believe.
Guys, are they still there?
They're gone, they're gone, they're gone, they're gone.
Oh, nice.
Maybe you can go...
Can you go back and come...
Come up here?
I'll try.
I don't know, I don't think so.
I don't believe.
I'm gonna watch Hiro's HP go down.
Can you activate the...
Oh no.
Oh my god, I'm safe.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
We have to go, guys.
Guys, we have to go.
Nice Hiro, nice.
Oh, nice Hiro lives.
The power of Ditto believing in you, you live.
Okay.
Where do you have a creeper?
Oh, that creeper's gonna kill us.
Be careful, be careful.
I don't have healer.
We have to kill this.
I'm gonna EMP them right now.
Okay.
There's also a team right here.
They're fighting too.
Wait, they're not here.
They're not?
They went here.
There's a loot.
Take the loot.
Go, go, go.
I have an ultimate cell for you.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god, this is ours now.
Wait, there's someone here.
There was.
It's okay, it's okay.
They went outside.
I don't feel okay.
The Pathfinder.
Wait, it hurts, it hurts, it hurts.
How do we...
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
We are still alive.
It's the Pathfinder.
Why did you all shoot?
Where is the Pathfinder?
Is he solo?
Where did he go?
Where did he come from?
Is he solo?
I think he's here.
I didn't see him at the bottom, too.
I didn't see him.
I didn't see him either.
I was like, where did he go?
I cracked him and then he disappeared.
He really disappeared.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
Oh my god, we can get Ditto to plat.
I believe.
It's okay.
Wait, how much is it to plat?
I don't know, we have to leave the lobby to find out.
Really?
You can't find out in the journey.
We're not leaving.
Ditto, rage quit.
I can't see my point.
Yeah, Ditto, rage quit so we can see it.
I won't let you down.
Okay.
I want to die.
Okay, I'm gonna go home.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
You know we're playing...
Now we're actually serious.
We're landing on real...
We're landing on... for no contest.
I'll hit the bottom.
Okay.
I'm gonna get to the center too.
Nice.
Ooh, a purple helmet.
Nice gun.
Okay.
What is the center?
What do you have in the center?
How did I die last time?
Oh, I got shot while...
using a jump tower.
Yeah.
Yeah, you did.
You were the last...
There was like a full team that shot you down.
And we watched it happen.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
It was so sad.
I just...
I watched you die in front of me and then I died too.
Well, I think...
Why did you die?
Because there was two teams.
Because the other team...
looked at me and I died.
There's a Havoc here.
Do you want it?
No.
No?
You don't want the Havoc?
No.
Damn.
I'll take the Havoc then.
Havoc is for the weak.
Havoc is for the weak?
I'll remember that.
If I see you ever use the Havoc again...
Yeah?
Yeah, I'm the weak.
I'm weak.
There's two teams in Syphon.
If we want a third party... Holy shit!
Look at Lodge site.
Wait, is there one person there?
What is that?
That's one person, isn't it?
Yeah, there's one person at staging.
Staging, staging.
Yeah, because their teammate is at Mirage.
Okay.
That's why.
I will go get Irohazard and Scandering.
Okay.
Woo!
Okay, we have to play the zone.
Alright.
Oh my god, we're playing zone, guys.
Yeah, we're playing zone.
Girl squad is trying now.
Alright.
Where's the zone?
Oh, little.
Okay, I'm scanning.
I'm gonna grab the health chest.
It's probably...
Kaotao?
Maybe Kaotao?
No!
What is this?
Oh, this frag.
Oh my god.
There's no one.
No.
Alright, guess we're going to frag.
Should we go through the tunnel?
Yeah, yeah.
I think we can go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Lifeline is heading over.
Wee!
Here I come.
I need a skill.
Oh my gosh.
Hurry up, Lifeline.
Hurry up.
I'm Lifeline!
I don't have any mobility.
But Kaeptoe.
Kaeptoe doesn't have any ability, too.
Well, actually he does.
I think when he level out.
Like, if his drone gets destroyed, he moves faster.
Yeah, see?
Really?
Lifeline has nothing.
Yeah, he's like, I'm going to go.
It actually does.
There's an upgrade where your drone time is like, faster and also you get like a speed boost.
I didn't even believe you.
She was like, really?
Really?
I can't believe it.
This sounds like a lie.
Oh, you're trying to say...
Are you trying to say that Hiro would lie to you?
That's fucked up.
Oh, no, no, no.
I can't believe you would think that Hiro would lie to you like that.
Is this faster?
Yeah.
Your first time knowing it, huh?
Yeah, she doesn't play crypto.
How did you know that?
Because I level it out.
Yeah, Hiro, how do you know?
I'm playing crypto.
It's not like you played crypto for four hours now.
Oh, my God.
It's been four hours.
Yeah, it's been four hours.
I'm playing crypto.
Alright.
Let's go to... when you go to Frag.
Okay.
I want Carbine.
No.
Because I have Carbine.
No Carbine for you.
Okay, I want to go grab that too.
Yeah, we got to get that.
Okay, turn... turn...
Yeah.
Get back.
Oh, I got one.
Oh, wait, no.
I should get that.
I can take the heat shield.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you can take it.
Okay.
Now we have to...
We have to think now.
We got to use our brains.
Okay.
We have to use our brains.
I'm going to be throwing my drone out constantly.
If we get a house, we can just chill.
Yeah, we have... yeah.
I think we should...
Which house?
Which is a good house?
IGL, which house?
I pay for this.
This house?
Alright.
That house.
This house.
Okay.
There's a lot of angles to take care of though.
Oh, no.
It's inside the lane.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could try this house, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like this house is better than this house.
This house has too many angles.
Yeah, that house is not good.
Yeah.
Wait, there's one team?
Well, let's see if they're in this house.
They're really far.
They're scanning.
Oh, yeah.
They're scanning this.
There's a bat here.
Let's see if I remember how to climb this.
Okay, go this house and...
Wait, did they change this?
They changed it.
Did they?
Yeah.
You used to be able to climb this.
Can you still do it?
You can climb here, you know, Doki.
Like here.
Oh, shit.
There's no cause.
Okay, I'm coming back.
The purple armor.
Where is it?
It's right over there.
Let me check.
Behind the bin.
Yeah, I got spam here.
91.
The catalyst is blue.
Let me check.
Okay, there.
No, not your drone.
It's fine.
Oh, careful.
Come here.
I can give you the gun.
I don't...
I think they're gonna push.
Okay, okay.
I'm looking.
No, they're not.
They're...
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Oh, my god.
They're flashed.
The bloodhound was so low.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, they're coming down here.
They're on me.
Careful, careful.
Grenade.
I'm fine.
I have another nade.
It's fine.
I almost had my drone back.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Blue, purple.
Down here.
Okay.
If you're EMP, I will go for this wall.
They might push with that.
I'm looking.
How many seconds?
I don't think they're gonna...
Kidnapping, kidnapping, kidnapping!
EMPing.
Nice.
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Bloodhound!
I have to drop.
I got one.
I'm battling.
I'm batting.
I'm coming over.
I dropped down.
They're resing.
Another team here.
Another team.
I'm hitting this one.
They don't...
Okay.
I'm going.
Down, down, down.
Bloodhound low.
Another team.
Ducky.
I have to go.
I will go.
Oh, I'm dead here.
I'm dead dead.
I'm going.
I will run.
Just run.
Yeah, just run.
Full team.
Mommy.
Just run.
Okay.
It's fine.
They also have one solo left.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can leave.
Don't worry.
Yeah, just leave.
Just leave.
Yeah, and craft this.
Yeah.
Let's like... You got 30.
That's what they get.
I'm like, why would you fucking flirt us?
Why did they push?
Yeah, why did they push?
You stupid?
This is why you're gonna stay in gold forever.
This is why you'll never get back to MasterChef.
There's no crafter here too.
Is there?
You have to go all the way.
Yeah.
Why would they push us?
I don't know.
They're so stupid.
I believe in ditto.
Oh my god.
Just go through it.
Oh, there.
Where are they going?
They're on top.
They're getting stuff.
Yeah.
Where are they?
Oh, they're getting shot at.
What?
What are they doing?
I'm so confused.
Why are they here?
Are they gonna try and sneak away?
Yeah, but now she needs to find a way to get a crafter.
I don't think there's... unless a crafter drops next to her.
There's literally zero crafters.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Oh!
What the heck?
What the fuck?
How can they... Oh!
Where did they come from?
I feel like they were fighting me.
Yeah.
What?
Where did they come from?
Wait, this is a duo.
Wait, there was a team here.
I got shot.
This isn't a team.
Yeah.
This is another team.
Where did they come?
They were hiding.
They were ratting here this entire time.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
They were ratting.
That stupid team that rushed us for no reason.
Yeah.
They rushed us just to die.
Did they eliminate it?
Yeah, they died.
I'm pretty sure they got eliminated.
Yeah.
The one that first pushed us.
They got eliminated.
They're so stupid.
They literally died just to kill us.
Yeah.
It's not stream snipers.
It's people being really stupid in rank.
It was separates like good players with unga bunga players.
Oh, the other team did BM though.
Oh, wait.
What BM?
Yeah.
The other one that killed us after.
Oh, did they?
Yeah.
I didn't realize.
They just like insta-killed me.
I understand.
They didn't insta-kill me.
I was like, oh.
Oh, they didn't insta-kill you.
Oh, they insta-killed me.
Yeah.
Alright.
One team maybe.
One team?
Okay.
Yeah, one team.
Where are they landing?
Okay.
I see a... We can go together.
I'm looting the bottom.
They might land on left.
Okay, I'll go with Ditto.
Okay.
Oh, they went center.
They went center.
They're on me.
Okay.
Inside.
Coming.
Oh, two teams!
Two teams!
I'm backing out!
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm backing out.
There's two.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm backing out to loot more.
There's three!
What the heck?
Why are you here?
This is shitty loot.
I think we go Harvester.
We are Harvester.
I don't know.
I mean, I love Slytherin.
Why three?
What the heck?
Yeah, what are they doing here?
What?
Why?
Why are you saying three?
What do they want?
Yeah.
I thought it was like one team, but then like...
Yeah, and then another team landed on the other side.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm like, this is not... there's not enough loot for three.
There's not enough loot for three.
There will be three on me.
There's not even enough loot for this.
I'm okay here.
Yeah, if...
If we...
If we won, we didn't have a lot.
Yeah, we lived.
That's all that matters.
We lived.
Whoa!
The server lagged for me.
Did it lag for you guys?
No.
Oh my god.
I have all the signs right now.
Oh, they're supposed to be here.
Oh, it might be a bit laggy.
Yeah, I have all the signs.
It's coming here.
Alright, I'm coming over to you.
I'm okay.
There's people here in Lava Siphon, by the way.
Okay.
I saw like the middle was looted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I saw it.
Whee!
Oh no!
Oh!
The server lagged.
You just stopped moving.
I saw you were in place, so I knew I was lagging.
You got... you got...
package loss.
I'm looting everything right now.
Okay, okay.
Oh, it disappeared.
It disappeared.
I think I'm okay.
I'm okay now.
Oh, it's looted here too.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm with Hiro.
It's looted here.
Okay, I'll go to heal.
Maybe guys...
Maybe we can... we can loot guys.
Yeah, we need...
Let's get that Evo Harvester up the hill though.
I feel like...
I'll go get it, sure.
I can check if there's anybody.
Oh, it's lagging for me too.
It's lagging.
Okay, I'm not crazy then.
That's good to know.
Oh, there's a team that just flew...
Where did they fly to?
I don't know.
They flew like here.
Alright.
Wait.
That's really dangerous.
I'm with you?
Yeah.
I'm looking for you.
Yeah, they jumped Howard.
Whew.
I'm gonna loot this.
Yeah, we need that Evo.
We need that blue armor.
We can go here, I think.
Can you scan here?
Okay, okay.
Scan the beacon.
I think we can loot here.
Yeah, we can.
I'm pretty sure nobody looted this.
Be careful.
There might be another team come from...
Yeah, it could be.
It's not looted.
I'm looking at it now.
Yeah, it's not looted.
Yeah, they jumped from that place.
I'm gonna...
I'm putting my Evo...
Wait, there's one guy.
Be careful here too.
His team is there.
On the tunnel?
Two people?
Yeah.
Oh, there's Blade.
One there and two in the tunnel.
Yeah.
Where's his team then?
No, it's still... Yeah.
No.
Should we... No, there's three there, I think.
I think maybe they're super close.
I think they'll head to us, right?
Or they're gonna go around.
They might go around since you scanned them all.
Yeah.
We could just go... We can just go head to zone now.
Okay.
Yeah, cause there's too many teams behind.
Do you have battery?
There's 16 teams still.
I have two.
I have three.
I have zero.
I have three bats.
I can give Hiro one.
Okay.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Okay.
There's...
There's one team in Monument.
They might scan the ring after the ring.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
We need to scan the ring too.
Yes.
I'm gonna... Can people scan the ring?
No?
Hiro can if she... No.
Wait.
Only people?
Oh, no, no.
Only people.
Yeah.
Okay.
Before he could, yeah.
Yeah.
Before he could, but now he can't.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
One team there.
I think they wait for the ring.
Okay.
Hiro, I got you more bats.
Wait for them to scan the ring first.
And we scan.
Thank you.
Okay.
Then I'll go here.
Me too.
I wanna see if there's a scope.
Yeah.
I think if we fight, we'll get dirt by the party.
I think so too.
We gotta be careful.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We are so careful now.
Scary.
Yeah.
They don't scan the ring?
No?
They're not scanning.
Oh, I think they scan the ring.
They already scan earlier.
They rotate it.
Not yet?
One squad.
So they're still here.
They're rotating.
No, there's one squad here.
Here.
Oh, okay.
There's two squads now.
Okay.
Two squads?
All right.
Okay.
Ooh.
Can I scan?
Yeah.
Just...
Let me check this game.
I'm looking.
This team did not come here.
They went there.
I'm scanning.
No.
There's another team right here.
Okay.
All right.
There's there.
I'm gonna head to Ditto then.
I'm heading to Ditto.
Okay.
They went to the tunnel.
Maybe we can go to the right.
All right.
We can go from the right.
Maybe.
I'm heading over.
I need a scope too far of my carbine.
If anybody sees one.
I'm running at zero scopes.
I have one and two.
Do you need it?
No, I don't want that.
I need a 2 or 3x.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll find one.
I believe.
I believe in us.
Okay.
One is still here.
Why are they still here?
Okay.
Where are they?
Yeah.
Why are you guys here?
Leave.
We're trying to gain SR.
Guys, we're in party on the last line.
I have evac towers.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
All right.
I'm almost there.
Somebody has a PK.
A golden PK.
They're fighting.
We can run.
Yeah.
We'll follow them.
Wait.
No.
They're fighting.
Right over there.
I will take that.
Yeah.
Okay.
We go here.
They're fighting right here.
We'll fly over them.
They're lacing.
Okay.
We go.
Yeah.
We take over there.
I don't have a scope for this.
We shoot them from the backs.
Here.
One guy here.
Yeah.
Shoot them from the backs.
I'll go with Ditto.
I'm in with Ditto too.
I caught Mirage.
I'm looking.
Let me scan.
Over there.
I got Mirage.
I...
Wait.
I didn't get Mirage.
I got somebody else.
Here.
Okay.
I'm with second thirst.
I will go right.
I got scope.
Wait.
Three.
Where's the guy?
One on me.
I broke the one in front of you, Ditto.
I'm heading over to you.
Nice.
Pushing.
They're pushing you.
I'm batting.
Pushing.
Full push.
They caustic ulted us.
They're lacing.
Come back to us.
Come back to us again.
Okay.
I will go back.
Another team is shooting us.
We have to back up.
Okay.
I'm back.
Yeah.
There's too many teams shooting us.
They have new castle.
Yeah.
They have caustic too.
Okay.
Oh, that's a window.
There's a guy right there.
There's a guy right here shooting us too.
Wait.
To my left.
They're flying over us.
It's okay.
Yeah.
This team is still here.
I'm giving us cover.
This one didn't make it.
Oh.
Mmm.
I'm batting.
There's a heal drone on me.
Be careful, Ditto.
Okay.
Cracked him.
I can't see.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I got us a lot of bats.
I'm gonna eat an alt-xl.
Okay.
Oh.
I have only one size.
Alright.
I get almost EMP.
They're running to the left.
There's a team to our left as well.
Careful.
I'm ping them.
I think they will get shot.
If they got shot from the left side.
I'm gonna get across.
I'm getting across right now.
They ran.
They rotated.
Okay.
This team is also redeployed.
I gotta get ammo.
I have no ammo.
I'm gonna get here.
What ammo?
I'll light.
I'll get it.
I'm watching them fly.
I wanna know where they're going.
Let's do that.
There's a rat.
Wait.
That's another team.
There's a rat team here.
Make sure they don't fly to us.
Yeah.
They ran this way.
They're called this way.
We can keep here.
They're still here.
Okay.
I don't see them.
I don't have an angle.
No angle.
Okay.
What kind of ammo do you need, Hiro?
I'm coming back.
I need the light.
I have no light.
Okay.
We have to take this spot.
I have my ult.
There's a team to our right here though.
That's the thing.
They went there.
I'm going across.
I'm getting across here.
They're still there.
They're still here.
Wait.
Down?
Nice.
They have new castle.
Yeah.
We can do that.
Nice.
I killed an enemy.
Be careful here.
Okay.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
I actually cracked.
Did you?
Make sure there's no rats.
I do need... I do need...
What ammo do you need?
What ammo?
I don't have it.
It's okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
Where?
Is there anybody on this box?
No.
That's why I wanted to go try and loot it.
That's right.
Can you use your dawn?
Yes.
If there's one, people, we can go...
Oh.
Wait.
Here.
Right here.
They kill.
Here.
Wait.
You should go loot that.
Go loot that box for ammo for Hiro.
Just loot it for him.
You should go there.
You loot all the ammo for us and then you come back to us.
Because Hiro can't...
Hiro is more dangerous to go.
This guy is shooting the bottom guy.
Okay.
They have a lot of ammo.
They have a lot of light ammo.
Grab all the light ammo to us.
I need some too.
Okay.
Grab as much as you can.
A lot.
Okay.
I think EMP...
And here.
Where?
Here.
I dropped some too.
What else is in there?
We have to go to a point.
We have to go find a place to stay at.
Okay.
We have to redeploy.
Where do we go?
Over there.
We need to figure out a place to go.
Let me check.
There is a guy.
Okay.
I'll get it.
I will take the top.
They are all here.
It's all here.
I'm getting closer.
I'm coming.
I'm here.
Okay.
I knocked two.
Only one.
I can't.
He is down here.
I'm batting.
I can't do anything about it.
Where is he?
Right below us.
Hero needs a zip if you have one.
Where is he?
Oh.
Loot for this.
Loot.
You need loot.
Okay.
Let's see if that has loot too.
This is... I need some loot too.
Okay.
I can go back out.
Yeah.
We need you to get us a zip to come back up.
Oh.
I don't have a zip.
Okay.
So we need to figure out how to get back up then.
Wait.
Oh.
550.
We can...
We can stay here.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
I'm broken.
I can't get to you.
Oh.
I can.
Okay.
Come over.
Nice.
We can come up.
We can climb up here.
Guys.
Okay.
I'm figuring out how to do this climb.
I just did it.
Here you go.
Oh.
No.
Here.
We climb this.
Okay.
Give it... Oh.
I don't think we need it.
Yeah.
We're in zone.
We're in zone here.
We have to take the high ground.
Yeah.
But this is zone.
This is zone.
Yeah.
But this is zone.
This is zone.
Be careful here.
Yeah.
You can come here, Doki.
It's safe on me too.
I'm giving us cover here.
Okay.
Let me check.
They're in the truck.
And then this one is over here.
I'm gonna look at them from the side here.
There's one behind there.
Okay.
I will stay on tall.
I cracked the guys over there.
Oh my gosh.
What the f***?
Okay.
They did not like me.
They broke my door.
I almost have EVE.
I'm gonna go EMP.
Woah.
Wait.
They're charging you.
Guys, I need help.
They're full pushing.
What the f***?
One hit lifeline.
One hit lifeline?
He's low.
Nice.
Last guy.
What the f*** is wrong with them?
Swap.
Yeah.
What's wrong with them?
Why did they push me?
I'll go look at another one.
They did not...
They were really mad that I did that.
Wait.
This squad...
I need to take the hiding off.
They're fighting.
I need to grab loot.
I'm coming over.
Here.
All broke.
I'm pushing up.
Over there.
Let's push.
One.
Okay.
I got one.
Resing.
Yeah.
You should be able to get...
Dead.
I'm pushing.
I don't know if they're flash yet.
Dead.
I'm batting.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm climbing.
Where are they?
To my left.
Here.
69.
Nice.
Over here.
Um.
Broke.
Yeah.
I'm here.
Nice.
Last team.
Last?
Oh yeah.
It's solo.
Yeah.
We played seriously.
See.
We played seriously guys.
We can win when we're serious.
Okay.
We can win when we're fucking around.
And we can win when we're serious.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
What the fuck was that team that rushed me?
That was actually...
I was like... I was like...
I think... I think...
I think they thought that they were solo.
I think so too.
I think they thought I was solo.
Yeah.
So they pushed you.
They like... I was like...
I cracked one of them and then...
They did not like that.
They were so mad.
I think they were angry.
They might have been angry.
I was like...
What did I do?
I'm just playing support.
Yeah.
I was like... I was like scanning around.
I was like... Wait a minute.
They're all there.
Yeah.
I cracked one.
And then they pushed me.
I was like...
Guys.
Why didn't you push me?
Yeah.
They pushed in and died.
That was so fucked up.
Guys.
I'm gonna go push a solo lifeline.
Cause she's never solo.
She's not solo.
Life can get crafters.
So yeah.
It's like... never assume.
That's so messed up.
Ditto is sure to be like...
You're still gold one, Ditto?
You're still gold one?
When are you plat?
I'm actually really surprised.
Yeah.
You're still gold one.
I thought that was their plat game.
Me too.
Like we got a lot of points there.
Yeah.
We got a lot of points.
And we got first.
Alright, Ditto.
Oh no.
I feel like Hiro is gonna get gold before she gets plat.
Why?
I think if we go on again, I might get plat.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay, we go Skyhook.
Alright.
Ooh, Ditto discorded.
Oh no, countdown.
Ditto got little robotic there.
I have a master's trail.
I see that.
Ditto's becoming like a plat fighter.
Okay, I'll go right.
I'm going on the other side here.
Yeah.
They go left.
Whee.
Okay, I got Carbun.
I got... um...
Alternator and...
2020.
Yeah, I have Alternator.
And Sentinel.
There should be here.
Wait, L-Star here.
Hey, Ditto.
Ditto here.
Yeah, I see them.
They come here.
I see them.
They walked across.
I'm behind them.
They're running.
They're running to you guys.
I'm right behind them.
One.
One guy.
Oh wait, I have to...
I have to pull back.
Okay.
Yeah, they're looking at you.
Broke one?
I will go back.
Yeah, I'm right behind them.
I'm right behind them.
I can push them whenever you guys are ready.
They're gonna push.
They're pushing.
I see them pushing.
One is still there though.
Yeah, they're pushing.
I got the bat.
Okay, shoot my drone.
Be careful.
On me.
They're looking at me.
They're looking at me now.
Yeah, they're looking at me.
They're all looking at me.
I need you guys to help.
No!
He's flashed.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't push.
They both looked at me.
Oh, I'm rolling.
I can't push because there's one way I can't.
Wait, I can't ditto.
I think you guys should just craft me.
Yeah, just fall back.
I didn't realize they both were gonna turn around and look at me.
That was my bad.
Only one guy pushed up to you guys.
The other two were on me.
Yeah.
Yeah, because there was one guy looking at us.
How dare they.
I need to remember I'm lifeline.
I can't flank.
Lifeline can't flank.
I'm too... I'm baby.
I think I can actually craft her.
Should I craft her?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, do it.
This team is fighting here.
They won't know.
Okay.
Okay, they won't know.
Yeah, they won't know.
You can rez me right here and then we can third party this team.
Here.
Oh, you are brave for that.
You are so brave.
I was trying to get you guys.
Alright, we're rezzing.
I'm too squishy to flank.
I'm a little squishy lifeline.
I actually don't know where they're fighting.
Where did you see the fight?
I'm not sure, actually.
I heard them fighting, but like...
It ended.
There's one team went to the guy.
Oh.
There might be a lot of team over there.
In Skyhook.
I have no idea where the team is though.
I'll scan.
I'm looking around.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Oh, they...
They're fighting at the Bloodhound.
Oh, they're fighting there.
So this is safe.
Yeah, Bloodhound's powers.
Is this place safe then?
Yeah, it's safe.
Okay, I'm gonna go to the middle then.
Oh.
I know this one.
Nice.
Where did you knock them?
You can do it.
Ditto, where did you knock them?
I think she's like...
On me.
Oh, okay.
We can go to her.
Let's just go to her.
Okay.
I'm heading over now.
I'm sliding.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the Evil Harvester for us.
Oh, never mind.
We don't need it.
Wait.
That's a bit dangerous.
Ditto, you're in the middle.
Okay.
I'll go back.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
We're here though.
Yeah, they're over here.
They're over here.
I see them.
Okay.
One's in this house.
I think we'll get squished.
I think we can go that way.
Yeah.
I scanned out somebody.
They're there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw that guy.
Over there.
Yeah.
Oh.
They Bloodhound ulted me.
I'm gonna try and heal.
Pull back.
I'm falling.
Back.
I'm falling back.
I'm okay.
They have a blue armor.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Oh my god!
That's a gold longbow!
Guys, I'm gonna get that.
Okay.
I need that, guys.
Guys, you don't understand.
Do you have any bats?
I have five bats.
Yeah, I do.
I don't have bats.
Guys, I haven't... I've been trying to get a gold longbow for so long.
Okay.
I'll give you two here.
Really?
Yeah.
When... that moment when I got that first gold longbow and then I died because of the flank.
It made me so sad.
They might...
They might come to us.
Okay.
They'll pass by the team.
Vito and I are really far, by the way.
Yeah, they come to us.
They come to us.
We're far.
Do you want us to come here?
Wait, there's one here?
Yeah.
There's one in the tunnel.
Oh, okay.
I'm heading back.
I'm going up the house.
Yeah, go to the door.
Go to the door.
Oh, shit!
You have one.
Almost got one.
Every time.
Ditto, Ditto.
Someone behind.
Yeah, Ditto.
We need help.
We need help, Ditto.
Okay, okay.
Here, here, here, here.
I'm like stuck here too.
I'm gonna... I almost hit one.
I hit one.
He's one behind this car.
The car, yeah.
Someone on top.
There's someone on top.
We have to go to Doki... Doki place.
Yeah, come here.
Kill.
Come to me.
I need help.
Yeah, I'm trying to cover.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
I can't cover.
There's two teams.
Wait, wait.
You can actually get me, I think.
I got one.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna rest.
Okay, okay.
Okay, you're okay.
You go.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, my god.
Do you have a Q?
Yeah, I do.
Come here.
Come inside.
Wait, wait.
There's a grenade.
Come inside.
I'm pushing.
The Q is out here.
We can't go.
We can't go third.
They're fighting.
Yeah.
I got one.
I got another.
I got third.
I'm just gonna snipe here.
I'm just gonna snipe.
Because I have gold.
Okay.
I'm gonna ditto.
I got the bat.
Two teams.
Yes.
I'm covering.
Yeah, I'm just sniping from outside.
Pass through there.
I have no idea where they are.
I knocked two.
They are racing.
Yeah, I think they are playing inside now.
They are playing inside.
Oh no!
He is still low.
Okay.
I'm going to try and come here guys.
No, no, no.
You have to...
No, no.
I can't come inside.
There is a...
Oh my gosh!
I couldn't come inside because they...
I think you got to have them.
Two, two, two.
They have two.
There is two.
It's fine.
I can craft you here too.
Okay.
You can come later.
Goodbye.
Oh my gosh!
The harvok!
The harvok is really great.
Yeah.
Didn't you say it was trash?
You said it was trash.
No, no, no.
If you are...
Wait.
This guy hit all headshot on me though.
On the harvok.
Oh, the hair is scary.
Oh, that's scary.
Yeah.
He did 188 headshot by the...
He walked so fast.
Yeah.
I think he could be a cheater.
Yes.
I'm a bit scared of that one.
Yeah.
I'm going to leave now.
I'm going to...
I couldn't come inside.
The catalyst locked the doors.
So I couldn't go in.
I was like, no.
I'm so far away.
Oh yeah.
You can...
Oh, be careful.
Be careful right side.
You can...
There is a tear.
Yeah.
Oh, I see that.
Did you guys see that?
There is...
Yeah.
I see that.
Oh!
They fly away.
Oh, not yet!
It's okay.
There's no one.
No!
That's not.
That's us!
That!
Oh, they just fell.
Oh, no.
No.
Doggy is...
Oh, my god.
It's very... It's very close.
That's...
Oh, my god.
Oh, they're fighting different team?
No.
I think he was trying to shoot me.
I think he was fighting different team.
No.
I'm just going to rest you here.
I'm going to rest you here.
Okay.
It's still... it's still... um...
...a ring to.
Yeah, I can't believe Ditto lied to us again.
There's nobody there!
I didn't see anyone.
Okay, okay, Ditto.
Okay, then...
There's no one there.
Really?
I didn't see anyone.
That was the scariest fucking...
I literally had to walk to the left.
She did it to me before.
I didn't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I would never.
I am a team player.
I'm a team player.
I would never.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I would never gaslit my teammates.
You're lying.
Why would I lie?
What the heck?
I'm just gonna die.
Okay.
I have gold red shield.
Just come to me.
But like...
Okay.
Yeah, I have gold red shield.
Okay, you're gonna last me?
Yeah.
I'm crafting.
You're gonna craft?
Last me?
What the heck?
Oh my god.
You're there.
Oh my god!
Why the fuck are you guys...
Guys, I don't have a lot of heals either!
They're not decamping us though.
We have to go to... um... tunnel?
Going... to a tunnel?
A tunnel?
Okay, I have two syringes left.
Okay.
It's okay.
You guys go.
I'll try and go separate.
Okay.
And see if they...
I'm also gonna craft a medkit.
Okay.
Oh god.
They're shooting me, so it's okay.
I think I might die.
Please, you're so far.
Ditto, I can't pick you up there.
It's okay.
I'm safe.
Okay?
If I'm lucky, I will survive.
You have to come to me then.
Oh no, I'm not lucky.
I'm not lucky.
Why?
Where did you go?
Okay, oh, I will come to you.
I will go to you.
Come to me.
Kido's alive too.
I'm alive.
I'm going.
What the heck?
There's no sign in here.
Okay.
Hello.
You have to come to me if you want heals.
Why?
There's no heal.
You have to come to me.
There's heals right here.
I'm trying.
Heals right here.
You have to come to me.
Oh.
Oh, raise me.
Raise me.
Oh, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Okay, we go.
We go.
I think we're gonna die, Hiro.
I think I'm gonna die.
There's people right in front of me.
There's no other place to go.
We have to fight.
I will go on top.
I will go top.
There's three squads here.
Bang a little monster tank.
Be a little less.
I got bang.
One monster tank.
Oh, God.
Oh, please.
No.
You're gonna die.
Oh, God.
I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
No, live.
Live.
Is there a prison here?
You have to live.
Live.
There is no other place to die.
Quiet.
Oh no!
I got scared!
Holy shit!
Bro, and then there's a- There's so many people!
What was that?
There's just so many people!
Holy shit.
Hey guys, I got plus 55.
No, I got plus 17!
I was looking at the wrong person!
Wait, what?
You could look at your RP in the ranked.
Oh yeah, we can.
Yeah, we could.
At least I got to use my longbow, guys.
I got to use it.
Did you?
Yay!
I used the longbow!
I'm so happy!
Holy shit.
Who would've thought?
There's so many squads there.
It's like impossible.
There were so many people.
And we had no heals.
We were broke, we were poor.
I had no heals.
I only had cells.
Yeah, I had no heals.
And they had blood!
We were so poor!
We were so poor.
We were crying.
Please, can someone donate...
...heals to us?
I wish, you know like, those games where you can get chat to help you and stuff?
Oh yeah, and like...
Twitch plays.
Like, they do like Twitch plays something and then they like send you stuff while you're playing.
Like the Hunger Games!
The tributes!
I wish we can get tributes.
Oh yeah!
Like, like sponsors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We play and the chat sends help kits to us.
Like, sends us tributes and sponsors.
Imagine you can sponsor like a Craver.
Yeah, yeah.
That should be a thing!
There should be chat integration in Apex.
That would make the game more alive!
One team, one team, one team.
Okay.
I'mma land here in the circle.
Okay, I'll go with Ditto here.
I wish Twitch can... I wish chat can sponsor us so we can get help kits.
One team, one team, one team.
I see them.
They're right over here.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
There's a triple take.
I'll grab the triple take.
Okay.
Oh my god.
They're here?
They're there.
Is there any weapon I need?
Oh my god!
My gun!
There is.
My gun is like... Oh my god, my gun's stuck.
There's a lot of guns here.
Okay, okay, I got the beta gun.
There's alternators.
There's everything down here.
Yeah, I need a weapon.
There's so much stuff.
Okay.
Alright, I'm ready to fight.
Where are they?
Oh, I saw them over there.
I'm waiting for the scan before I push up.
Okay, I'm waiting for the scan too.
I'm not sure.
Oh, they have a crypto too.
They have a crypto.
Oh, they scan your drone?
Oh, I see them.
Oh, they're running too.
I grabbed them crypto over there.
Behind the container.
Okay, I'm pushing up.
They're like right here.
Whoa!
Wait, they also have a sniper.
But they're better at it than me.
I think they have a scope.
They're on the tower?
It's right on the tower.
I'll scan them.
Okay.
Let me check.
Wait, wait, wait.
Crypto's like here.
Alright, I'm pushing up then.
Wait, yeah, the crypto's close.
Here, I'm pushing up.
He's here.
Oh, they scanned me.
They know I'm here now.
Here, here, here.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Got it?
I'm pushing up.
I'm selling, I'm selling.
Okay, I'm selling.
Oh, he has a massive...
Oh, I might be dead.
Oh, that's my bitch!
Okay, go, go, go.
Okay, this side is...
Okay, I'm here.
Shit, I'm not even... I'm playing from NA.
Crack on...
She's almost dead.
Yeah.
I will go kill her.
Down here, down here, down here.
Crypto's here.
Okay, I will go kill it.
Where is he?
Crack?
Oh, there, over there.
I see him.
Crack?
Can I one-kick though?
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Dead, dead, dead, dead.
Nice.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I thought you...
I don't know who you are.
You're so toxic.
Yeah, this is our POI.
Leave our POI.
What did they do to you?
They shot me.
That's right.
I'm gonna do this to you too.
There's a fragment.
We're so free here.
Yeah, we're so free.
We can loot.
We should go to No Name and loot a little bit.
Hold on, she's... yeah.
Yeah, we're broke.
She's crazy.
Why am I crazy?
What did I do?
They deserved it.
They tried to creep our game.
They tried to land where we were landing.
That's all I needed.
Oh yeah, and they had a crypto.
And they had a sniper to contest us.
Yeah, exactly.
That's on them.
They should have left.
They fought back.
So I have to kill them.
They got a laser.
Alright, I need shield cells.
Holy shit.
I will play... I will play...
...Farbine.
Okay, I'm gonna do triple take.
That was a good triple take game.
Ooh, there is...
Mmm, I should...
Okay, I'm gonna... I should go...
Oh, there's this.
You want?
Oh, never mind.
I'm staying on triple take then.
I need it.
Yeah, it's a sign.
I can open the vault.
Oh, nice.
They're resting at the back here, by the way.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we can fight them after.
Yeah.
I'll go open the vault.
Alright.
We're heading over.
I'm so broke.
Oh, wait!
Wait!
What?
I... What is this?
It's a bug.
What happened?
Okay, I'm fine.
Oh, what happened?
It's a... like a... um...
I'm... um...
No, no, wait.
Okay, okay.
What the fuck?
I'm not going to go.
Okay.
I...
Wait.
I'm going to go.
Okay.
It's an inventory bug.
Like...
Oh.
Yeah, it's an inventory bug.
Let's see.
Oh, there's a triple charger.
Oh.
Mine.
Yoink.
I just took everything.
Wait, they have crypto?
They have crypto?
They do?
How do you know?
Yeah, they do.
They do.
You know.
I heard their drone.
Here.
There's a triple charger.
I don't need it.
Oh, there's a scope.
I need it.
I took it.
But I don't have...
My scope now.
I took it.
All right.
Uh...
You have to be over there.
Yeah, right outside here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you have...
Do you have any...
Oh, yeah.
They're here.
Loba.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
They have Loba.
I'm looking.
They opened the door.
Yeah, Loba.
They're...
Loba crypto.
No, they're far.
They're far.
Oh, okay.
Crypto again?
Yeah.
Okay, can...
Okay.
I will go.
I'm waiting for you, Ditto.
They're far though.
They're far.
Yeah.
Come here.
I will zip line.
You see?
Oh, they're so far.
They're like right here.
Where?
I was...
Holy shit.
Do you see this?
One, two, three, four.
Do you see that?
What?
No.
I was scan doing that.
What the fuck are they doing?
Look at the map.
Right here.
What the heck?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
A lot.
Yeah, and then there's here.
One team with us.
Oh, I got scan.
I got scan.
Okay.
What's going on?
It's Fable.
Wait, they went there.
Oh, there.
There's one.
There's one that flew too far.
Oh, they're flying.
They're flying.
Yeah.
They're getting high ground.
They're flying.
Okay.
I will try to get the anger.
I think they're running.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah, I think they went to the ring.
They're gone.
Gone.
I think we should go level 7.
Yeah.
Take this.
This has armor for you, Hiro.
Okay.
I will carve battery first.
Yeah.
Evil cash.
Okay.
I'm just getting a shield cell.
I will carve battery first.
All right.
Let's get the lava siphon.
We should.
Yeah, we should get the lava siphon now.
Yes.
Let me see.
We should go here.
Hmm.
All right.
I'll wait.
Third floor is the base, I think.
Wait.
My phone is ringing.
I'm going to get my zip line.
All right.
We're here.
Okay.
Here, here.
Oh, no.
We can't.
Wait.
Tera, what happened?
Come here.
You're RGN.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yay.
There might be people here.
This zip line is lagging.
Oh, wait.
The zip line is fine for me.
At least you.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, bye.
Bye.
Okay.
100.
We go check that building.
Okay.
There's no one, I think.
I'll go check it.
Okay.
I'm going to poke a little bit.
And then...
They're not looking.
They're scared.
Wait.
I still have no shields.
Oh, shit.
Oh, then let's get this.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
You...
Okay.
You're going to get it.
Third floor is the base, I think.
Okay.
I need a shield cell.
I just realized I have zero shield cells.
I can give you some.
Why?
Why is it all...
Because I forgot to loot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I don't need bats.
I have a lot of bats.
You can take the bat.
Really?
You just need a shell?
I have seven bats.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
One team there.
Sell the bottom ducky.
Okay.
Grab it.
He's one tech.
He's...
There's people behind us.
He's tech.
What the hey?
Why you shoot me?
There's a team in that small house.
There's a team in small house.
Okay.
Let me...
We have three.
We have our mate.
No.
Not yet.
70%.
Wait.
They're coming over.
What?
The password is cracked.
All cracked.
Yeah, but we can't do anything about it.
They're all above us.
One guy there.
Two guys.
Two guys above us.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
I will nade.
I nade it too.
No.
I hit the railing.
They're below us?
Yeah.
We gotta make sure nobody...
I'm gonna make sure nobody's below us.
I'm on the other door.
There's people here too.
Here.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I'm looking below us too.
Okay.
Because they wanna...
They wanna...
I want people to flank us here.
No, I don't.
I haven't.
I think...
He'll...
Pay here.
He has the...
Did you...
Yeah.
Wait.
I have...
He has the stair.
Wow.
Wait.
No.
Two hundred.
Okay.
They went back.
They went up.
I can get him.
I can't get him.
I'm gonna...
He's scared.
I'm closing the door.
He's going this way.
Okay.
I did it.
Close.
He went back.
I'm gonna close the door for us.
They went back.
They're scared.
They're scared, they went back.
Yeah, they can't go through the store now.
They're all...
Careful.
Okay.
Wait, there's so many people.
Another squad!
I guess we can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, come.
I'm not gonna use... I'm not gonna peek anymore.
I don't have many cells.
There's a...
Here.
I'll just take everything.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure...
Okay.
Oh my god, they're crazy.
Wait, they're coming on top of us?
Really?
Yeah, that's fine.
The guy right...
They're above us.
Here.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm gonna scan them, okay?
Okay.
We play this loom, okay?
I'm trying to...
Let's see, one, two...
How many people are above us?
Two.
Okay.
Two?
Yeah.
Only two.
Let me check the rest.
This kind of building is more cell.
Yeah.
This one, this one, there's one person down here.
I'm looking around behind us here.
I'm looking here.
There's a team here.
How many, how many battery do you guys have?
I have seven.
I have eight actually.
We have so many.
Can I have, can I have, can I have some?
Here, here's two.
There's one team here.
There's another top press.
Okay.
Someone look below us, just in case.
I'll take a bath later.
Okay.
I'll just go look around now.
I'm checking.
They're fighting.
They're...
There's so many people.
Oh my god, so many people died.
Yeah, we're still here.
We're still here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Inside the zone.
So many people died though.
Holy shit.
This is zone.
This is zone right here.
Oh yeah.
Wait, wait, hello?
Am I, am I still here?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
My internet.
Oh no.
You're still in, you're still in.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm here.
You're just flying around.
You're flying.
Yeah, I see a drone flying around.
You're still here.
Let me check.
You're still in here.
You're inside here.
How many light ammo do you have?
I have...
Light?
Uh...
Light.
I can give a bit.
Oh.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll give you 20.
That's it.
I, I can, I can give you, I can give you some.
I can give.
Here, here, here.
Ditto.
Here.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, there's a team here too.
Thank you.
I get EMP.
Just tell me who do EMP.
I feel like we have to EMP the people above us.
Because they're the most annoying.
Me too.
We could do, do you want to go all the way down?
Do you want to go down to rotate or above?
Okay, let me check, let me check, let me check above her.
It's, it's one guy.
It's one guy?
It's one guy.
Okay.
Do you want, do you want to fight him?
Do you want to just kill him?
I can.
He's not moving.
Yeah, yeah.
What, I can do it now.
Is he?
I'm alright.
Just kill him.
He just moved.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Here.
Are they coming to us?
He literally just moved the moment you said it's one guy.
Wait, did it get banned?
Like, like his team is gone.
Did it get banned?
I don't know.
What happened to them?
That's crazy.
I think they got banned.
That's so funny.
What happened?
We have no, he just disappeared.
I'm getting ready to EMP this.
Okay.
Where?
Here.
89.
All, all broken?
I can't do anything about it.
Okay.
I, I have no anger.
I have no anger.
Yeah, yeah.
I will go outside the, outside the building.
I'm going, I'm going here.
I'm going here.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab some nades too.
But there, there, there's a guy there.
Okay?
There's a guy there.
Ditto.
I'll go to Ditto.
Watch out for that guy.
Wait.
Oh my god.
He ran so fast.
If you guys find a sniper ammo, let me know.
This team, this team, this team.
Okay.
I really need sniper ammo.
I got scanned from my left.
That's them.
Almost get a lifeline.
I don't have an angle.
I'm trying to get across.
I'm charging my ult.
Okay.
There's a team here.
There's a team there.
Really behind this.
Team here too.
Team here.
That one's cracked.
Ditto.
Okay.
Oh, I have no anger.
Oh.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm getting bats.
You guys need bats here.
Here, I have so many bats.
They're resing there.
They're resing.
Can we go?
Okay.
Wait, they scanned us again, Ditto.
Here, here, here, here.
Wait.
I'm going to Ditto.
We are going to Ditto.
Go to Ditto.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, Ditto.
We're trying to get to you.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can't do this.
I'm going inside.
I'm going inside the bin.
Oh no.
I'm dead.
Just...
Okay.
I don't want.
I'm in the barrel.
Oh my god.
I'm coming to you.
I'm coming to you now.
I can't.
Oh, sorry.
He's dead.
You can res me.
He's resing.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
No.
That team.
No, we should have stayed.
We should have stayed.
Yeah.
That team.
Are you...
Are you flat?
You didn't check.
Click on the rank and see if you're flat.
Click on rank.
Let me check.
Not yet.
Yeah.
How much?
Really?
How much more?
150.
It's okay.
150?
Yeah.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
We need one win.
Okay.
We'll win this one.
All right.
We can do it.
I should have stayed.
I should have kept my...
I should have kept my triple take.
I was so happy getting the longbow.
I should have played with my triple take.
It's okay.
We get another one this round.
It's always...
Always the triple take and the longbow.
I see gold longbow.
I...
I don't...
I don't play longbow actually.
Oh, longbow is fun.
I haven't played longbow in a long time.
I mean, when you have the gold sight...
Really?
It's just the gold sight.
The gold sight is fun.
Oh, the gold sight.
Yeah.
When you get the gold sight, it's like, oh, I want it.
You can see everything?
Yeah.
It's just so fun to see everything.
No.
We need either...
Yeah, we need Ditto to get a lot of kills.
The moment she hits 150...
We know it's over.
Probably.
Oh, that was Syphon.
Yeah.
Oh, Carbine.
Carbine is not that...
There is...
Wait, there's not a song.
It's only...
What?
It's just long range.
Wait, they're landing together.
What?
Oh.
Yeah.
The two teams.
All of them.
All three teams.
Three teams?
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
They all landed together.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
One guy.
Why?
They...
But they didn't fight.
What is that?
They're not fighting.
Oh, they're not fighting.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now.
It was slow.
Okay.
Do you want to go?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Okay, let's go together.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm heading over.
Wait, there's one guy on top.
Ditto.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Yeah, I heard that here.
Yeah, how did I get burned?
I was like...
I was like running.
You're so far from it.
High five, one.
Three of them.
Be careful.
They didn't fly.
Watch.
Oh my god.
Be careful.
Okay, we'll wait a little bit.
We wait.
I like to wait.
Wait a bit.
Wait until it knocks.
Yeah.
Let me look.
Okay.
I'll call you.
They're here.
Okay.
What?
They're down.
Some people are down here.
I saw a knock.
You can come.
Cracked him.
I cracked him.
I'm going to shield cell.
This guy is also...
I can stay.
One hit.
Go careful.
I'm going to...
Oh, we got one.
We got one.
I'm going with you.
Okay.
On the team.
Last team.
Oh god.
Flash.
I can.
Flash too.
Nice.
He's...
Okay.
You can...
You can touch me.
Yeah.
I was trying to.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
No.
I gotta get...
Yeah.
Oh.
Cute me.
Goodbye.
Can I get out?
Oh nice.
Wait.
I'm out.
Nice.
Did we...
Did you kill all of them?
Yeah.
Okay.
Body.
Cute.
My body.
It's a sacrifice I had to make.
Let me grab...
Grab a car.
Wait.
You said there were three squads.
Wait let me check.
Yeah.
I remembered.
It was like three squads.
Wait there's no...
They're all dead.
No squad?
Okay.
That's good.
That's what we needed.
Yeah.
Now the loot is all ours.
Nice!
We have all the loot now.
Wow.
We are so good.
Yeah.
Oh my god, they looted this too.
Do you need bats, guys?
I have two.
I have zero.
I'll give you some.
Are you here, Dokie?
Where are you?
I'm all the way here.
Do you need this?
I need some light, I think.
Light?
Okay.
I can give you...
I can craft.
I have like 300.
Oh, yeah.
You should.
You don't need a craft.
That was 300.
Okay, 1,020.
Yeah, I need that.
1,020.
Alright.
Where do we go?
That's a lot.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
I have 300.
Are you in...
You're not even running double light.
You're not...
You just have 300.
No.
Ooh.
Dokie, do you want more bats?
There's not more bats here.
No, I'm okay.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna scan the ring.
Okay.
Look at it.
Grab it.
Yeah, I don't have a beacon here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
There's nobody here anymore.
You know what?
I'll...
Really?
Yeah.
Wait, there's one squad.
There's one squad.
Oh, no.
She's out.
Fake news.
Let me check.
Okay.
I don't see them here.
Yeah, how was I supposed to know?
They're here.
They just came.
They're gonna loot.
We can fight.
I can EMP.
Okay.
Don't EMP yet.
Wait until we're closer.
Only one?
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't.
They're white.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so they're babies.
They're babies.
Okay.
Only one?
Yeah, they're babies.
They're looting here.
Yeah, they want loot.
They want loot because they're babies.
I hear them.
Gas?
There's gas?
On me.
You mean Caustic?
Yeah, yeah.
Caustic, Caustic, Caustic.
Wait.
Behind me?
Oh, my God.
There was a guy right behind me.
Over here.
Whoa.
Goodbye.
It's not low.
I'm coming.
They don't...
He's so low.
Too low.
Don't worry.
I'm coming back soon.
I'm almost there.
Too low.
Okay, down, down, down.
Down, down, down.
Nice last guy.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
I'm back.
Wait, wait, wait.
Me come back?
Oh, my God.
You guys, I'm saved.
There's so many things here.
Wait, here.
Gold knock.
What the fuck?
Why were they...
How are they, like, poor and rich at the same time?
I thought they were solo.
Oh, my God.
The guy was behind me.
Dude, they had nothing?
They had, like, white armor, but they had items.
Yeah.
They were fucking goaded.
What the heck?
There's so much stuff in here.
I need energy armor.
Here, here, here.
Energy.
There's a lot of energy here, too.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I got it.
Oh, hell.
Okay.
I lived.
Let's see.
I died right next to you.
I died right next to the cart.
No, Scott.
Okay.
You can scan ring now.
Yeah, you can scan it now.
No, Scott.
Okay.
I live.
All right.
While you scan, I'll get the Evo.
I live.
Okay.
Dorky, give me some dawn.
Dawn.
You're just...
What?
You're just one HP.
Come over here.
And then you get it.
You have to come over here.
Ooh.
Wait.
That's a PK.
I don't like the PK.
Oh.
Put the dawn there.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
You don't like PK?
This ring.
Oh, the ring.
Oh.
No, no.
I mean, the ring.
The ring is...
It's hard to panic.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
I should...
I don't like landslides.
Wait.
There's no one with the PK?
Pick a countdown.
Ditto, I'll give you the tower, Ditto.
Okay.
Yeah, you give me this.
Does no one want the PK?
No.
Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm gonna do it with like 200 ping.
Let's go.
Oh, you have 200 ping?
No, I have 100.
100 ping.
120, I think.
That's usually how much ping I get.
Do you need energy?
Ditto.
Okay.
Which way are we gonna go?
I'm good.
We go countdown.
Countdown?
All right.
Yeah, countdown.
Let's look.
Valerie here.
Oh, my God.
Let me place my...
Dang.
All right.
Who wants the red armor?
You can grab it.
Oh, I can?
Okay.
I need it.
Yeah.
I need it the most.
If I'm going in with my PK...
Oh, there's another gold rose.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go.
Oh, I don't like to this way and this way.
We should go this way.
We go.
See if we can get to landslide.
Okay.
Let's see if there's no one in landslide.
But I think there might be people at landslide.
We can go here and see if Hiro scans anybody.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
If Hiro scans somebody.
Oh, my gosh.
Do he?
What?
You are so smart.
I know.
Let's see.
I'll grab this.
Sounds like...
Okay.
That's gun sound.
We gotta wait for Hiro to see how many teams are around.
I will go grab evil harvester.
Yeah.
And from the same...
Nobody near.
Then we could go through this.
Yeah.
We should be able to go through this.
Where do you wanna go?
There's one team there.
You wanna fight or do you wanna...
This way.
Oh, I'm gonna go this way.
Oh, I think...
Oh, Ditto wants to fight now.
Can you...
Can you scan there?
Where?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Here?
Okay.
It's kind of far.
Yeah.
I quit.
It's scanned.
Oh, there's a team.
There's a team here too.
Yeah.
Ditto, you wanna go?
There's a team there too.
We could just wait until it closes.
Okay.
Let me check.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's blue armor by there.
I cracked him.
I cracked him from all the way here.
The blue armor.
Let me try and scan.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna look behind us here too, just in case.
Okay.
Team, team, team, team, team.
Team, team, team, team, team, team, team, team, team.
Yeah.
We have to focus on this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Make them back up.
Maybe one.
Maybe one, I think.
No, no.
Three, three, three.
I saw three.
One fell.
Yeah.
One ran down.
I'll EMT.
Yeah, I know.
Blue, blue, purple.
Blue, purple.
Let me check.
They're all the way down here.
They're here.
Why are they running to us?
We cracked them.
Their third ran the different direction.
Low armor.
They're trying to run.
Be careful.
Flash, flash, flash.
That's a different squad.
What?
No, no, no.
It's his teammate.
I got one.
Oh, fighter.
Nice.
Last.
There's a rev over there.
I got two.
Did you give me a Q?
Yeah.
All dead, all dead.
We got Q, we got Q, we got Q.
Did you give me a Q?
I don't know if they're all dead though.
I'm taking one flu.
Over there, over there.
We go, we go, we go, right?
We go, right?
Yeah.
Don't kick you.
Drone.
Oh, sorry.
Thank you.
Oh, they get, they get keeping us.
Yeah, yeah.
So we have to go this way.
Okay.
They get keeping us.
We can, okay.
Let me check.
I think we, let me, let me drone.
I'll drone, I'll drone.
I can scan.
This is zone, this is zone, this is zone, this is zone.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll throw my drone down here.
Okay.
I'm gonna go down here.
That's a lie.
Oh.
No way.
I saw them, I saw them over here earlier.
I'm not sure where they are now.
Wait, I don't see them, actually.
Yeah, then we can go move up.
Wait, they're not here.
They're not here.
They're here.
We gotta get out of the tunnel.
I don't want to...
Can, can, can we play on, on the...
Nobody here, nobody here.
Nobody here.
Everybody's here.
Everybody's fighting there.
Okay, we can, we can, we can, we can.
Yeah, we're safe.
We're safe all there.
Yeah, yeah.
Get the ring, get the ring too.
We take the high guard, we take the high guard.
Yeah.
Yeah, you scan the ring because all of them are fighting here.
Little scan ring.
Okay, I will scan the ring, okay?
I'm going to check the package.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh!
What the f***?
1, 2, 3 teams.
Oh, it's here.
We should push up here now.
Okay, okay, okay, I will push up here.
We care package though.
Yeah.
It's a Devo.
Because I want to get...
Someone should get...
No, there's another one coming down here.
Oh, shit.
Someone should get the Devo.
Okay.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
You can take it.
I'll grab... I'll stay here.
But there's another one here though.
I will look left.
Check what that is first.
I'm going to look right here.
Because the last team is here and then another team is here, left side.
Over there, over there, over there.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to put my package here too.
They should know we're here as well.
Okay, okay, okay.
Then...
There are only two teams left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Left and right.
But there's another Devotion.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'll grab one of the Devotions.
I'll grab the other Devotion.
Okay, you take one.
Okay.
I'll grab that.
I'll grab this one then.
I have a lot of energy.
Do you guys need it?
No.
I'm running PKD.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay, they're there.
They're there.
They're fighting.
They're down.
Push up, push up, push up.
They're fighting.
You gotta push up.
Hiro, you gotta come up.
You gotta come up.
Yeah, I'm a bit far.
Wait.
Yeah, just run up.
Go, go, go.
They're fighting.
Hard fight.
I'll try EMP them.
Let me EMP.
Okay.
I'm on the town.
EMP left side.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm going out.
Yeah.
They didn't...
They got...
They got one knocked.
One knocked at first.
I EMP'd the other one.
One knocked?
This...
We can actually fight here.
Oh, they're all dead.
Oh, come.
Oh.
They're not dead.
No, no, no.
We have to focus on the left side too.
Yeah, I know.
This one is very hurt.
Very hurt.
Yeah.
I can't...
I don't have an angle on this team.
I'm looking at my right just in case.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna wait.
I forgot D.Va's recoil is so hard too.
I'm gonna look at this team for you.
This team.
All right.
See here.
I'm looking here for us.
Oh, the Corsi.
Blue armor.
Yeah.
They're all...
This team is blue as well.
Oh.
On the left team.
Left team have...
Left team have three people.
We have to focus on left team.
Yeah.
You guys focus on left.
I'm focusing on right for us.
Okay.
Wait.
One's pushing up little.
Here.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Calm down.
Thank you.
They're here.
Can you use the drone?
Here.
Yeah.
My drone just broke.
They're trying to get...
They're here.
Oh, okay.
The one down.
Left team down.
Okay.
They keep destroying my drone, but it keeps getting...
I'm getting across.
I'm getting across on the left...
The right team.
Okay.
They might push up to us.
So I'm gonna be sure.
Hey, hey.
Right on the left team.
They're there, Doki.
They're there.
They're right here.
They're right here on me.
Right here.
Let's go back.
Actually, let's get zone.
We're not even in zone.
You guys are not even in zone.
No, I'm going up.
Go up.
I'll be bottom.
Okay, I'll be bottom.
Right here?
I think they want to push up.
Are they fighting each other?
I'm pushing up.
Cosney is cracked.
I'll crack.
Okay.
Cosney is cracked too.
I knocked one.
I got one.
Okay.
I'm going to Doki.
Okay, here.
On me.
Oh my god.
This is dumb.
One hit.
In the cart.
Okay, be careful.
Last guy.
They're inside.
Nice.
Last one.
Solo.
Oh my god.
I can.
Got him.
Nice.
I'm just like, fuck off.
Get out of there.
Yeah.
He's just sitting inside.
He's just like he's staying in there.
Oh my god.
We did it.
That has to be Plat.
That's a champion.
Nice.
We got champion.
Let's see.
I'm returning the lobby.
Yeah, I'm returning the lobby too.
It definitely is, right?
Surely.
I got gold 1 from that.
I got 330 points from that.
I'm gold.
Oh, you got it!
We got Plat!
We did it!
We accomplished our goal!
Both the goals!
600.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, because when you rank up to another tier, you get half.
I got 764.
I got 330, guys.
You almost got Plat.
Guys!
GG.
That was fun.
We are so good.
Our teamwork is so good.
I know!
We are fucking gamers!
We are so good, guys.
Look at us.
We climbed so much.
We got like wins against other Master Players.
We are so good.
GG.
I had a lot of fun.
Yeah, me too.
We played for 5 hours.
Oh my god!
We played so long.
We were so long.
Oh my gosh.
I had a lot of fun, though.
I had so much fun.
We should do this again.
We should definitely grind again.
Yeah.
Alright.
GG, guys.
I'm gonna head off.
It was so good to play, guys.
Bye bye!
I'm gonna talk to my dragons.
Bye!
Bye, Ditto!
Go eat!
Bye bye!
Oh!
That was so good.
That was so fun.
I had a great time playing with Hiro and Ditto.
We grinded.
We won so many games.
Oh my god.
We won so many games together.
And like our teamwork was so good.
I'm gonna go back to Yiha land.
I had an incredible time today.
Tomorrow is Once Human launch with Tenjin tomorrow.
Um...
I was not expecting to stream for five hours, but it was really fun though.
Like we won so many games.
We fragged the fuck out today.
My aim when I got warmed up, my aim was like killing it until like I forgot how to control the devotion recoil.
But other than that...
Other than that, I had a great time.
Um...
Wait, let's see.
Wait, I need to double check.
Is the YouTube figure still...
orderable?
Guys!
In ten hours guys!
Okay, before I leave, I need a shill.
Complete the Triforce.
Guys, all I'm saying is like you need this for the figure Triforce.
Look, your shrine is gonna look real silly if it's incomplete.
I'm not...
You need...
If we're completing the Triforce, we need like the U2s, the Nendoroid, and the Funko Pop.
I will not stop until I get a Funko Pop.
But, it's gonna look really silly if you don't have the U2s figure.
Start it up.
Um...
But yes, the U2 figures has ten hours left before it's gone forever!
Uh...
So feel free to pre-order it before it's gone, gone, gone, gone, gone.
Um...
Is the Funko Pop confirmed?
No, but I will not stop until I get that Funko Pop so I can complete the Triforce, guys.
It's like, okay, you know like, um...
What was it?
What's that word called when people have like an Oscar, a BAFTA, a Tony... Oh my gosh, what is it called?
Um...
When you have an Oscar, BAFTA, Tony, uh...
EGOT!
Yes!
This is our EGOT!
So you know how celebrities who get, win like the EGOT, which is basically like an Emmy, Grammy, Oscar, and Tony award?
This is gonna be my EGOT.
So like, I'm gonna get like, it's called the Triforce because it means you get a figure for like, um...
for like every well-known figure play.
So like Funko Pop, U2s, and Nendoroid.
So we have like, so we gotta make sure, like, uh, yeah the Funko Pop will appear once you purchase the other two.
Yeah, the Holy Trinity .
.
So guys, we have to complete the collection.
Anyway guys, that was so fun!
I had a great time, uh, with Hiro and Ditto.
Um, we were really, really good together, all of us.
We were fragging the fuck out, uh, and um, I had an incredible time with them.
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm really tired.
We streamed five hours of Apex.
Um, so I'm gonna call it here.
My throat, it needs to rest now.
But, uh, thank you all for the, uh, gifted membership.
Thank you for the 20 gift-a-ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for all the Akkas.
Thank you all for the gift-a-ships.
Thank you all for the memberships.
Um...
Minecraft update.
I'm sorry if you guys haven't got whitelisted yet, uh, regarding the Minecraft server.
We're very slowly, like, getting through the whitelist.
Cause like, we're, uh, implementing a new chat system, uh, for the, for it in, uh, within a few days.
So within a few days we're gonna have a new chat system where you can chat within your factions, you can chat within a group, and you can chat global chat.
So there's like three diff- like, I'm not sure yet how many chats there's gonna be, but I asked them.
And!
Um, in the future, uh, we're gonna have a server made regarding the Minecraft server.
Um, and we're planning on hiring a full-on moderation team that handles just the server.
Uh, because it got a lot bigger than I expected it to be.
A lot of people are joining the Minecraft server.
Um...
And it's getting a lot bigger than I expected it.
So we're gonna have regular updates.
And, um, we're gonna have uh, donations to the server so that it goes straight to the Minecraft development team.
Um, so like, uh, cause we were talking about it because uh, you know, I use your superchats, your memberships to fund the Minecraft server.
But I figured it would be uh, why are you so- why MindTalk?
What do you mean, Ditto?
I am so nice.
I was so nice.
I'm not toxic, Ditto.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I was not toxic at all.
Anyway, anyway, um, so like, we're talking about like funding it because um, I put down payment for uh, for like a couple of uh, we're already using- we're almost used up all the payment regarding like server updates.
So we're talking about like future funding.
And like, I already used your guys like when your money goes towards like uh, future investments in the channel.
So I pitched an idea that like uh, for those who wanna fund the Minecraft server, we're gonna have a specific donation link that just goes straight to the Minecraft server.
Cause I was like- cause we were like, oh we're- at first they were like, well there's too many steps to it because they're gonna donate to you anyway.
So you- and you just pay us.
And then I was like, yeah, but they really wanna donate to the Minecraft server and they donate to me.
YouTube takes 30% of that.
So I might as well like, if they wanna go directly to the server itself and it goes towards the team, um, and it goes towards the team, towards the Minecraft server specifically, um, I told them to make a, uh, fund just for that.
And when we reach that fund, uh, and when we reach that fund, uh, you guys won't need to donate anymore.
And then it goes straight into development.
Like, uh, so they just grab the money from that fund.
The team- the Minecraft team will just grab the money from that fund and, uh, and just use that to improve more and more on the server.
And like more and more updates and everything.
Um, so, cause I was already funding the server, but I thought like, since like you guys are fun- like sending donations and super chats, uh, to me, and I put it towards the server, it just makes it more easier to just like have it directly to them instead of just YouTube taking 30% of the cut.
Um, but I already put a- I already put like a- I already put in my own money regarding like future improvements to the server, but after that, um, after that like we're planning on having a donation goal- not donation goal, but like just if you wanna provide more- if you wanna like fund for future updates on the server.
And when we hit that certain goal, we like cap it so that people don't like over-donate, you know?
And then the team just like grabs the funds to create more stuff.
And, um, and that's what we're doing for the server.
Uh, so yeah, I didn't realize how- how, like, like how much work I guess?
How much it was gonna grow into?
Cause like, I didn't realize there's so many people that was like so- like it was like- it was getting more- bigger.
It's actually turning into a real SMP.
So like I- I was not expecting that.
Like- I was not expecting it to like actually turn into like a real ass SMP thing.
So-
So we're- it's- it's like getting- growing more- it's like- it's growing more and more every day.
Um...
But yes, I really apologize uh, if you're not whitelisted yet.
We're handling it slowly because there's like a lot of other stuff we're dealing with at the moment.
So, um, and we're gonna try and- we're planning on streamlining the whitelist a little bit more in the future.
Uh...
Regarding the server stuff.
Uh, Discord server.
Also, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
My husband enjoys your Minecraft game and even- No!
I'm sorry!
That means you gotta join Minecraft 2.
You have to play Minecraft 2 so you can go on Minecraft Day.
It's on my server.
Alright.
I'm gonna head off now, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Mmm... Bye!